foreign
welcome to this devops tools full course
by simply learn
in this complete course we learn
everything that we need regarding
several devops tools
we have Matthews and chidanand to guide
us through this journey so let's look at
what's in store for us we shall begin
with having a basic understanding of
devops with a short animated video
after that we'll dive deeper and
understand the basics of devops like its
relevance in the current scenario and
several devops phases
once we know devops we shall begin with
learning different devops Tools in
detail
you shall learn about get followed by
GitHub
and in the process we shall learn about
various git commands
second we shall see what Jenkins is
Jenkins Pipeline and how we install
Jenkins
after that we'll move on to Docker and
check out what Docker is and Docker
container is all about
we'll also learn about the different
processes and how to install docker
moving further we'll understand the
basics of kubernetes the difference
between kubernetes and Docker and
kubernetes on AWS
the following tool in the list will be
puppet where we shall know what puppet
is and why we use puppet and the process
to install it
moving forward we'll learn about ansible
and its installation process and what
are the benefits of using ansible
the last tool on our list is selenium
where we shall learn about selenium and
all about its sweet tools followed by
its installation processes
while we're learning all these tools we
shall understand them with the Hands-On
demo making the understanding much more
effective and more accessible
finally when we have a piece of deep
knowledge regarding devops and several
devops tools we'll look at some of the
most prominent devops interview
questions that will help you excel in
your forthcoming devops interviews
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure you hit the Subscribe button and
the bell icon to never miss an update
so without further Ado let's begin right
from the start software development
comprise two different departments the
development team that develops the plan
designs and builds the system from
scratch and the operation team for
testing and implementation of whatever
is developed the operations team gave
the development team feedback on any
bugs that needed fixing and any rework
required invariably the development team
would be idle awaiting feedback from the
operations team this undoubtedly
extended timelines and delayed the
entire software development cycle there
would be instances where the development
team moves on to the next project while
the operations team continues to provide
feedback for the previous code this
meant weeks or even months for the
project to be closed and final code to
be developed now what if the two
departments came together and worked in
collaboration with each other what if
the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth though
there may be communication challenges
devops manages a streamlined flow
between the teams and makes the software
development process successful the
devops culture is implemented in several
phases with the help of several tools
let's have a look at these faces
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding Begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like git and merged when
required this process is called Version
Control the code is then made executable
with tools like Maven and Gradle in the
build stage
the code is successfully built it is
then tested for any bugs or errors the
most popular tool for automation testing
is selenium once the code is passed
several manual and automated tests we
can say that it is ready for deployment
and is sent to the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible Docker and kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase the feedback received after this
phase is sent back to the planning phase
and this is what forms the core of the
devops life cycle that is the
integration phase Jenkins is the tool
that sends the code for building and
testing if the code passes the test it
is sent for deployment and this is
referred to as continuous integration
there are many Tech Giants and
organizations that have opted for the
devops approach for example Amazon
Netflix Walmart Facebook and Adobe
Netflix introduced its online streaming
service in 2007. in 2014 it was
estimated that a downtime for about an
hour would cost Netflix two hundred
thousand dollars however now Netflix can
cope with such issues they opted for
devops in the most fantastic way Netflix
developed a tool called the Simeon Army
that continuously created bugs in the
environment without affecting the users
this chaos motivated the developers to
build a system that does not fall apart
when any such thing happens so on this
note here is a quiz for you match the
devops tool with the phase it is used in
a
B
C
d none of the above
today more and more companies lean
towards automation with the aim of
reducing its delivery time and the gap
between its development and operations
teams to attain all of these there's
just one Gateway devops and if you're
also looking forward to doing the same
and Excel in devops check out Simply
learn's postgraduate program in devops
design in collaboration with Caltech
ctme the program can help you master
several in-demand devops skills and
tools like continuous integration and
delivery devops on cloud kubernetes
Docker and much more
what do you think helped Netflix evolve
from Shipping DVDs to streaming video
over the web
or helped Amazon to predict how much
equipment to buy to meet traffic demands
how do you think NASA was able to
analyze data from the Mars rover
Curiosity
what would have made it possible for
Walmart to become the king of the big
box retailers and help Facebook refresh
its mobile app so rapidly
the answer to all these questions is
devops
the devops market generated 3.36 billion
dollars in 2017 and is expected to
generate 9.4 billion dollars by 2023.
devops is helping many organizations to
automate their entire process the
process allows any organization to
create and improve their products at a
faster Pace than traditional models so
now let's understand
what is devops
devops as the name suggests is a
combination of two practices Dev refers
to development and Ops refers to
operations
devops is not a workflow but a culture
that brings these two teams together the
development team writes codes for new
products security updates and Bug fixes
the operations team looks after the
servers and makes sure that the
deployments happen more reliably and
frequently
the main focus of devops is on
integrating these two teams in order to
improve collaboration and increase
productivity by automating the entire
process of software development
devops has several stages and tools to
ensure that all this process is
implemented in the best possible manner
let us have a look at all these stages
with the tools that play a significant
role in that phase
beginning with the development phase so
the first step is to put down a plan
that includes the modules and the
algorithms to be used in the software
and once the plan is finalized it is
developed with tools like git as git
helps in storing all the codes and
different versions of those codes this
is called the Version Control System
now this code is fetched and made
executable in the next stage that is the
build phase
this phase uses tools like Gradle and
maven
after the code is made executable it is
supposed to be tested the next stage
tests the code for any bugs and the most
popular tool used in this phase is
selenium
once the testing is done deployment
comes into consideration and this is
where the work of the operations team
begins in the deployment phase the
product is deployed and this deployed
product is continuously configured to
the desired State the tools that
automate these phases are ansible puppet
and docker the product from here is
continuously monitored for any failures
and the most common tool that makes it
possible is nagios
the feedback of all the monitoring is
sent back to the planning phase this
process is repeated in continuous Cycles
until we reach a satisfactory result
this completes the entire devops cycle
the process of automation from the
planning phase to the monitoring phase
this is what is referred to as the core
of devops lifecycle the integration
phase
Jenkins another devops tool is known for
sending the code for build and test and
if this code passes the test it is
further deployed and monitored
let us have a look at some features that
are making Industries move toward devops
increase customer satisfaction improve
response time
fewer chances of implementation failure
reduction in it cost
Better Business agility
higher employee productivity and
satisfaction
faster delivery better Release Control
frequent software releases better
collaboration among teams
automated server configuration
now when you know so much about devops
you must be curious to know what the
future of devops holds it is quite
evident that devops is on the rise and
it's going to have a long ahead there
are several fields that devops is going
to be explored in the near future every
organization has started leaning toward
automation so devops is going to play a
major role in new upcoming organizations
when everything moves toward automation
there will be a need for devops in the
security field
devops framework in Ai and ml will help
the devops team to focus on Innovation
and creativity by enabling them to
manage the amount and speed of data in a
more efficient way
devops focuses on infrastructure as code
which ensures continuity as all the
processes from building to staging are
configured automatically with no place
for human error
the future of devops will make the
culture more popular there is no
industry that does not want to shift
toward more reliability in deployment
every organization wishes to deliver
their product in shorter durations and
reduce the gap between its development
team and operations team
all these scenarios will take devops to
new heights in the near future there are
organizations that have shifted toward
devops and many are planning to do the
same hence the jobs in the market for
devops engineers are certainly going to
rise in the near future
so when are you planning to master
devops you can begin today with
simplylearn's devops certification
training course thank you for watching
and stay tuned to Simply learn hello
this is Matthew with simply learn and
today we're going to go through and
introduce you to devops I'm going to go
through a number of key elements today
the first two will be reviewing models
that you're already probably using for
delivering Solutions into your company
and the most popular one is waterfall
followed by agile then we'll look at
devops and how devops differs from the
two models and how it also borrows and
leverages the best of those models we'll
go through each of the phases that are
used in typical devops delivery and then
the tools used within those phases to
really improve the efficiencies within
devops finally we'll summarize the
advantages that devops brings to you and
your teams so let's go through waterfall
so waterfall is a tradition National
delivery model that's been used for many
decades for delivering Solutions not
just I.T Solutions and digital Solutions
but even way before that it has its
history it goes back to World War II so
waterfall is a model that is used to
capture requirements and then Cascade
each key deliverable through a series of
different stage Gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage Gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project plan
so you have an understanding of what the
level of work is needed to be able to be
successful in delivering the solution
after that you've got your plan then you
start doing the development and that
means that the program is to start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do UI testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks now the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage Gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your clients and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just going to see after you spend a lot
of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
chance you then have is if you want to
add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using the waterfall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback in quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the teams have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that Solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send requirements back to
the programmer with feedback this allows
us to create what we call a feedback
loop where we're able to get information
to the client and the client can get
back to the development team much faster
typically when we're actually going
through this process we're looking at
the engagement cycle being about two
weeks and so it's much faster than the
traditional waterfall approach and so we
can look at each feedback loop as
comprising of four key elements we have
the planning where we actually sit down
with the client and understand what
they're looking for we then have coding
and testing that is building out the
code and the solution that is needed for
the client and then we review with the
clients the changes that have happened
but we do all this in a much tighter
cycle that we call a Sprint and that
typically a Sprint will last for about
two weeks some companies run sprints
every week some run every four weeks
it's up to you as a team to decide how
long you want to actually run a Sprint
but typically it's two weeks and so
every two weeks the client is able to
provide feedback into that Loop and so
you were able to move quickly through
iterations and so if we get to the end
of Sprint 2 and the client says hey you
know what we need to make a change you
can make those changes quickly and
effectively for Sprint three what we
have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple Sprints but when you go through
the Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually Implement successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprints
again it's a two-week activity you meet
every single day the two with the actual
Sprint team to ensure that everybody is
staying on track and if there's any
blockers that those blockers are being
addressed effectively and immediately
the goal at the end of the two weeks is
to have a deliverable product that you
can put in front of the customer and the
customer can then do a review the key
advantages you have are running a Sprint
with agile is that the client
requirements are better understood
because the client is really integrated
into the scrum to team they're there all
the time and the product is delivered
much faster than with a traditional
waterfall model you're delivering
features at the end of each Sprint
versus waiting weeks months or in some
cases years for a waterfall project to
be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the Sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their Sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their Sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for the deployment and
then the operations team may submit
their work to the production servers but
what if there is an error what if there
was a setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an API that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these charges that the operations
team are constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works so this is where devops
really comes in and let's dig into how
devops which is developers and operators
working together is the key for
successful continuous delivery so devops
is as an evolution of the agile model
the agile model really is great for
Gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
Solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the Ops Team and the
dev team and so so with devops what
we're doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that is based on data so let's step
through the different phases of a devops
team so typically you'll see that the
devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
Agile and what I'd like to point out at
the time is that again agile and devops
are very closely related that agile and
devops are closely related delivery
models that you can use with devops it's
really just extending that model with
the key phases that we have here so
let's step through each of these key
phases so the first phase is planning
and this is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
Agile is that the code is actually start
coding but they typically they'll start
using tools such as git which is a
distributed Version Control software it
makes it easier for developers to all be
working on the same code base rather
than bits of the code that is rather
than them working on bits of the code
that they are responsible for so the
goal with using tools such as git is
that each developer always has the
current and latest version of the code
you then use tools such as Maven and
Gradle as a way to consistently build
out your environment and then we also
use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another Point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as ansible and Chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can just
zero in on spikes and issues that are
relevant to either the code or changing
consumer habits on the site so let's
step through some of those tools that we
have in the devops environment so here
we have is a breakdown of the devops
tools that we have and again one of the
things I want to point out is that these
tools are open source tools there are
also many other tools this is just
really a selection of some of the more
popular tools that are being used but
it's quite likely that you're already
using some of these tools today you may
already be using Jenkins you may already
be using git but some of the other tools
really help you create a fully
scriptable environment so that you can
actually start scripting out your entire
devops tool set this really helps when
it comes to speeding up your delivery
because the more you can actually script
out of the work that you're doing the
more effective you can be at running
automation against those scripts and the
more effective you can be at having a
consistent experience so let's step
through this devops process so we go
through and we have our continuous
delivery which is our plan code build
and test environment so what happens if
you want to make a release well the
first thing you want to do is send out
your files to the build environment and
you want to be able to test the code
that you've been created because we're
scripting everything in our code from
the actual unit testing being done to
the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production and environment if however
your code passes the the scripting test
it can then be deployed and once it's
out to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to Agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your Sprint Cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
Google Google any given day will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great video
those on YouTube that you can find out
on how their devops teams work Netflix
is also a similar environment now what's
interesting with Netflix is that Netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and Netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on Smart TVs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for Netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from Netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver a software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to Waterfall complexity of
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment now you're improving
the communication between all your teams
so teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted a very warm welcome to
all our viewers I'm Anjali from Simply
learn and today I'll be showing you the
installation for get on windows so we'll
start by downloading and installing it
on our system we'll then have a look at
the git bash interface we'll type in
some basic git commands next we'll
create a local repository that is we'll
create a repository on a local machine
we'll then connect to a remote
repository and finally we'll push the
file onto GitHub first things first we
need to download and install git so
download git for Windows and I'll select
the second link
so 2.19.1 which is the most latest
version of git that's the one we want
for Windows system choose your version
so mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while so
git is
on a system
click here run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path uh just so just click on in
quick launch and on desktop next next
again next nothing to change here either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash so let's just stick that and then
click on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master Branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version and as you can see version
2.19.1 on our Windows system which is
exactly what we just downloaded we'll
now explore the help command so let's
just type get help config so config is
another command and as I hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it so in case you have
any doubts regarding how a command is
used what a command is used for all the
various syntax of the command you can
always use the help command now this
another Syntax for using the help
command itself which is git config dash
dash help enter this does the exact same
thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir test now test is my
new directory I'll move into this
directory so CD test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so get init is the command for
initializing the directory and as you
can see as you can see the path here
this is the local path where a directory
is created so I'll just show you the
directory test and it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and I'll
just name this demo I'll open this and
just put in some dummy content so hello
simply learn
save this file and go back to your bash
interface let's just check the status
now so get status and as you can see our
file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is
we'll be adding demo to a current
directory the next command that we will
be applying is the commit command and
when you add certain files to the
current directory the commit command is
applied on all the above directories so
git commit minus M and a message that
will appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion I'll just clear the
screen next thing we need to do is we
need to link our git to our GitHub
account so the command for doing that is
git config Global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
GitHub account
so this is my GitHub profile and my
username is simply learn Dash GitHub so
guys before you begin this procedure
just make a GitHub account type in my
username here simply learn Dash GitHub
and enter and there you go a git is
successfully linked with GitHub next
thing we do is we'll just open our
GitHub and we'll create a new repository
give a repository name so I'll get name
it test underscore demo and create
Repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and a
local Repository
so git remote origin and then paste
the HTTP link and now that our local
repository and a remote repository are
linked we can push a local file onto a
remote repository so the command for
doing that is git push origin Master as
we are on the master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to GitHub I'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo thanks Anjali now Matthew and
shadanan will take you through the
remaining part of the course hello this
is Matthew from Simply learn and today
we're going to go through and explain
how you can use git for your software
development so what are we going to
cover today so we're going to introduce
the concept of Version Control that you
will use within your devops environment
then we'll talk about the different
tools are available in a distributed
Version Control System we'll highlight a
product called git which is typically
used for Version Control today and
you'll also go through what are the
differences between git and GitHub you
may have used GitHub in the past or
other products like gitlab and we'll
explain what are the differences between
git and git and services such as GitHub
and gitlab will break out out the
architecture of what a get process looks
like how do you go through and create
forks and clones how do you have
collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in get finally I'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run git
yourself and in this instance use the
software of git against a public service
such as GitHub all right let's talk a
little bit about Version Control Systems
so you may have already been using a
version control system within your
environment today you may have used
tools such as Microsoft's team
Foundation services but essentially the
use of a Version Control System allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
version Control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there would be an
addendum added to that so um there will
be the the version one changes that you
had then the person would then later on
check out that code and then be a
version two
um added to that code and so you keep
adding on versions of that code the
bottom line is that eventually you'll
have people being able to use your code
and that your code will be stored in a
centralized location however the
challenge you're running is that it's
very difficult for large groups to work
simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a VCS system a Version
Control System should demonstrate that
you're able to store multiple versions
of a solution in a single repository now
let's take a step at some of the
challenges that you have with
traditional Version Control Systems and
see how they can be addressed with
distributed Version Control so in a
distributed Version Control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed Version Control System
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed VCS server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software and appear to pay care-like
approach so that as changes are being
made into the server of changes to the
code then those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed VCS environment is
get now you may remember that we
actually covered get in a previous video
and we'll reference that video for you
so we start off with our remote get
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment that local environment can
be updated manually and then
periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you've made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so your git
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this this
allows you to be able to accomplish is
that each person will always have the
latest version of the code so what is
get get is a distributed Version Control
tool used for source code management so
GitHub is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
clients to that certain remote Hub
server now git is used to track the
changes of the source code and allows
large teams to work simultaneously with
each other it supports a non-linear
development because of thousands of
parallel branches and has the ability to
handle large projects efficiently so
let's talk a little bit about git versus
GitHub so get is a software tool whereas
GitHub is a service and I'll show you
how those two look in the moment you
install the software tool forget locally
on your system them whereas GitHub
because it is a service it's actually
hosted on a website git is actually the
software that used to manage different
versions of source code whereas GitHub
is used to have a copy of the local
repository stored on the service on the
website itself git provides command line
tools that allow you to interact with
your files whereas GitHub has a
graphical interface that allows you to
check in and check out files so let me
just show you the two tools here so here
I am at the get website and this is the
website you would go to to download the
latest version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do Version Control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
Hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with GitHub there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to GitHub gitlab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as Microsoft
Visual Studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of Visual Studio team Services
also provides this same ability but
GitHub it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where we can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to GitHub and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment I'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact I think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on GitHub at the moment that
number's probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project I would certainly encourage you
to start a GitHub to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open
source project that they want to share
that's already available
um in GitHub certainly if you're doing
anything with um Azure you'll find that
there are thousands 45
000 Azure projects currently being
worked on interestingly enough GitHub
was recently acquired by Microsoft and
Microsoft is fully embracing open source
Technologies so that's essentially the
difference between get and GitHub one is
a piece of software and that's get and
one is a service that supports the
ability of using the software and that's
GitHub so let's dig deeper into the
actual git architecture itself so the
working directory is the folder where
you are currently working on your get
its project and we'll do a demo later on
where you can actually see how we can
actually simulate each of these steps so
you start off with your working
directory where you store your files and
then you add your files to a staging
area where you are getting ready to
commit your files back to the main
branch on your git project you want to
push out all of your changes to a local
repository after you've made your
changes and these will commit those
files and get them ready for
synchronization with the service and
we'll then push your services out to the
remote repository an example of a remote
repository would be GitHub later when
you want to update your code before you
write any more code you would pull the
latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure the that Aid the code remains at
very high quality and B that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available and get so let's talk
about forking and cloning and kit so
both of these terms are quite old terms
when it comes to development but forking
is certainly a term that goes way way
back long before we had distributed CVS
systems such as the ones that we're
using with get to Fork a piece of
software is a particularly open source
project you would take the project and
create a copy of that project and but
then you would then associate a new team
and new people around that project so it
becomes a separate project in entire
charity a clone and this is important
when it comes to working with get a
clone is identical with the same teams
and same structuring as the main project
itself so when you download the code
you're downloading exact copy of that
code with all the same security and
access rights as the main code and then
you can then check that code back in and
potentially your code because it is
identical could potentially become the
mainline code in the future now that
typically doesn't happen your changes
are the ones that merge into the main
branch but also but you do have that
potential where your code could become
the main code with Git You can also add
collaborators that can work on the
project which is essential for projects
where particularly where you have large
teams and this works really well when
you have product teams where the teams
themselves are self-empowered you can do
a concept what's called branching and
get and so say for instance you are
working on a new feature that new
feature and the main version of the
project have to still work
simultaneously so what you can do is you
can create a branch of your code so you
can actually work on the new feature
whereas the rest of the team continue to
work on the main branch of the the
project itself and then later you can
merge the two together pull from remote
is the concept of being able to pull in
Services software the team's working on
from a remote server and git rebase is
the concept of being able to take a
project and re-establish a new start
from the project so you may be working a
project where there have been many
branches and the team has been working
for quite some time on different areas
and maybe you kind of losing control of
what the true main branch is you may
choose to rebase your project and what
that means though is that anybody that's
working on a separate Branch will not be
able to Branch their code back into the
mainline Branch so going through the
process of a get at rebase essentially
allows you to create a new start for
where you're working on your project so
let's go through forks and clones so you
want to go through the process so you
want to go ahead and Fork the code that
you're working on so this is this
scenario that one of your team wants to
go ahead and add a new change to the
project the team member may say yeah go
ahead and you know create a separate
Fork of the actual project so what does
that look like so when you actually go
ahead and create a fork of the
repository you actually go and you can
take the version of the mainline Branch
but then you take it completely offline
into a local repository for you to be
able to work from and you can take the
mainline code and you can then work on a
local version of the code separate from
the mainland Branch it's now a separate
Fork collaborators is the ability to
have team members working on a project
together so if you know if someone is
working on a piece of code and they see
some some errors in the code that you've
created none of us are perfect at
writing code I know I've certainly made
errors in my code it's great to have
other team members that have your bag
and can come in and check and see what
they can do to improve the code so to do
that you have to then add them as a
collaborator now you do that in GitHub
you can give them permission within
GitHub itself that's really easy to do
supervisual interface that allows you to
do the work quickly and easily and
depending on the type of permissions you
want to give them sometimes it could be
very limited permissions it may be just
to be able to read the files sometimes
it's being able to go in and make all
the changes you can go through all the
different permission settings on GitHub
to actually see what you can do but
you'll be able to make changes so that
people can actually have access to your
repository and then you as a team can
then start working together on the same
code let's step through branching and
git so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that Branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master Branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master Branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen show
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
there can be many branches in git so git
keeps you the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge them back in with
the main branch so let's talk a little
bit about that merge process so your
style starting with the master branch
which is the blue line here and then
here we have a separate parallel branch
which has the new features so if we're
to look at this process the base commit
of feature B is the branch f is what's
going to merge back into the master
branch and it has to be said there can
be so many Divergent branches but
eventually you want to have everything
merge back into the master Branch let's
step through git rebase so again we have
a similar situation where we have a
branch that's being worked in parallel
to the master branch and we want to do a
get rebase so we're at stage C and what
we've decided is that we want to reset
the project so that everything from here
on out with along the master branch is
the standard product however this means
that any work that's been done in
parallel as a separate Branch we'll be
adding in new features along this new
re-based environment now the benefit you
have by going through the rebase process
is that you're reducing the amount of
storage space that's required for when
you have so many branches it's a great
way to just reduce your total footprint
for your entire project so git rebase is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase it you unplug a branch and
re-plug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new Master Branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single Master Branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote Suppose there are two developers
working together on application the
concept of having a remote repository
allow allows the code to the two
developers will be actually then
checking in their code into a remote
repository that becomes a centralized
location for them to be able to store
their code it enables them to stay
updated on the recent changes to the
repository because they'll be able to
pull the latest changes from that remote
repository so that they are ensuring
that as developers are always working on
the latest code so you could pull any
changes that you have made to your
thought remote repository to your local
repository the command to be able to do
that is written here and we'll go
through a demo of how to actually do
that command in a little bit good news
is if there are no changes you'll get a
notification saying that you're already
up to date and if there is a change it
will merge those changes to your local
repository and you get a list of the
changes that have been made remotely so
let's step through some of the commands
that we have in git so git and it
initializes a local git repository on
your hard drive get ads one or more file
else to your staging area get commit
Dash M commit message is a commit
changes via git command commits changes
to head up to the git command commits
changes to your local staging area get
status checks the status of your current
repository and lists the files you have
changed get log provides a list of all
the commits made on your current Branch
get diff the user changes that you've
made to the file so you can actually
have files next to each other you can
actually see the differences between the
two files get push origin Branch name so
the name of your branch command will
push the branch to the remote repository
so that others can use it and this is
what you would do at the end of your
project git config Dash Global username
or tailgate Who You Are by configuring
the author name and we'll go through
that in a moment git config Global user
email will tell get the author of by the
email ID get clone creates a git
repository copy from a remote Source get
remote ad origin server connects the
local repository to the remote server
and adds the server to be able to push
to it git branch and then the branch
name will create a new Branch for you to
create a new feature that you may be
working on get checkout and then the
branch name will allow you to switch
from one branch to another Branch git
merge Branch name Will merge a branch
into the active Branch so if you're
working on a new feature you're going to
merge that into the main branch a get
rebase will reapply commits on top of
another base Tab and get rebase or
reapply commits on top of another base
tip and these are just some of the
popular git commands there are some more
but you can certainly dig into those as
you're working through using get so
let's go ahead and run a demo using get
so now we are going to do a demo using
get on our local machine and GitHub as
the remote repository for this to work
I'm going to be using a couple of tools
first I'll have the deck open as we've
been using up to this point the second
is I'm going to have my terminal window
also available and let me bring that
over so you can actually see this and
the terminal window is actually running
git bash as the software in the
background which you'll need to download
and install you can also run get batch
locally on your Windows computer as well
and in addition I'll also have the
GitHub repository that we're using for
simply learn and already set up and
ready to go all right so let's get
started so the first thing we want to do
is create a local repository so let's go
ahead and do exactly that so the local
repository is going to reside in my
development folder that I have on my
local computer and for me to be able to
do that I need to create a drive in that
folder so I'm going to go ahead and
change the directory so I'm actually
going to be in that folder before I
actually create and make the new folder
so I'm going to go ahead and change
directory
and now I'm in the development directory
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and let's go ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
I'm going to move my cursor so that I'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that I'm in the hello world
folder I can now initialize this folder
as a git Repository
so I'm going to use the get command init
to initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here I have my Hello
World folder that I've created and
you'll now see that we have a hidden
folder in there which is called dot get
and we expand that we can actually see
all of the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so that we
can see the rest of the work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users Matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt in our folder so
here is our hello world folder and I'm
going to go ahead and using my text
editor which happens to be Sublime
I'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in the text hello world
and I'm going to call this one
readme.txt
if I go to my Hello World folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt file
actually in the folder what's
interesting is if I select the get
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the get status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders haven't been
committed and what we can now do is we
can go and actually add the readme file
so let's go ahead I'm just going to say
at git add so the git command is ADD
[Music]
readme.txt so that then adds that file
into our main project and we want to
then commit those files into the main
repositories history and so it's that do
that we'll hit the get command commit
and we'll do a mess message in that
commit and this one would be
first commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and I can change this so we
can go hello get
is a very popular
Version Control solution
and we'll
we'll save that now what we can do is we
can actually go and see if we have made
differences to the readme text so to do
that we'll use the disk command forget
so we do get
Dave
and it gives us two releases the first
is what the original text was which is
hello world and then what we have
afterwards is what is now the new text
in green which has replaced the original
text
so what we're going to do now is uh you
want to go ahead and create an account
on GitHub we already have one so what
we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from GitHub with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do Dash and it's
going to be a
globaluser.name and we'll put in our
username that we use for GitHub and this
instance we're using the simply learn
Dash
GitHub account name
and under the GitHub account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we call the repository
hello dash world
and what we want to do is connect the
local GitHub account with the remote
hello world.get account and we do that
by using this command from get which is
our remote connection and so let's go
ahead and type that in open this up so
we can see the whole thing so we can
type in git remote add origin https
backstage by search
GitHub
.com slash
simply learn
Dash GitHub and you have to get this
typed in correctly when you're typing in
the location hello dash world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the git push command commit git push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote GitHub so I'm just
going to bring up my terminal window
again and so let's select get remote add
Origins
and we'll connect to the remote location
github.com slash
simply learn
Dash GitHub
slash
hello dash world dot get
oh we actually have already connected so
we're connected to that successfully and
now we're going to push the master Gish
to get
push origin
master
and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to GitHub now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and Fork a project from GitHub and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the fork tool that's actually available
on GitHub let me show you where that is
located and here is our branching tool
it's actually changed more recently with
a new UI interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy of that to our account using
the forks new HTTP URL address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
Fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now I'm
actually logged in with the default
primary count for this project so I
can't actually Fork a project as I'm
working on the main branch however if I
come in with a separate ID and here I am
I have a different ID and so I'm
actually pretending I'm somebody else I
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
created the fork
so you want to say clone or download
with this and so this is the I select
they'll actually give me the web address
I can actually show you what that looks
like I'll open up my text editor
that's the correct
I guess that is correct
so I'm going to copy that
and
I can Fork the project locally and clone
it locally I can change the directory so
I can create a new directory that I'm
going to put my files in and then post
in that content into that file so I can
now actually have multiple versions of
the same code running on my computer
I can then go into default content and
use the patchwork command
so I can create a copy of that code that
we've just created in the college that's
a clone and we can create a new folder
that we're actually putting the work in
and we could for whatever reason we
wanted to we could call this where
folder Patchwork and that would be maybe
a new feature and then we can then paste
in the URL of the new directory that has
the forked work in it and now at this
point we've now pulled in and created a
clone of the original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
Fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then develop
our work separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in that separate
branch
and so we want to check out um the the
branch and then push the origin Branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to GitHub and we
can actually come in and add in our
collaborators
and we'll do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
GitHub name or by email address
or by their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes and merge it into the
master Branch now to do that you would
create a folder and then that folder in
this instance would be called test we
would then move our cursor into the
folder called test and then initialize
that folder so let's go ahead and do
that so let's call create a new folder
and we're going to first of all change
our root folder and we're going to go to
development
I'm going to create a new folder
call it test and we're going to move
into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
because one test one
and then when we do file save as and
this one's going to be test
two
and now we're going to commit those
files
and
git add and then we'll use the dot to
pull in all files
and then git commit
m
files
it
make sure I'm in the right folder here I
don't think I was
and now that I'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and get commit
and it's gone ahead and added those
files and so we can see the two files
that were created have been added into
the master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
Branch we call this one get branch
test underscore
branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file three
into file save as we'll call this one
test three dot text
and we'll go ahead and add
that file and just to get add
test three Dot txt
and we're going to move from the master
Branch to the test round branch
okay
check
out test underscore
branch
I switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the tech in that
Branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do git merge test underscore
branch
and it's well we've already updated
everything so that's good so otherwise
it would tell us what we would be
merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all my merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from Master Branch to test branch
so get
check out
test underscore branch
and we can modify the files the test3
file that we took out
and pull that file up
and we can
now modify
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in and we've actually been able to then
commit the file with one changes and now
we've seen as the text free change that
was made
now we can now go through a process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
the workers kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future so let's switch to it by to our
test branch which I think we're actually
on we're going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
four
and
five
and so we now have additional files
and we're going to add those into our
branch that we're working on so we're
going to go and let's say get add Dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit Dash a dash m
adding
two new files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch them to our Master
Branch we want to rebase the master
so we do git rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date
and we can go
get
check out
Master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then continue
through and rebase the test branch and
then list all the files that are all in
the same area
so let's go get rebase
test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
hello and welcome to git commands my
name is chidanand and I am with the
simply learn team today I'm going to
cover a few essential git commands and
walk you through a demonstration for
most of it I begin by installing a git
bash or the git client and configuring
it for its first time usage once I'm
done with configuring the git client I'm
going to spin up few repositories
locally and work on these repositories
using git commands once I'm happy with
my local changes I'm going to commit few
of them and then push these changes to a
git server of my choice for today's
demonstration I plan to use github.com
which is a cloud hosted free service and
it provides free account registrations
for anyone eventually I will cover few
topics regarding git branching and
merging because these two in my opinion
are the killer features of the get
distributed Version Control tool kit is
one of the most popular distributed
Version Control tools of recent times
and like any other distributed Version
Control tool it allows us to perform
various Version Control tasks without
really needing a network connection
before I jump into my demonstration let
me spend some time explaining to you the
git client server working model what
does it take for a couple of users to
collaborate and start working with Git
the bare minimal thing that any user
would need in order to start working
with Git is something called as git bash
or the git client this comes as an
installer for all popular operating
systems like Windows all flavors of
Windows Linux Mac OS and other operating
systems so once you install git bash you
get a command line utility using which
you can fire up your git commands and
ensure that you can bring up
repositories you can work with these
repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and and you can work with your
repository using this git bash but what
does it take for you to share this
repository with another user who has
also got git bash installed on his
system this is where you would need
something called as a git server so for
user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
Market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with a
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that I can think of are
GitHub which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an Enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this GitHub Enterprise
servers wherein they buy this servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is bitbucket this is from
the famous atlasian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlasian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this Runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and gitlab also
provides you with a Community Edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what I'm
going to do is I've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and I'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that I'm gonna put up on
this server is all public by default so
I will register Myself by using my
username or my email ID and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication so
in order for me to share my repository
with say user 2. the first thing that I
got to do is have an access to a git
server where both user 1 and user 2 are
set up so once I have that I can push my
repository onto this server and provide
right kind of access so that user 2 or
the other developer whoever wishes to
collaborate with me on this repository
can use his credentials as long as is
registered properly on the git server he
can use his credentials and pull down
this repository and work with this
repository so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as SSH Authentication as many
of you would know SSH means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while I
create a keys I will be asked for a
passphrase I need to type in a
passphrase and remember passphrase and
then I take this public key and kind of
post it on to my account within my git
server so that whenever I'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as I remember my passphrase correctly I
can authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and SSH are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my GitHub credential to
connect to my GitHub server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that I can go ahead
and install it so I just type in git
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that I
find is a GUI tool I don't need this GUI
client I need this one so this is a git
client or the git bash that I was
referring to it's about 40 Megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
complete when I'm recording this video
the version that I have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0 and this
is a 64-bit version for Windows so I've
got that downloaded let me go ahead and
find it and install this EXE
all right I go ahead choosing all the
default options I want it to be
installed in SQL and program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me I'm not going to make any changes
here
get Bash from Windows yes I may want to
use git from Windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open SSH that's fine
next card looks good no I don't want any
of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that I can
start using my git commands
and the portion that I'm using is
2.19.0 which as I record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say again
launch git Bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good it's a Git
Version it sounds good it's a git help
all right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so I ended up
installing the git bash I can go ahead
with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure It For
the First Time stating what would be the
username and the email ID with which I
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iPhone Global which means that
this setting that I'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case I am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen iPhone Global this is
also Global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email ID need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email ID that
I would be setting up it to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you are placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so I will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo so this would be a
folder so I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo
and let me
get into the syllable all right as of
now this is just an empty folder
if at all I navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do I create a repository of
this is pretty simple I just run and get
init command
when I say get init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing in it was
an empty repository so it initialized an
empty repository in this particular
folder for all I look at my content you
would see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I've
configured my Explorer to view all
hidden folders I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit init
if I get into this folder I see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and this info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say git in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
Branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
Master within braces this doesn't mean
anything else other than we have a
repository out in this particular folder
and by default there is a branch called
master and we are currently on that
Branch if at all I create multiple
branches in this folder whenever I
navigate to different branches the
branch name within this brackets would
change all right so far so good so we
created a folder we made it a git
repository by initializing that with the
git in it and then I have not put
anything yet in the repository so let me
try to do that let me create a few files
within this particular repository so I
use a touch command touch is a Linux
command it kind of creates this
particular folder if all you're not
comfortable with the file creation by
this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so I create a file called touch
master.txt and open up in the notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what I'm going to write inside this
I save this and I come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this set tell you there's
no commit set you're in the master
Branch there is an untracked file and
this shows up in red it also gives you
all the command that is supposed to be
run so if at all you want to add this
file you would say git add and the name
of the file and then you're going to
commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it says there's no commit yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master.txt all right it
also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstage or undo your changes so what has
happened is the file which was earlier
untracked has been added into the git
index or it is ready for staging or it's
in a staged State now I can go ahead and
commit this file if at all that's what I
want to do so let me do that
I'll do a kit commit minus M and I give
a message that I want I would say this
is my first get commit
all right I run the get status command
again and see it says on the branch
Master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created a empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if it were I run the git log
command
it says this was the commit ID or the
commit number or the commit hashtag and
this is the author if you notice this is
the email ID and the username that we
set earlier and this was done on this
date and this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so I will touch
Master One Dot text I'll put in another
file
I'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right I save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what I did I modified the
older file that existed I also added a
new file to my repository now if I run
the get status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
I want to
incorporate I would say git add dot I
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and Commit This so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if I do git log now it shows both the
commits the first commit is the one that
that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice I'm doing all these git commands
without really connecting it to any git
server I don't need any network
connection for doing any of these things
I can keep on doing more and more git
commands and run git commands the way I
want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server now that I have my
changes the way I wanted and I've
checked in all the code changes into my
local repository I may want to share my
repository with somebody else and work
in a collaborative way so the way to do
that is as I mentioned earlier to host
this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server I already
have a GitHub account wherein I've
registered myself using my username and
password so I log into my GitHub account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
Repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is his first repo
so let me copy this I would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it will go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
get Hub Repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up and if you notice
I can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just a
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go
ahead and click on the create repository
button
so if you notice
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
URL which is nothing but the placeholder
that I've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the URL looks good I am all set
I've got two commits in my repository
I'm done with all the changes so let me
try to push my repository onto the
server the command for doing it for the
first time is git push hyphen U this is
for linking the Upstream
origin master
so git push hyphen U Upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to An Origin
and the origin points to this URL all
right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my GitHub server so let me just
copy and paste
the username and the password with which
I have registered
I would say login
okay success so I'm able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called Master it is linked the
master Branch from the local repository
with the master branch on the server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text fit all I see
the comments they seem to be two commits
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
I added these lines
I made this you know one line chain that
was there I also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the Commit This is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually commented the code in the
client the pushing is just after we have
committed the change we have pushed it
so there's no time stamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein I create a repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
Skeleton on the server now let me
demonstrate to you the SSH configuration
that is required for creating a pair of
SSH keys and ensuring that I connect to
the GitHub server using the SSH
mechanism so for doing that I need to
First create a pair of private and
public key the command to do that is SSH
Keygen
hyphen T I will use the RSA mechanism
for creating my keys Capital C and I
need to specify the email ID using which
I'm going to connect to all right I need
to create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should I create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a DOT SSH folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that I would need to
remember my passphrase because when I'm
going to authenticate myself using SSH
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase I need to enter
the right passphrase so that I get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in
on the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I have
logged in to GitHub using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or gpg keys so I would click
on new SSH key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say add SSH key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
I've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my SSH keys are working well
so I do SSH hyphen capital T I would say
get
at github.com
this is just to double check if my SSH
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now a check for my passphrase
let me enter my passphrase I hope I
remember it correctly
all right
triggered I've been successfully
authenticated so that means now my SSH
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase I can connect to my GitHub
server using SSH all right so for the
Second Use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I will
create a new Repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the GitHub server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time I am
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server all right I say
created Repository
So Random readme file with some content
in it gets created and I can see there
are two URLs to this repository https
and SSH so this time let me copy the SSH
URL so that I will use this URL to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that I
created on the server the command to do
that is git clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone
oops looks like I didn't copy the URL
correctly let me copy that again
copy this URL
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it I'm just cloning the URL
that is SSH URL of the Repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so I just had first deposited earlier
now I have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if I get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here I would say
Notepad
second dot text some text file I'm going
to put in here yes definitely you will
not find that file there
this is my second
file that
I will push onto the server
I'm going to put in some content out
there
and save this
and if I do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file you want to add this file onto the
repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
I'm giving some particular message
and this time around since I cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why I had to set
up the Upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more I'll
then push the content I'll just say get
push to be in the safer side I would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it posts the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here okay wonderful I had only
one commit now I see my second comment
so what was added as a part of the
second comment it says a new file was
added all this line that never existed
got added this is the second file the
content exactly what I pushed onto the
server
now this completes the tutorial when I
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now get init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master Branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen M with a
meaningful message this will commit all
the work items that you have done in
terms of the files that got changed the
more files that got added all this with
one particular message get status will
give you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all the status of the files will
be obtained using the git status command
git log will show you all the commit
history with the latest history or the
latest commit showing up on top git add
remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen U origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server over git clone and the URL of
the server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify or change some of the
files that they recently committed or
checked into the repository now from a
perspective of get this is a very very
simple activity however from a
perspective Version Control tool you
will have to be really cautious about
the chain that you're gonna do in case
the changes are pretty local none of the
developers or none of the other users
who are collaborating with you would be
affected by this change you are good to
go ahead and make this change however if
your repository has been pushed to the
server and you're trying to modify
something from history this would have a
very bad or adverse effect on all the
other users who will be using it you
need to be really cautious while running
these commands in case your repository
contents are local you've not pushed
your changes to your repository and if
at all you made some changes to the
repository maybe to fix a defect or to
include a new feature and you may few
things you can go over and modify this
with some of these commands let's say I
have this simple repository called undo
undo repo and if at all I look at the
logs of these I have the commit
histories which are like this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in C1 I've added a
file in C2 I add another file in C3 I've
also added some file in C4 I made some
changes to M1 and M3 and in C5 I have
added another file called M4 now this is
my commit history now let's say I made
these two commits but possibly I want to
Club them together along with some other
changes because whatever changes I did
did not really fix things the way I
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all I need to go back in history
and go back to this particular comment
and however I just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but I want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist I would do
command called get reset hyphen iPhone
soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two commits would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen iPhone soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the comment that I
want to get back to I just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all I do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is 7 C2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to C5 it's gone back
to C3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of C4 and C5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of C4 was
some changes to M1 and M2 and C5 a new
file got M4 got added if I do a git
status
you would see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history C3 is the topmost comment
that exists as of now c4 and C5 have
been currently read off but the changes
that were there still exist
all right now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.text
and say one new file that was missed out
C1 C2 C3 still existed and whatever was
a part of C4 and C5 the older ones I
have gotten rid of this along with those
old changes I also added a new file I
made some changes and I was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
to this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what I talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and is not
being pushed to the repository take this
scenario wherein let's say I have a git
server
and I have the changes which are C1
C2
C3
and possibly C4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer 1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got C1 to
C4 on his history
I'm going to jump all these C2 and C3
and get into C4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here and there are a
bunch of people from the server who has
pulled this repository and all of them
are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer
won then figures out that by mistake he
put in the C3 which is a wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the C3 or C4 or any one of these
comments
if he's gonna do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from C4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so in short never go back in
history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
comment to undo something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of C3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C5
and what does this commit to this commit
possibly gets rid of the C3 instead of
going back in history it actually is
taking your git history ahead but as a
part of this commit you are undoing some
part of the work that was done as a part
of C3
in short you're removing a comment but
to remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are you're using this
repository collaboratively and what plan
to get ahead in terms of History they
cannot afford to go back in history and
modify something in history all right
the command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all I do a git log
pretty one nine
I have these bunch of comments
and C1 I've added a file in C2 our other
file in C3 I've added one more file and
in C4 I made some changes and this is
the latest commit and this is the oldest
commit so if at all I see the contents
of the git folder it contains M1 m2m3
and M4 and let's say looking at the
previous use case that I mentioned I may
want to get rid of this particular
comment
I want to get rid of the C3 which is
nothing but I've added a file called
m3.text but I added it by mistake I need
a better way of fixing it possibly I
look at it later on but for now I don't
want this particular commit and the
changes that were made as a part of that
commit to exist so the better way to do
that is using the git revert command so
git revert and the commit ID whatever I
want to revert so if I want to revert
this
I copy this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit reward at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert
face this
essentially what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while I'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new comment and
a part of this new commit It undoes
Whatever changes that were done as a
part of this command so if I say git
revert this
all right I forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me I say write and quit
all right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this C1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from C5 I see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
comment actually is getting rid of this
commit C3 so if at all I see my files
here there's only M1 M2 and M4
M3 was added as a part of C3 now I've
gotten rid of M3 by getting rid of the
revert command for C3 so this is a
better way of undoing things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into very very interesting topic
regarding git which is about branching
the topic is interesting because git
deals with branches in a completely
different way compared to any other
version control tool in most of the
Version Control tools whenever you
create a new Branch a complete copy or a
subset of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it's a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space however in
get you just create a very very
lightweight movable pointer whenever you
create a branch there is no folder or no
copy of the repository that is created
in short the branches are very very
inexpensive and great so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then I'm going to
create a new folder here
I'll create a folder called Arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right I navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
initial as a repository a DOT git folder
is created without any files in it so
let me create a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
I create a name.txt within this maybe
I'll create one more file in this
Notepad
employees dot text
foreign
just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if I try to get status I just see two
files in it so let me go ahead and add
these two files and let me commit my
changes it's okay
commit hyphen am or iPhone m
First Command
so if I do a gig log
I see only one commit and there are two
files here you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get Branch name of the branch so let
me name my branches Bangalore Branch blr
branch
and this created a branch but I don't
see any changes in the folder structure
or in the file that exists here I've
just created this Branch so if it all I
do a git branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
Branch so let me go ahead and get into
the blr branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same there's absolutely no change in
any of the branches both master and
Baylor Branch point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is git checkout
plr Branch now actually switched into
Bangalore Branch if you see the content
of the files this exactly two files the
way it was earlier because I've created
a branch from my base branch which is
the master branch and when I created a
branch there were two files existing
here if you see the content of these
files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a file that
is specific to Bangalore branch so I
will just say Notepad
maybe I want to put down the address of
this organization specific to Bangalore
in this address dot text so I see
notepad address dot text
we'll say simply learn
Bangor office
say located in
some address
I would say Bangalore
foreign of this file
and I'm creating all this new file in
this blr Branch so I would sync it add
Dot
and I would say git
commit hyphen m
angalore
branch
comment
all right if you see this now I have an
address dot text which is there only in
the Bangalore branch that I'm presently
on now let me switch back to my master
Branch the command to do that is git
checkout
Master Branch if you remember when I
forged out or when I created a new
Branch from the master Branch I didn't
have this address dot text in it so let
me go back to git git checkout Master
branch and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address dot text
it kind of disappeared how did that
happen it's all because of this magical
git folder so what happened is now git
knows that when you are in the master
Branch the file that was there in the
Bangalore branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if I come back let's
say I come back to git checkout
Bangalore branch
if you see this the address dot text
file appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever I am switching to Bangalore
Branch I see this address dot text when
I go back to my master Branch I don't
say this Bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that I created this Branch
maybe I may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new Repository
all right this
is the name of the Repository get Branch
demo this is what I'm going to put in as
a description I would say public I don't
want any readme files in it because I
already have a repository I will just
say create a repository
all right let me use
the SSH URL yeah this is this is a URL
this is good for me so let me copy this
URL
let me add it here
I'm linking my local repository with the
server and I would let me come back to
my master branch
let me first push my master Branch so I
would say git push hyphen U origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
push my master Branch it looks good it
says New Branch Master is created so if
I go back to my server and it will
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git Branch command now
this Branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new Branch onto
the server so the command would be
get push hyphen new origin and the name
of the brand that I want to specifically
push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if we get into this Bangalore Branch I
will see the address dot text if it will
I go back into Master Branch I would not
see this as a stock text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the brands that I
created back into the master branch that
is what I would mean by merging I would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangle Branch to come back into
my master Branch so if I go to click
checkout
Bangalore Branch I see this address DOT
type this is there only as a part of
Bangalore Branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Bangalore
Branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merging the changes is
get merge so what is that you want to
merge I want to merge the Bangalore
Branch changes and where will it merge
it will merge it into the current brands
that I'm on presently I'm in the master
Branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bangalore Branch into
your master Branch so with this if we'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
Bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
would see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
all right so there's only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
Bangalore Branch commit which was there
as a part of the Bangalore Branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well git push
origin master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all I do a refresh out here
okay I mean two branches
apprentice's Master even if I'm in
master plans I should see this address
dot text that is there even if I'm in
the Bangalore Branch the content is all
same because we immersed these two
branches now that I've merged this
Branch I don't need this Branch anymore
so I would go ahead and delete this
locally as well as push it onto the
server so that it gets deleted from the
server as well so delete Branch locally
the command is get
Branch hyphen D and the name of the
branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
I would say gate brands and I'm
presently in the master Branch so I can
go ahead and delete the other Branch so
get Branch hyphen D Bangalore branch
all right this got rid of our Pandora
Branch locally
if at all I don't get Branch hyphen V it
shows there's only one branch as of now
however this Branch would still exist on
the server because Server doesn't know
anything about the changes that we have
done we need to specifically push our
changes onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iPhone delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as I said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive in it go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular Branch to summarize the
git branching commands are as follows to
create a new Branch you issue a command
git Branch the name of the branch and
this would automatically spin off or
create a new Branch from the existing
Branch from where you issue this command
if you are on the master branch and if
you execute this command get Branch new
underscore Branch it creates a new
underscore Branch from the master Branch
once you create a new branch in order to
get into this Branch you would type in
git check out the name of the brand
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific Branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command get
push hyphen U origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new Branch are pushed
onto this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git Branch hyphen AV assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master Branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
Branch into a master Branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you're on the master branch and
if you issue a command git merge new
underscore Branch this would merge the
contents of the new Branch onto the
master Branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this Branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get Branch
hyphen capital D and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this Branch from the server
the command to do that is git push
origin hyphen iPhone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
brands that you created on the server
hello this is Matthew from Simply learn
and today we're going to Deep dive into
what Jenkins is and how it improves your
devops continuous integration
environments so this is what we're going
to be covering in this session we're
going to cover what life is like before
using Jenkins and the issues that
Jenkins specifically addresses then
we'll get into what Jenkins is about and
how it applies to continuous integration
and the other continuous integration
tools that you need in your devops team
then specifically we'll Deep dive into
features of Jenkins and the Jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using Jenkins
today to actually transform how their it
organization is operating so let's talk
a little bit about life before Jenkins
let's see this scenario I think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits are actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent you as
a developer may be based in India you
may have another developer that's based
in the Philippines and you may have
another team lead that's based in the UK
and another development team that's
based in North America so you're all
working at different times and you have
different amounts of code going into the
code repository There's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we'd like to call
development how where things just aren't
working out and there's just lots of
delays being added into the project and
the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested and
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project the actual
process of delivering software was slow
there was no way that you could actually
iterate on your software and you just
ended up with just a big headache with
teams pointing fingers at each other and
blaming each other so let's jump into
Jenkins and see what Jenkins is and how
it can address these problems so Jenkins
is a product that comes out of the
concept of continuous integration that
you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code Jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment so there
are two ways in which you can do
continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous so
the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
Legacy approach to building out
Solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly bill and the way
that our 90 builds would work and
operate is that as code developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day that was consistent
around the world that we would put our
codes into a single repository and at
night all of that code would be run and
operated and tested to see if there were
any changes and a new build would be
created and that would be referred to as
the nightly build with continuous
integration we're able to go one step
further we're able to not only commit
our changes into our source code but we
can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in an arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification Services into the build
environment so you're always running
Cycles to test against your code this is
the power that Jenkins provides in
continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the content accept of continuous
integration is that as a developer
you're able to pull from a repository
the code that you're working on and then
you'll be able to then at any time
submit the code that you're working on
into a continuous integration server and
the goal of that continuous integration
server is that it actually goes ahead
and validates and passes any tests that
a tester may have created now if on the
continuous integration server a test is
a pass then that code gets sent back to
the developer and the developer can then
make their changes it allows the
developer to actually do a couple of
things it allows the developer not to
break the build and we all don't want to
break the builds that are being created
but it also allows the developer not to
actually have to run all the tests
locally on their computer write tests
particularly if you have a large number
of tests can take up a lot of time so if
you can push that service up to another
environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be Beyond just the standard CI test
so maybe there's a Code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it's
simply just works
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the tools that you may have in your
continuous integration environment so
the cool thing with working with
continuous integration tools is that
they are all open source at least the
ones that we have listed here are open
source there are some that are private
but typically you'll get started with
open source tools and it gives you the
opportunity to understand how you can
accelerate your environment quickly so
bamboo is a continuous integration tool
that specifically runs multiple builds
in parallel for faster compilation so if
you have multiple versions of your
software that runs on multiple platforms
this is a tool that really allows you to
get that up and running super fast so
that your teams can actually test how
those different builds would work for
different environments and this has
integration with and and Maven and other
similar tools so one of the tools you're
going to need is a tool that allows you
to automate the software build test and
release process and buildbot is that
open source product for you again it's
an open source tool so there's no
license associated with this so you can
actually go in and you can actually get
the environment up and running and you
can then test for and build your
environment and create your releases
very quickly so buildbot's also written
in Python and it does support power
execution jobs across multiple platforms
if you're working specifically on Java
projects that need to be built and test
then Apache Gump is the tool for you it
makes all of those projects really easy
it makes all the Java projects easier
for you to be able to test with API
level and functionality level testing so
one of the popular places to actually
store code and create a versioning of
your code is GitHub and it's a service
that's available on the web just
recently acquired by Microsoft if you
are storing your projects in GitHub then
you'll be able to use Travis continuous
integration or Travis CI and it's a tool
design specifically for hosted GitHub
projects and so finally we're covering
Jenkins and Jenkins is a central tool
for automation for all of your projects
now when you're working with Jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called Hudson Hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became Jenkins and it was
acquired by Oracle when that acquisition
happens the team behind
um Hudson was a little concerned about
the direction that Oracle May
potentially go with Hudson and so they
created a hard Fork of Hudson that they
renamed Jenkins and Jenkins has now
become that open source product it is
one of the most popular and continuously
contributed projects that's available as
open source so you're always getting new
features being added to it it's a tool
that really becomes the center for your
CI environment so let's jump into some
of those really great features that are
available available in Jenkins so
Jenkins itself is really comprised of
five key areas around easy installation
easy configuration plugins extensibility
and distribution so as I mentioned for
the easy installation Jenkins is a
self-contained Java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including Windows Mac
OS and Unix you can even run it on Linux
it really isn't too bad to set up it
used to be much harder than it is today
the setup process has really improved
the web interface makes it really easy
for you to check for any errors in
addition you have great built-in help
one of the things that makes tools like
Jenkins really powerful for developers
and consumers integration teams in your
devops teams as a whole when you have
plugins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product Jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
Center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly checking out
there's just lots of stuff out there in
addition to the plugin architecture
Jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure Jenkins to fit in your
environment it's almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending Jenkins not creating a
custom version of Jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
Foundation remains as the court Jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of Jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of Jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core Foundation the
distribution and the nature of Jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your CI environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops so let's
jump into the standard Jenkins pipeline
so when you're doing development you
start off and you're coding away on your
computer the first thing you have to do
when you're working in the Jenkins
pipeline is to actually commit your code
now as a developer this is something
that you're already doing or at least
you should be doing you're committing
your code to a git server or to an SVN
server or a similar type of service so
in this instance you'll be using Jenkins
as the place for you to commit your code
Jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that Jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the Jenkins environment assuming
everything past the the tests you can
then get everything placed in a stage
and release ready environment within
Jenkins and and finally getting ready to
deploy or deliver your code to a
production environment Jenkins is going
to be the tool that helps you with your
server environment to be able to deploy
your code to the production environment
and the result is that you're able to
move from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your codes or
going through a nightly build you're
looking at being able to commit your
code and go through this testing process
and release process continuously as an
example companies Etsy will release up
to 50 different versions of their
website every single day
so let's talk about the architecture
within Jenkins it allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections so on the left hand
side of section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then Jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and we'll
run tests against it it'll use a build
service such as MAV into actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that Jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that feedback is sent right
back to the developers so that they can
then change their code so that the build
environment can run effectively the
final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
scripts can be written in selenium amp
so it's probably good to mention here
that both mavin and selenium are plugins
that run in the Jenkins environment so
before we were talking about how Jenkins
can be extended with plugins mavin and
selenium are just two very popular
examples of how you can extend the
Jenkins environment the goal to go
through this whole process again it's an
automated process is to get your code
from the developer to the production
server as quickly as possible have it
fully tested and have no errors so it's
probably important at this point to
mention uh one piece of information
around the Jenkins environment that if
you have different code builds that need
to be managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed Jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of Jenkins for that to be able
to happen so let's talk a little bit
about the Master Slave architecture
within Jenkins so what we have here is
an overview of the Master Slave
architecture within Jenkins on the left
hand side is the remote source code
repository and that remote source code
repository could be GitHub or it could
be a team Foundation services or the new
Azure devops code repository or it could
be your own get repository the Jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that Master
environment can then push out to
multiple other Jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so Jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server Master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used Jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario and over
the last 10 or 15 years there has been a
significant shift within the automotive
industry where manufacturers have
shifted from creating complex Hardware
to actually creating software we've seen
that with companies such as Tesla where
they are creating a software to manage
their cars we see the same thing with
companies such as General Motors with
their OnStar program and Ford just
recently have rebranded themselves as a
technology company rather than just a
automotive company what this means
though is that the software within these
cars is becoming more complex and
requires more testing to allow more
capabilities and enhancements to be
added to the core software so Bosch is a
company that specifically ran into this
problem and their challenge was that
they wanted to be able to streamline the
increase increasingly complex Automotive
software by adopting continuous
integration and continuous delivery best
practices with the goal of being able to
delight and exceed the customer
expectations of the end user so Bosch
has actually used Cloud bees which is
the Enterprise Jenkins environment so to
be able to reduce the number of manual
steps such as building deploying and
testing Bosch has introduced the use of
cloud bees from Jenkins and this is part
of the Enterprise Jenkins platform it
has significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software developments cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because Jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment now the results have been
tangible previously it took three days
before a build process could be done and
now it's taken that same three-day
process and reduced it to less than
three hours that is significant
large-scale deployments are now kept on
track and have expert support and there
is clear visibility and transparency
across the whole operations through
using the Jenkins tools hello and
welcome to continuous integration
tutorial using Jenkins my name is
chidanand and I am with the simply learn
team today let's get started with
Jenkins Jenkins in my opinion is one of
the most popular continuous integration
servers of recent times what began as a
hobby project by a developer working for
Sun Microsystems way back in early or
mid-2000s has gradually and eventually
evolved into a very very powerful and
robust automation servers it has a wide
adoption since it is released under MIT
license and is almost free to use
Jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
Jenkins because using plugins one can
connect Jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun with that
introduction let's get into what all
will be covered as a part of this
tutorial I will get into some of the
prerequisites required for installing
Jenkins post which I will go ahead and
install Jenkins on a Windows box there
are few first time configuration that
needs to be done and I will be covering
those as well so once I have Jenkins
installed and configured properly I will
get into the user administrative part
I'll create few users and I will use
some plugins for setting up various
kinds of access permissions for these
users I will also put in some freestyle
jobs freestyle job is nothing but a very
very simple job and I will also show you
the powerfulness of Jenkins by
scheduling this particular job to run
based upon time schedule I will also
connect Jenkins with GitHub GitHub is
our source code where source code
repository where I've got some
repositories put up there so using
Jenkins I will connect to GitHub pull up
a repository is existing on GitHub onto
the Jenkins box and run few commands to
build this particular repository that is
pulled from GitHub sending out emails is
a very very important configurations of
Jenkins or any other continuous
integration server for that matter
Whenever there is any notifications that
has to be sent out as a part of either a
build going bad or build being good or
building propagated to some environment
and all these scenarios you would need
the continuous integration servers to be
sending out notifications so I will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure Jenkins for sending out emails
I will also get into a scenario where I
would have a web application a
maven-based Java web application which
will be pulled from a GitHub repository
and I will deploy it onto a tomcat
server the Tomcat server will be locally
running on my system eventually I will
get into one other very very important
topic which is the Master Slave
configuration it's a very very important
and pretty interesting topic where
distributed builds is achieved using a
Master Slave configuration so I will
bring up a sleeve I will connect the
sleeve with the master and I'll also put
in a job and kind of delegate that
particular job to the slave
configuration finally I will let you
know how to use some plugins to backup
your Jenkins so Jenkins has got a lot of
useful information set up on it in terms
of the build environments in terms of
workspace all this can be very very
easily backed up using a plugin so this
is what I'm going to be covering as a
part of this tutorial Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any value of Linux as well one other way
of running Jenkins is downloading this
generic War file and as long as you have
jdk installed you can launch this war
file by the command opening up a command
prompt or shell prompt differently on
Linux box specifying Java hyphen jar and
the name of this war file it typically
brings up your web application and you
know you can continue with your
installation the only thing being if at
all you want to stop using Jenkins you
just go ahead and close this prompt you
either do a Ctrl C and then bring down
this prompt and the Jenkins server would
be down other older versions of Jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a Java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so Jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your Jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate Jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
Administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
Administration otherwise all the
commands are all the configuration are
the way in which I'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is run in
Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the
recommended RAM for running Jenkins and
also like any other open source toolsets
when you install jdk ensure that you set
in the environment variable Java home to
point to the right directory this is
something very specific to jdk but for
any other open source tools that you of
install there is always a preferred
environment variable that you got to set
in which is specific to that particular
tool that you're going to use this is a
generic thing that is there for you know
for any other open source projects
because the way open source projects
discover themselves is using this
environment variables so as a general
practice or a good practice always set
these environment variables accordingly
so I already have GDK 1.8 installed on
my system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page you
will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so
I'm not going to do the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I've just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk 1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run Java
or Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java hyphen version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download
you also have a Docker container wherein
you know you can launch Jenkins as a
container but I'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what I want is yes this is
the war file which is generic War file
that I was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows MSI installer so go
ahead and download this MSI installer I
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running a war file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
even begin your installation for now I
don't need to do any of this thing so
I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes in into
the Jenkins configuration SQL and
program files is good for me yeah this
is where all my destination folder and
all the configuration specific to it
goes I'm happy with this I don't want to
change this I would just say go ahead
and click installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is it
will start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done so and by default Jenkins Launches
on the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not great it'll crib about
it but this looks good so it's going
ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that install
recommended plugin so if you see there
is a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugin that is required for
Jenkins in order to run properly so
Jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you this is a good
combination to kind of begin with and
mind you at this moment Jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your your network is not so good
few of these plugins would kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know all
available on openly or or mirrored sites
and sometimes some of them may be down
so do not worry in case some of these
plugins kind of fail to install you'll
get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just ensure that you
know at least most or 1995 of all these
plugins are installed without any
problems let me pause the video here for
a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that I get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
again given any username and password
but ensure that you kind of remember
that because it's very hard to get back
your username and password in case you
forget it alright so I'm going to create
a very very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I got a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you would kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line you are
a little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkins
know at any point in time how many jobs
or how many threads can be run you can
kind of visualize it like a thread that
can be run on this particular instance
as a thumb rule if at all you're on a
single core system number of executors
two should be good enough in case at any
point in time if there are multiple jobs
that kind of get triggered the same time
in case the number of executors are less
compared to the number of jobs that have
that woken up no need to panic because
they will all get queued up and
eventually Jenkins will get to running
those jobs just bear in mind that
whenever a new job kind of you know gets
triggered the CPU usage and the memory
usage in terms of the disk right is very
high on the Jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out there by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email ID
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine the scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
an example in case your source code is a
Java source code and assuming that you
know because in this a demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install GDK on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command Dash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
chenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
manage Jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
with hashes of these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root DN password
or the manager DN and the manager
password and all these details in case
you want to connect your Jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization but for now since I
don't have any of these things I'm going
to use this own database that's good
enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job all
right so job new item you know little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so I'll just say you
know first job this is good for me I
just gave a name for my job I would say
it's a freestyle project that's good
enough for me I don't want to choose any
of that so unless until you choose any
of this this particular button would not
become active so choose the freestyle
project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
Jenkins job all right I don't want to
choose any of these again there are some
helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on a Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
will let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once you save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that I've created whichever I'm
running would you know there will be an
individual folders specific to the jobs
that has been put up here all right so
one job one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
let's say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in a build script
pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and now put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering uh hook or a web hook kind
of a triggering later on but for now
what I want to do I want to ensure that
this job that I'm going to put in would
be automatically triggered on its own
let's say every minute I want this job
to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and he's asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah I want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do I check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not I just don't do
anything I'll just wait for a minute and
if at all everything goes well Jenkins
would automatically trigger my second
job in a minute's time from now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific role I can
have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into many Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for you to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins all right so let
me come back to available and I would
want to search for my role based access
plugin so I would say search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of a
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I have
installed the role based access plugin I
would need to just set it up and check
that you know I would go ahead and
create some roles and ensure that I
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
managing canes
configure all right let me see where is
this configured configure Global
Security is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of these at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options you can click
hover over it you would see some sort of
a help on what what are these uh you
know permissions specific to so what I
want is like you know it sounds a little
you know different but I would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job
I'll check you know have read only
access to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run an
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular dial I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular Global rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and these permissions can
be you know fine grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that had set in let me
quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so bottom line Jenkins
without plugins is nothing so plugins is
the heart of Jenkins for you to connect
or for in order to connect Jenkins with
any of the containers or any of the
other tool sets you would need the
plugins if you want to connect or you
want to build a repository which has got
Java and Maven you would need to install
Maven and GDK on your Jenkins instance
if at all you're looking for a net build
or Microsoft build you would need to
have MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a Jenkins build you can can
build a job on Jenkins and push it to
sonar Cube and get sonar Cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in Jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our Jenkins
instance to GitHub I already have very
very simple Java repository up on my
GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up the https URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just
at the Java file how do I build my Java
file how do I compile my Java file I
just say Java C and the name of my class
file which is hello.java and how do I
run my Java file I would say Java and
hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here this is a git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would sure because
the plugin is already there SVN perforce
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
this particular Source control tools
okay so I would copy the https URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to go and grab my source
code from but all right that sounds good
but what is the username and password so
I'll have to specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use this
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm gonna grab this URL what am I
going to do this step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
so Java C Java that sounds good I would
say save this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system or
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it'll compile it will based
upon the goals that you specify it can
compile it can run some tests and it can
you can build a war file and even deploy
it into some other server for now what
we're going to use Maven is just for
building and creating a package out of
this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the Jenkins
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download I'll let you know how to
quickly download and install the Tomcat
alright so download Maven first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this my one there is
zip files binary zip files and archive
files so what I've done is I've just
already downloaded Maven and if you see
I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know Maven again is is a
one open source build tool so you'll
have to set in a few configurations and
set up the path so mvn hyphen iPhone
version if I specify this after setting
my path my one should work and if at all
I Echo M2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my over node it is already set here
so once you unzip my oven just set this
M2 home variable to the directory where
you unzip your Maven also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your Maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable mav1 is running
perfectly fine on my system I've just
verified it okay next one is the Tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this way you download Tomcat server and
I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let Tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port Clash
so what I've done I have configured
Tomcat to use a different port so if I
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that is one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloy
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created our username
called deployer and the password is
deployer and I've added a role called
manager hyphen script manager hyphen
script will allow programmatic access to
the Tomcat server so this is the role
that is there so using this credentials
I will enable or I'll Empower Jenkins to
get into my Tomcat server and deploy my
application all right only these two
things that is required
let me just start my Tomcat server first
so I get into my bin folder I open
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go don't get
service up and running now this is
running on Port 8081 so let me just
check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
NBN
web app I call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of my git repository is
uh this guy https URL
okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this Warfare was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server again I would need a
small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I will
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
continue container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I would say this web application War
file that is already built so I would
need to configure this plugin to pull up
this war file and deploy it onto the
Tomcat server for deploying onto the
Tomcat server I will use the credentials
of the user that I've created okay so
let me go to configure this particular
project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it'll pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my Tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed okay so
let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deploy credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular folder and then you
know context path is MN web app use the
deployer deployment credentials and get
into this localhost which is there
1881 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if I
type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the you know the
date timestamp so this is the file that
get got recently copied and this is the
Explorer version of our application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different type that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own the four components are as follows
the docker clients and server which
we've already done a deeper dive on
Docker images Docker containers and the
docker registry so if we look at the
structure that we have here on the left
hand side you see the relationship
between the docker client and the docker
server and then we have the rest API in
between now if we start digging into
that rest API particularly the
relationship with the docker Daemon on
the server we actually have our other
elements that form the different
components of the docker ecosystem
system so the docker client is accessed
from your terminal window so if you are
using Windows this can be Powershell on
Mac it's going to be your terminal
window and it allows you to run the
docker Daemon and the registry service
when you have your terminal window open
so you can actually use your terminal
window to create instructions on how to
build and run your Docker images and
containers if we look at the images part
of our registry here we actually see
that the image is really just a template
with the instructions used for creating
the containers which you use within
Docker the docker image is built using a
file called the docker file and then
once you've created that Docker file
you'll store that image in the docker
Hub or registry and that allows other
people to be able to access the same
structure of a Docker environment that
you've created the syntax of creating
the image is fairly simple it's
something that you'll be able to get
your arms around very quickly and
essentially what you're doing is your
create dating the option of a new
container you're identifying what the
image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what this is
its strength it allows you to be able to
create those multiple environments that
you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your Solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
Consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that Docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an Open
Source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use Docker
itself as its own default registry and
Docker Hub now something that has to be
bear in mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and I really
encourage you to go out to Docker and
see the other Docker images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that that
point you'll likely want to create a
private repository so you're not sharing
that knowledge with the world in general
now the way in which you connect with
the docker registry is through simple
pull and push commands that you run
through terminal window to be able to
get the latest information so if you
want to be able to build your own
container what you'll start doing is
using the pull commands to actually pull
the image from the docker repository and
the command line for that is fairly
simple in terminal window you would
write Docker pull and then you put in
the image name and any tags associated
with that image and use the command
pause so in your terminal window you
would actually use a simple line of
command once you've actually connected
to your Docker environment and that
command will be Docker pull with the
image name and any Associated tags
around that image what that will then do
is pull the image from the docker
repository whether that's a public
repository or a private one now in
Reverse if you want to be able to to
update the docker image with new
information you do a push command where
you take the script that you've written
about the docker container that you
define and push it to the repository and
as you can imagine the commands for that
are also fairly simple in terminal
window you would write Docker push the
image name any Associated tags and then
that would then push that image to the
docker repository again either a public
or a private repository so if we recap
the docker file creates a Docker image
that's using the build commands Docker
image then contains all the information
necessary for you to be able to execute
the project using the docker image any
user can run the code in order to create
a Docker container and once a Docker
image is built it's uploaded to a
registry or to a Docker Hub where it can
be shared across your entire team and
from the docker Hub users can get access
to the docker image and build their own
new containers welcome to all our
viewers I'm Anjali from simply learn and
today I'll be taking you through the
installation process for Docker so
before we begin let me give you an intro
to Docker so what is Docker Docker is a
tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in
lightweight containers so when I say
containers I mean a software package
that consists of all the dependencies
required to run the particular
application and when you deploy
containers you're basically providing
the capability for the application to
run in any kind of environment so
Dockers have multiple features some of
which are that multiple containers can
run on the same Hardware it has very
high productivity when compared to
Virtual machines it maintains isolated
applications and has a very quick and
easy configuration process so now let's
begin with the demo we'll be installing
Docker on an Ubuntu system so this is my
system I just open the terminal so the
first thing you can start with is
removing any Docker installation that
you probably already have present in
your system if you want to start from
scratch so this is the command to do so
sudo app get removed docker
Docker engine Docker dot IO enter your
password
and Docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install Docker
once again before that I'll just clear
my screen
okay so before I install Docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo app get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that occurred so sometimes it's possible
that due to the environment of the
machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type Docker install
and that by itself will give you the
commands you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
Docker dot IO is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the sudo
snap install Docker so sudo apt install
Docker dot IO first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have sudo snap
install Docker so snap install Docker
installs a newly created snap package
there are basically some other
dependencies for Docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire Docker i o it
will take some time
great so our Docker is installed the
next thing we do as I mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install talk
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for Docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for Docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is Docker
version
and as you can see Docker version
17.12.1 CE has been installed next thing
we do is we pull an image from the
docker hub
so Docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a Docker image which
is present on the docker Hub Docker Hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is sudo Docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository this is present on our system
currently so the image has been
successfully pulled onto the system and
this means that our Docker is working
now we'll try out another command
pseudo Docker PF minus a this displays
all the containers that you have pulled
so far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed and
all of them are in exited state so I did
this demo previously too which is why
the two hello worlds which is created
two minutes ago is also displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for Docker PS
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running State you can
simply execute sudo Docker PS
pseudo docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running State and with that we come to
an end of our Docker installation
welcome everyone to our one another demo
on which we are going to see that how
exactly we can do the installation of
Docker on the Windows platform
specifically on Windows 10. now Docker
is something which is available for most
of the operating systems different
different platforms so it supports both
the Unix and the windows platform as
such so Linux through various commands
we can do the installation but in the
case of Windows you have to download the
exe file and a particular installer from
the docker Hub websites you can simply
Google it and you will get a kind of
link from where you will be able to
download the package so let's go to the
Chrome and try to search on for the
windows string uh particular installer
you will get a link from Docker Hub you
download it you get the stable version
you get the edge version whichever
version you want you wish to download
you can download it so let's go back to
the Chrome so here you have the dock
occur next stop for Windows so you can
go for this table or you can go for the
edge right so you also have the
comparison that what is the difference
between these two versions right so um
the particular Edge version is something
which is getting releases every month
and uh the uh stable version is getting
the releases every quarter so they are
not doing much of the changes to the
stable version as compared to the edge
there so you just have to double click
on the installer and that will help you
to do the installation of the process so
let's get started so you just click on
the get in stable version so when you do
that the particular installer is going
to install now it's going to take like
around 300 MB there so that's the kind
of install which is available so once
the installer is downloaded so what you
can do is that you can actually go ahead
and you can proceed with the doing the
double click on this installer when you
double click on that you have to proceed
with some of the steps like you know
from the GUI itself you are going to
proceed with these steps so we'll wait
for 10 to 20 seconds more and then the
installer will be done and then we can
do the double click and the installation
will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of Unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a GUI is also
involved and there are a lot of binders
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the Hue size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
Windows 10 professional or Enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous version of operating
systems like Windows 7 and all you have
the older version called Docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like Docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as in Docker desktop with the new
Docker Windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so I'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a GUI component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay I'm going to
click on OK so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
Docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any Docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here that Docker
is you know something which is installed
so you can run like Docker version you
will be able to get a version of the
client when you do the restart of the
machine then add that moment of time the
docker server will also be started and
then this particular error message will
go off right now the docker demon is not
up and running because the installation
requires a restart and when you close on
this one and go for the restart the
machine will be restarted here so this
is the way that how exactly we can go
for a Docker installation and we can go
on that part welcome everyone to this
topic on Docker tutorial for the
beginners here now in this one we are
going to talk about the various
components for example what is the
devops here why the devops is important
what is Docker the advantages of Docker
installation of Docker architecture of
Docker components of Docker here so
these are the different things which we
are going to talk about over here now
let's start with what exactly isn't
devops all about here now devops is
nothing but a collaboration between the
development and the operations teams
over here which enables continuous
delivery of the applications and
services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration continuous
deployment continuous delivery all these
things are possible with this
collaboration over here now why exactly
Docker is important for us as such
in a city far away from this one so a
developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single VM now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the the
multiple application on a single machine
but for him these virtual machine got a
crashed because definitely if you are
putting up more uh different different
applications as such on the on a single
VM uh it's not able to take up that much
kind of load over there so in order to
avoid this situation how exactly he can
do the various options or what he can
Implement to have this uh issue result
so ultimately Docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications uh
on a single virtual machine or he want
to have different different applications
then Docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so uh there
will be no issues as such when we talk
about that uh the errors or the virtual
machines cannot be crashed and there
will be no impact on the virtual machine
as such so why exactly Docker is
important so let's talk about the
comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly the docker is being
chosen over a virtual machine because
virtual machine is a full-fledged
component which can take up any kind of
load but some of the reasons are still
that in which case we will be preferring
the docker instead of the virtual
machine here the very first one is the
memory users so Docker is having a very
less memory users because there is no
concept of guest operating system
whereas on the other hand the virtual
machines are going to take a huge amount
of ram resources in order to keep that
particular operating system up and
running second one performance because
if definitely if you have less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver about that amount of performance
as such over there and then again we
have portability so portability is also
quite easy when we talk about the
virtual machines in case of Docker it's
quite portable as compared to the
virtual machine and then the last time
is that the boot up time so virtual
machine bottom time is probably in
minutes but uh in case of Docker it's in
second so if we summarize it on this one
so the memory utilization the boot up
time the performance everything is
better in case of Docker as compared to
the virtual machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that app one app to and app3 is
there so green and red color represents
the occupied memory and the wasted
memory now
there is a particular uh utilization of
let's say that
um you know a server which is available
there and uh you know uh 3gb of uh RAM
is something which is wasted and 4GB of
RAM is something which is being occupied
there so app2 is using like 2GB and then
you can see that the specific 2GB of RAM
is occupied and 3gb is occupied and the
wasted one is 1GB so VM can see over
there that uh you know 9 GB of RAM is
used and the remaining 6gb of uh unused
Ram cannot be reused because if for
example I allocate like 4GB of ram to
the virtual machine it's there itself it
it gets logged on so it's not like okay
uh I'm using only 4GB Ram out of this 9
GB of RAM then the next 5gb of ram will
be totally wasted so you cannot reuse it
for any purpose so this is a problem
with the virtual machine that if you
allocate some memory to the specific
virtual machine if you are not using
that much resources or that much memory
the remaining memory will be simply
pasted because this is hard coally
allocated to a virtual machine and you
cannot utilize these unused memory as
such over there so this is the
limitation from the memory perspective
but in case of Docker definitely if uh
you know out of the 9 GB of RAM if we
are using uh only 3gb of RAM
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually reuse it to for the
new containers so it's not dedicately
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using out of 9gb if you are using
1GB 2GB 3gb or 4GB whatever the
remaining uh memory is available that
you can simply use it for the other
containers also this ensures that you
always go for an optimal utilization of
your resources and unnecessarily there
is no wastage of the different different
resources or the different components
over here in this one so that's the
reason why the docker containers are
quite uh efficient in terms of memory
when we compare it with the virtual
machine next one is the performance now
in a virtual machine we know that you
know on the infrastructure on the
physical infrastructure on top of that
you put up a kind of operating system a
base operating system is there and then
on top of that you have the hypervisor
and this hypervisor then is used to
create the virtual machines which is
having a kind of just operating system
inside it now the issue over here is
that you have two operating systems over
here so the guest operating system is
also going to take some particular
resources and for example the memory or
a space a processor so in every terms in
every resource terms it is going to
go ahead and say that okay I'm going to
use the particular sum of the resources
Now problem is that if you're hosting a
very small application you will end up
in having a more conception because of
this guest operating system will take
more of more of the resources and then
you are just using some small very small
resources for your application in an
real world so Docker container on the
other hand does not have a concept of
the guest operating system and that's
where what happens that the docker
engine is more than sufficient to handle
the docker containers and inside the
docker containers there is the
application which is being hosted over
there now with this one definitely the
performance is quite better as compared
to any virtual machine because of the
terms that there is no unnecessarily
wasted of the resources because in the
previous case virtual machines are
full-fledged gas operating system is up
and running you need some resources to
be allocated to that but in case of
containers you don't need to have that
particular functionality implemented
then portability so
um you know having a portability or
moving an application which works on a
system a does not mean that it will work
on the system B also this is a similar
problem which we face that you know
usually the application works perfectly
fine in a lower environment and when it
goes to the production environment it
sometimes fails and it does not comes up
properly so this isn't portability issue
which we have when we talk about the
virtual machines but when in case of
containers when we got a container up
and running in a lower environment and
once the container is prepared you don't
have to do the changes or modification
to that depending on the environment the
same container can be deployed till
production environment and it's very
easy so whatever a container prepared in
the lower environment in a Dev
environment the same will work in
production environment without any
issues because it contains all the
dependencies and executables everything
inside it so you don't have to do any
kind of modifications or changes to
these containers as such over here and
the last one is a boot up time so uh the
boot up time of the virtual machines is
in minutes and whereas the boot up time
of the docker containers is in seconds
or probably in milliseconds so these are
the reason why we consider the virtual
machine as in resources based
environment but on the other hand Docker
is something which is quite light and
fast as compared to watch a message so
let's see that what exactly is in Docker
all about here so in this one you can
see uh we have the physical
infrastructure on which we have the host
operating system now we don't have the
hypervisor and the guest operating
system instead of that we have the
docker engine which is taking care of
managing the docker containers and
inside these Docker containers you have
the applications and all the required
binaries and the libraries here so there
is no concept of the gift operating
system these Docker engine is the uh
person or is the process which is taking
care of all the requests which is going
on and if this Docker engine is up and
running then all the containers will
also be accessible and will be available
now Docker is nothing but a OS level
virtualization software platform that
enables developers and it administrators
to create deploy and run applications in
a Docker container with all its
dependencies so Docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production government now let's talk
about what exactly is in Docker
container here now Docker container is a
lightweight software package that
includes all the dependencies whether
it's a base operating system uh some
framework sample libraries it's it's
something which is uh part of this one
so that if you will be if you want to
host your application you will be able
to do that so it's a complete package so
both the source code and the
dependencies is what you put up inside
the docker containers now
within this Docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
Frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
this Docker containers you can host them
as such over there now one of the
different advantages of Docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so rapid deployment is
the very first advantages which we are
getting over here second quick and easy
configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability and security over here now
there are different ways in which we can
understand the benefits or we can have
the understanding about the docker here
so uh these are some couple of benefits
now let's take a uh take them one by one
the first the first one is the
deployment part so uh it's it supports
the rapid deployment now
just like a web application for instance
I want to deploy to Webster so there are
some couple of steps which needs to be
done across different different
environments like for example if I have
five environments I have to do the
deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
Docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one Docker
container the same Docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay I have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your Docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we go for
the quick and easy configurations so uh
the configurations of Docker containers
is quite easy you can have your own
custom Docker images built out the
docker files so these processes can be
integrated within the Jenkins also so
cicd is quite possible with the help of
Docker if you want to really do that and
then we have better efficiency yes they
have a better efficiency and resources
management as compared to the virtual
machines portability uh we have already
thought about that that it's easy to
move from one environment from one
system to another in fact it's easy from
the developer also so from one machine
from one developer to another developer
it's very easy to move these uh
different Docker containers then we have
scalability
scalability is also possible with the
Stocker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
orchestration tools then security is
there so you can have your best
practices of the security implemented
because
um it's just a kind of a virtualization
just like a virtual machine so you have
all the uh different uh possibilities
which is available which you can explore
when you talk when you want to make the
stock container secure right so these
were some of the benefits which was
there for the docker okay now let's talk
about the installation of Docker here
now installation of Docker is pretty
common and whatever platform you want
it's available over there so it's
available for Ubuntu windows
it's available for Mac operating system
so for Ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the Ubuntu part operating
system to download it and for Windows
it's actually having a
a particular exe file so you can go for
the installation of exe file and then we
have the Mac operating system so for Mac
operating system you have the DMG files
and when you do the DMG file so it will
help you to install the component over
there so Mac you can also use the home
view wants to do the installation of
that particular component now next one
is the architecture of Docker now the
architecture of Docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of Docker here the very
first one is the as the client facing is
the docker client now Docker client or
you can say the docker CLI is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example I'm running the command so it
will take all the requests from me as an
end user and it will send those uh
particular things or the requirements to
the docker demon to the server using the
rest TV API interface so this Docker
demon is something which keeps on
running on the server and it's a
background process it gets deployed as
in service there in case this Docker
demon is not available or it's not up
and running you will not get the proper
response from the docker command line
here so in order to get your activity or
your procedures implemented you need to
have the docker server or Docker demon
up and running in fact this Docker CLI
can be configured to connect to any
other servers or any other different
server Docker Daemon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest API interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demon and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of Docker here let's talk
about that so Docker client consists of
the CLI component like we have already
discussed so that is something which is
going to take up all the requests from
the end user then it's using the rest
API interface which is there to have the
connectivity with the docker Daemon so
Docker demon is uh something uh which is
always up and running so if you run a
couple of commands like Docker pull
position also that activity you are
actually sending the request to the
docker demon and Docker demon is
actually doing all the work so it's not
a Docker client which is doing it just
taking its kind of interface which will
take the things up and send it back or
send it forward to the docker day
right so it's a backend process which
keeps on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's the same
process across all the infrastructure
all the different platforms whether you
use Mac operating system use Windows or
you use Linux everywhere this is the
basic functionality and it keeps on
listening to the rest API interface so
uh whatever the request new request
comes in it immediately process it and
whatever the response whether you are
stopping a container whether you're
running a container according to that
the action will be taken and the
response will be sent back to the rest
API to the docker client so a dockerd is
a process or it's a command line which
is used to start the docker demon when
you run the command like service Docker
status on the server you will be able to
see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that Docker is the process or is
the command line which is used to
initialize the docker Daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psyphen EF
command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
particular Docker in history so we have
a ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker Hub so you
can actually store the docker images on
these Docker registry so there are a lot
of ready-made Docker images which is
available there but of course you can
have your own Docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom registry Docker Registries also
for example in jfrog you can have your
private hosted Registries also so all
these uh different repositories you can
use with your Docker container so Docker
containers is having the flexibility
that whichever Registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here in detail
now a Docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions it's having a
couple of instructions in which you will
be using these instructions to create a
final doc container so Docker image is
uh nothing but uh for example I want to
have a tomcat Apache Docker image so
what are the instructions I have to do
so the very first thing is that I have
to pick up a base operating system then
on top of that I will be installing the
jdk awesome pre-request packages and
then on top of that we will be
configuring on to the Tomcat Apache
there so these are the steps these are
the different instructions step by step
procedure which we are implementing so
that at the end of the uh activity we
will be able to have a Docker container
ready which we can deploy to host Tomcat
Apache so it's a template which is
having all the particular instructions
in order to build a Docker image you
require a file called Docker file which
is uh of course having all these
different uh
instructions embedded that so when you
run the docker file it acts like a build
tool so whatever the instructions you
are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting a processed and
you are able to get a end result uh then
these Docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration of of the term kit
Apache and then another layer will be
there so it's a multi-layered in
component which is available and these
layers are in incremental order so
definitely the oldest one will be known
as the base layer and then on top of
that all the latest changes will be done
in the latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that there
are four instructions and these four
instructions are also known as the four
layer Docker image so whatever over the
final Docker image you will get in there
you will be able to see four layers of
the docker image here now the very first
is Ubuntu so Ubuntu 18.04 we are pulling
up and then we are pulling like uh the
file over here and uh then we are
running the make utility and uh once
that is done then we are running that
file dot uh python file over here in
this one so these are four instructions
which is available right so uh which
will definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can make or we can perform
the different activities right from the
base so in this case the base layer will
be like uh the Ubuntu one so one to one
will be the base image and the moment
the final CMP attribute or CMD uh
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full flash Docker image over there
so this will be a full complete Docker
image or Docker container which you will
get once the whole build process is
completed
now in this ways you have you can see
that the previous Docker file which we
processed so the base layer is Ubuntu
18.04 we are not building that actually
it's automatically it's uh it's by
default getting downloaded as in full
base layer after that only we have like
layer one layer 2 layer 3 added up
because those modifications we are doing
it after the uh because from does not
means that you are doing any kind of
layer modifications it's just like you
are importing some base operating system
or base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new layer is something which is stopped
on top of the image these layers are
known as the containers layers so one to
one the very first instruction does not
comprises it it is it's not a com kind
of a container layer we can call it as
an base image layer there so every
container has a separate read write
container layer and any modification in
a container is reflected upon the
container layers only so layer 1 may be
having some different of uh
instructions layer to maybe having
different instructions so like that it's
a step-by-step processor
in case you know whenever our container
is deleted the top layer also gets
deleted over there in that one so if I
delete some uh particular containers and
that is something which is gone so it
was suppose having like three layers so
the top layer will be simply deleted
because the container is also deleted
for that particular part now Docker uses
a copy and write strategy with both
Docker images and Docker containers so
uh whenever we uh perform any activity
or whenever copy on uh write a
strategies and strategy to share and
copy files for better efficiency so it's
something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes Docker
efficient by reducing the uses of disk
space because whenever uh required okay
whenever is needed only at that moment
of time it's actually performing the
copy and uh it it definitely reduces the
overall disk utilization and this is
very important also because when you
have so many document containers up and
running so you have to worry or you have
to make the utilization of a disk or
your disk users or resources also
minimum so that is also you need to make
sure that it does not exceed a
particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about some of the facts
here so the base layers are something
which is purely read-only format so you
cannot do the modifications Union file
system saves the memory uh you know by
avoiding the duplications of the files
the layers can be combined in a union
file system to create a single image so
all these layers are combined and got a
final product are called you know you
can call it as Docker image or Docker
containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a writeable which is known as copy on
right so copy and write strategy is
being used so to do the changes or to do
the perform the modifications of this
Union file system file creating the
different different layers so
now let's talk about the docker registry
very important component because even if
you prepare the docker image locally and
you don't have the collaborative tool or
you don't have the tool where you can
share these images definitely it's not
easy for you to Port these Docker images
from one system to another so Docker
industry is very important for the
portability feature of Docker so Docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute Docker images among users so
uh it can be built up by one user and
multiple users can use it for example
I'm using a Jenkins one so
um shenkins image is prepared only once
but it's being used by different people
as such Docker registry again it's a
repository is a collection of Docker
images so in a repository you will be
having like different different uh
Docker images as such so in registry a
user can distinguish between the docker
images with their tag names so uh for
example Jenkins is an a kind of a single
image they might be different type of
images there let's say that okay let's
talk about uh Jenkins uh gdk8 so there
will be image called Jenkins the name of
the image will be same but the tags will
be different so one tag could be like
jedicate one tag would be like jdk9 and
one time would be jdk 10. so the
difference between all these three
Docker images is that that jdk81 is
prepared on gdk8 it's running on jdk8
and if you want to use jtk 9 in that
case you have to pull down the the
docker image of Jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the framework
so depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distant qh between
the uh Docker images and whichever
Docker image you feel you want to use
you can Implement according to your
requirement and uh Docker by default is
having its own uh cloud-based registry
called as Docker Hub which gets
automatically connected when the moment
you do the docker installation but in
case you are working into your private
infrastructure so in that case you may
use the repositories uh Docker
repositories on the specific jfrog
artifactory or the private repositories
also can be hosted
but Docker Hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use uh
push and pull activities to interact
with these Docker images you want to
download a Docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your Docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the docker Hub so when
you run some build process or when you
run the containers there may be some
Docker containers which is getting
pulled down from the specific registry
from the docker Hub and uh if that
specific image and tag is available
definitely pull command will be
successful but in case of push command
you are pushing your custom Docker
images uh you cannot push the ready-made
Docker images which is available you can
publish your own Docker image only to
the docker Hub and then you can further
on do the pull and push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready made and third party
images which is available you can only
do the poll activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom Docker image next one
is the docker container now Docker
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a Docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the application source
code inside it so the docker container
don't have to look for the dependencies
on the host machine on the server so
this is one of the benefit where we see
that the portability is very easy
because whatever I'm building up on one
system everything is inside the docker
container so I don't really need to do
any further activity on other machines
so whatever works on one system can be
easily worked on another system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular uh servers
because it does not take that much
utilization like a virtual machine so if
you are looking forward for having your
application hosted into your local
system you can easily do it within the
dock container so the utilization is
very less as compared to the virtual
machine so you don't have to worry about
your operating host operating system and
the qualifications
so Docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine so
there is no interaction or there is no
interface so they share the OS called uh
kernel but uh the thing is they don't
have the interface as such over there so
it works totally in isolation uh two
different containers will not have any
interaction unless and until we do we
set up that window containers to have
the interactions
now there is uh data volumes which can
be shared and uh be used among the
multiple containers so
um you have the capability over here
that you know if uh the there are some
on used uh space that can be easily
shared across the multiple containers
here so uh it is uh built using the
docker images so uh using the docker
images the docker containers are built
up and uh Docker run is a specific
command which is used to build a Docker
container so if you got a Docker image
let's say that I have prepared a Docker
image a custom Docker image using the
docker file now if I need to create a
Docker container out of a Docker image I
have to run a docket one command so
Docker run command is nothing but it
initializes or creates an instance of a
Docker image now next component is the
docker compose now typically when we
work with the docker containers so we
had to run like if I want to run like
five six containers I have to initialize
like five six times or I have to run
Docker and commands five six times there
so and if you want to create a
relationship between the containers then
definitely that is something which you
need to manage using the docker commands
but sometimes it's not an easy task for
you to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so Docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
it's called a kind of a single file you
just run it and all the containers
definitions and relationships everything
is inside this Docker file here so you
want to run two containers that's
totally fine instead of running two
commands now you just have to run one
file and that will do take care of that
now you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any manual
activity or without any maintenance onto
the server
so these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to uh
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these uh
Docker compose files so Docker compose
file is something which is written in a
vaml format and in this you define that
okay I need two containers and this in
this image should be there these are the
parameters which you need to run and if
you want to have the interaction or the
linkage between the images that also you
can establish within this yml files or
this in within this Docker compose file
here right so let's say for example I
want to have an application which
requires Apache web server and mySQL
database now I can create a Docker
compose file which can run both
containers and uh without you know you
don't require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so I will be having a final Docker
compose file which is having like a uh
you know containers like Apache
containers and mysq containers both
inside a single Docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you are going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate Apache and
separate viable MySQL so you can get it
done with the help of a single Docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker spam now Docker spam is a
inbuilt or it's a default oxygen tool
which is being provided by the docker
itself it's a service for containers
which allows the it administrators and
the developers to create and manage a
cluster of swamp nodes so
um in a typical world when you do the
installation of Docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high availability multiple uh
instances or scalability all these
things are not possible as it is with
the code Docker now on top of that you
require the organization tools like
Docker swam where you have a swam of
node machines five six known machines
are there on which you can have your
highly available application
infrastructure implemented now this one
means that if I want to run my
applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of Docker swam is a human
which is uh used to for performing the
interaction so there will be a master
node which is available so uh it will be
interacting with all the known machine
on the all the client machines and this
interaction will be in such a way that
it will let them know okay I want to
deploy the container or onto the Note 3
so it will perform that activity and the
container will be up and running on the
Note 3 there so a swam consists of two
type of nodes one is the manager node
and one is a worker node so manager is
the master node which you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so uh
the manager node is not something which
is expected to host uh anything apart
from the main component but yes uh you
can always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can do during the deployment of
the containers so manager will will keep
on connecting to the different worker
nodes there and whenever new request
comes in so it will basically try to
connect and see that okay I just want to
go ahead and deploy a container so it
will do the deployment of the container
on the worker node so the main work will
be done by the worker nodes and manager
is just doing the management of all
these resources the worker nodes will be
definitely receiving the request from
the manager and it will be proceeding
and Performing those activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active or online so the master node will
not be able to deploy the containers on
that server so right now let's talk
about a demo in which we have to create
a Docker image using a Docker file on
the open220 so uh if you want to use a
base operating system as an Ubuntu 20
there and using that we will we aren't
going to create a custom Docker image so
let's connect to our virtual machine and
see that how we can do that
[Music]
image of Ubuntu so let's take an
operating system of Ubuntu 20 20 is the
latest version of the Ubuntu operating
system so I have got a server so let's
see so first of all we have to install
the docker.io package which will install
the docker package and then we can
enable the uh service we can make sure
that the docker service is up and
running because if the service itself is
down then we will not be able to perform
any activity and then our sample if you
run Docker run hello hyphen volt so that
is going to pull a Docker image from the
docker Hub and a particular activity
will be done to you so once that is done
so we can say that okay the container is
up and running and everything has got uh
you know over there up and running and
then you can also try some of the Ubuntu
Docker image also if you feel that you
want to try you can do that but the main
uh demo which we need to do over here is
that we need to prepare a custom Docker
image and in this one we will be having
like we will be using an Ubuntu base
operating system on top of that we will
be installing PHP nginx all these
different components so we are going to
have a PHP based website hosted onto the
Apache web server as an nginx and then
we will be able to access that
application so the very first thing
which we need to do is that we need to
create a folder let's say that I just
created a particular folder called nginx
iPhone image and then I create a Docker
file over there so Docker file uh
content we are going to take from this
one so let's go to the server and see
that how we can go ahead with the
activity now uh what we can do is that
uh What uh we have got a server over
here now in this server what I'm going
to do is that I am going to proceed with
the installation of Docker first now
when I do the docker installation first
so what will happen that I will be able
to have my Docker installation completed
and then further on I can take the
furthest steps of having the
accessibility of going through the
understanding that what is this
particular platform or how to prepare
different different kind of containers
so
I have got a particular container over
here so what I can really do is that I
can simply say that okay I have got a
server so this is Ubuntu Server so I'm
going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that I will
be able to have establish the fact that
I'm trying to connect I'm trying to
connect to the Ubuntu URL so that at any
moment of time I should be able to fetch
on the latest packages now once that is
done so I'm going to run the command
called apt install Docker dot IO now the
moment I do this what will happen that
it will try to download some packages it
will ask for the confirmation you can
give your confirmation and I can say yes
the moment you give the confirmations
the download of the packages will
proceed over here step by step it will
download the packages and the
installation will go on now once the
installation is done so what you can do
is that that you can see that Docker is
deployed into your system or not you can
run Docker version command or you can
also use the service command to check to
make sure to ensure that the docker
service is always up and running if the
service is not up and running you have
to make sure you have to enable it you
have to start that service so these are
some couple of steps which you need to
do in order to make sure that your
connectivity or your environment is
ready for with the docker installation
and once the docker installation is done
then only you will be able to proceed
further with the further activities like
preparing the containers preparing the
images and all that stuff but if you
don't have the docker installed prior to
that then definitely it's going to be a
problem so just make sure that before
even doing any kind of activity before
even doing any kind of steps we ensure
that the docker is fully up and running
so it's going to take some time to
download the packages and we will wait
for that and once the installation is
done we will continue further on that
part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command called
service Docker status and when you do
that uh it will let you know that
whether the docker service is available
there or not so uh you can start the
service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response and uh now you can see that
it's showing up that a process is
running so earlier it was not uh up and
running it was inactive but now it's
active and you can see here the dock
right is the process which is running
over here as in a process to initialize
the docker demand so Docker demon is up
and running now and we are good to go
here so now uh if we go and say like
Docker run hello hyphen world so we are
doing a validation to our Docker
instance that whether our Docker
instance is working fine as expected or
not because uh if there is any kind of
problem with the docker demon and Docker
demon it's not up and running properly
we would be able to get an error message
over there but right now there is no
error message which represents that uh
yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh Docker
images when you run so you will be able
to see that the docker image is pulled
down to your system and definitely you
have executed that and it got you the
response now the next thing which you
need to do is that we need to run a
particular Ubuntu one so for example if
I go for docker run hyphen ID Ubuntu
bash so what exactly we are doing in
this one is that we are pulling down a
Ubuntu Docker image and we are running
the bash executable on top of that the
whole purpose of doing that activity is
that so that if I want to do some uh
process or I want to perform some
activity I should be able to connect to
that Docker image so the moment I do
this first of all uh if this Docker
image is available locally that's great
it will immediately create the container
if the docker image is not available
locally the very first thing which it
will perform over here is to pull down
the docker image the correct one and as
you can see here that it uh definitely
pulls down the docker image and once it
is done so it got a terminal for you now
you can see it shows that root and the
ID root and the rate one ID is there
this ID is nothing but it's a container
ID which we are getting here so
definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come out of the docker
container over here and the moment you
run Docker PS hyphen a command you can
actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far so you run
hello world you run the Ubuntu One both
of them are stopped there you can see
the exit 0 in the uh status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the intratic mode so they are
done so if you want to keep your
container up and running you need to
have a container which runs in the dash
mode and always up and running but for
that you have to go ahead to the level
where we need to create a custom Docker
image and do the setup accordingly so
let's see that how we can do that now
I'm going to create a particular folder
called nginx hyphen image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
I'm going to put up a file called Docker
file so let's see that what content we
need to put as such when we talk about
the docker file because whatever content
you put over here that is what according
which the docker image will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay Ubuntu 20.04 is what I want to
use then we are giving some labels now
these labels are used to give some
information like uh what is the version
Who is the maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so these
labels are actually defined and utilized
so that I will be able to give an
information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh Docker file or will
this build script we have to reach out
to that specific person so this is what
we typically do with the labels here now
um we also have to set up a parameter
like devian underscore fronted as in
non-interactive because whenever we talk
about any build process in Docker file
it it cannot be there in the interactive
session it should be there in the
non-interactive and definitely a typical
uh scenarios like you can run app update
command and then we are installing the
PHP nginx super supervisor all these
things we are doing we are doing the
installation uh we are using the Run
attribute run a particular step and in
there whatever the commands are executed
these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so nginx via virtual host PHP
underscore conf engine extenders for
conf and supervisor underscore conf
these are the different environment
variables which we configuring over here
now next thing which we have is that uh
we have to transfer some files like
probably nginx and the virtual host file
we may have to transfer from a Linux
server to the destination to the docker
container so for that we are going to
run some copy commands copy statements
so that we can do that stuff and uh then
definitely we are transferring the
supervisor configuration file also to
the server so that we can have that
configurations uh set up over there and
uh these uh config supervisor underscore
conf and all these different variables
we have already established where we are
saying that what exactly configuration
we are looking forward over here and
then we are you know creating in some
folder structure we via WWE HTML folder
structure we are creating so that we
will be able to push some content over
there and then we have the volume
configurations so whatever the volume
configurations are there we are putting
up so that uh you know we will be able
to have all the uh specific direct
directories mounted on the host machine
on the whole server so that we can even
talk about locally also and then the
start.sh is something which we need to
run because that's uh that will go into
the command statement which needs to be
executed because when you want to run
your process when you want to run your
engine X process or your Docker
container some process should be up and
running that's where uh if any
interactive process will run then only
the docker container will be hold up so
that's what you can do do or you can
configure over there so I'm going to
copy this whole content now this whole
content represents the complete Docker
file so uh we have already gone through
this content one by one but uh if we
combine all these content together till
the exposed part that's where we come up
into these ones so exposed we are doing
80 and 443 over here right after this
one we have to create a host file
virtual host file supervisor D file and
the star.sh file so let's go back to the
server here now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that uh so this is what I
will my master file will look like you
can see I'm running some run commands uh
these are the environment variables I'm
using then further on this variables I'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the host machine from
the server to the docker container and
then second file is supervisor D not
confile and then we have star.sh file so
these are the different files which we
want to configure here so once this file
is prepared we have to uh type in or we
have to create a default file over here
in this current directory so in this
current directory we have to put up a
file called default now in this one we
will be having the default virtual host
configuration config so we need to put
our server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the Via ww HTML directory
there so I'm just going to copy this
content
and put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so I'll save it
and then we have a supervisory.com file
so
so I'll just copy the content of this
one
I'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisor D dot confile
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into our
Docker file so we can double check that
so once this is done save it and we can
check the docker file you can grab
so you can see okay this one so super
visor D so the name is correct that's
cool so we got default we got supervisor
D now we have to create the star.sh file
because in this one we will be
configuring that how we want to start
our process of this nginx or this web
server so in this one again we have to
run the supervisory process over here
and a configuration file so we are going
to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there and
the moment is done so you are going to
give the execute permission to this one
because
um you can see that into our Docker file
that we are having the attribute where
we want to run this into the dots slash
there so if we want to refer in that
mode you have to change the permissions
in case so that uh change mode you have
to give the execute permission to the
start.sh here now once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular components like you got a
some couple of commands you have uh you
know uh got Docker file
supervisd.com default all these files
are there now the only thing which you
need to do next is that we need to do
the build process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process what happens the docker build is
the command which we need to use and uh
nginx iPhone image is the name which you
want to refer now you can totally use
this uh custom name you whatever name
you feel that you want to use you can
always use that there's no restriction
on that part and once that is on so you
will be able to list down those images
that you've got a new custom Docker
image here so you can see that you got
the Ubuntu as on base image which is
built down and the nginx iPhone image is
also prepared over there and once that
is done so you are going to create a
Webroot folder and uh you can run the
docker run command to see that if you
really got connected with that
particular one so let's go back and uh
see that how we can create uh the docker
custom Docker image here so the moment I
do this so it will pick up the docker
file over here and start performing the
activities uh the package installations
all those configurations ones will be
performed over here in a non-interactive
mode there is no confirmation which will
be asked from the user because because
you cannot put that confirmations so the
command should be in such a way that it
should not take any kind of
confirmations at all from the end user
so because tomorrow you may be putting
up these things in the Jenkins so that
will not be a feasible thing for you to
put up the commands and put up the
confirmations during the execution so so
it's trying to undo the package
installation for the PHP so fpm packages
are getting installed and um here we go
so we caught the successful message now
you can see it says successfully tag
this one this means that there is no
issues at all with the docker image and
when you run the docker
images or Docker images LS you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203 37 MB of the size
of this image that represents that this
Docker image is fully ready to run to
execute so now what we are going to do
is that we are going to map a volume
over here with VAR WWE HTML directory
during the execution of this container
because I really want to deploy some
pages and web pages there if you have
the web pages now as part of the build
process as part of the docker file you
can do a git clone also of some
repository but I don't want to do that
uh during the preparation of Docker
image I just now got an environment
where the nginx is set up properly and
it's up and running there now it should
be upon me that how I want to put up my
content and all so that's the reason why
I'm putting up a kind of a folder
structure over here and sharing it with
the docker container so that the moment
I put the the HTML files or the PHP
files into that local folder I should be
able to get some web page up up and
running there so that's what I'm going
to do over here in this one so I'm going
to create a folder structure saying
slash web root here okay so there is a
folder structure which is created now in
this Webroot I will be putting up some
files and then same files will be
redirected inside the docker container
with the help of Docker volume so let's
go back to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like I
said that you are going to connect on
that part okay so uh you can use this
port as an at also but here it is you so
whatever Port you feel you want to use
you can do that and we are giving the
container name as test and iPhone
container that also you can change nginx
iPhone image is the one which we are
using so if you use some different uh
particular image you can also use that
and you can see that the web root is
something which we are connecting with
the Via WWE HTML directory so the moment
you put some file in the web root the
same file will be reflected into the VAR
ww HTML directory there so I'm going to
run this command and once this is done
so you can see that for the testing
purpose we are putting up some content
in the HTML one so I'll come to that
point also and we'll validate as of now
we should be having our container up and
running over here in this one now I'm
going to copy that command
okay and hit on so if uh the 80 Port is
used so you have to make sure that photo
gets uh you know gets stopped
automatically or it should not be up and
running so just double check whatever
code you are using that should be free
now when you run the docker PS command
so uh you will be able to see a Docker
container up and running but if you see
like Docker psyphony that gives also
these stopped and running both the
containers are there but the main thing
which we want to run is that we want to
run the docker PS command and you can
see that this is a container which is
running so 8080 is the container which
is running in test hyphen container is
the name now you got a container up and
running so you can actually do a curl on
localhost colon 8080 so
um this is a way to get the content uh
you can get the public IP also and uh in
the browser you can put up and you can
have the content there but right now we
are getting the response at least uh
it's showing is 403 error format in
error but that's fine we will be putting
up some web pages there in the Via WWE
HTML free or we can say in local Webroot
directory so that we will be able to
have some content so what we can do is
that we can have some Eco commands to
executed so that we can have some added
some content added up into the uh
particular uh files there so let's see
that what different contents we can do
so uh you can use the vi mode also to do
a uh you know couple of files so I'm
just using this Eco command
so um the moment I go for this execution
so what happens that a file will be
created into that uh Slash web root
there so
um I'm expecting that I have put up a
index.html page so if you feel that you
want to put some different page you can
always do and the moment you do the curl
now you will be able to see the same
response so whatever the things you put
up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some PHP files you want to put up some
PHP content all that stuff you can do it
now what I'm going to do is that rather
than just a HTML static contain I'm
going to put some PHP content that is
going to help me to get a file so my
Webroot will have now two files so
um if if you feel uh that index.html
file should have some uniform content
you can always do that you can pull some
of the websites also you can put that
into the you can do or get clone in the
web root and the whole application will
be started and now
if you feel that I got a info dot a PHP
file so I can use the NAT name into the
URL I have to modify the URL because uh
index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do if you want to
put up some different name you can
change the server configuration of nginx
and according to that it will work so um
when I do this so you will start getting
the output so this is the PHP content
output which is there it's a complete
information now it may look like a very
bulky content to you but when you put up
this one into the browser into the web
browser that will be a meaningful
information probably in terms of some
tables or something like that right so
um let me scroll to the top here so you
can see that it's showing an error sorry
it's showing in the output and this
output represents it you've got a
particular PHP content here so this is
how we will be able to have a container
and uh you know this container is up and
running you can modify to at any level
you feel that you want to prepare a
Docker image with the code embedded also
you can have the kit clone or you can
have this configuration into some git
repository have the source code also
there and then prepare a complete bundle
all together so this is what we have in
this demo how we can deploy a container
and a container up and running in case
of the docker yes
today we're going to cover what is a
Docker container why you would want to
consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a Docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly the
different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest OS and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
Dev and Ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
container that's running Apache Tomcat
with Java a second container is running
SQL server and microsoft.net environment
the third container is running python
with mySQL these are all running just
fine within the docker engine and
sitting on top of a host OS which could
be Linux it really could be any host OS
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to have a solution that can
be shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional Java application so you have
your developers working in JBoss on his
system and he's coding away a and he has
to get that code over to a test and now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install JBoss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get it as
close as possible and then at some point
you want to be able to test this within
your production environment so you send
it over to a system administrator who
would then also have to install JBoss on
their environment as well yeah this just
seems to be a whole lot of duplication
so why go through the problem of
installing JBoss three times and this is
where things get really interesting
because the challenge you have today is
that it's very difficult to almost
impossible to have identical
environments if you're just installing
software locally on devices the
developers probably got a whole bunch of
development software they could be
conflicting with the JBoss environment
the tester has similar testing software
but probably doesn't have all the
development software and certainly the
system administrator won't have all the
tools that the developer and test to
have their own tools and so what you
want to be able to do is kind of get
away from The Challenge you have of
having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where Docker comes in and Docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your Docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what Docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of Docker and kind of go
through what Docker container is and how
to create a Docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of use
using Docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is darker so
Docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer a
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into the
architecture so you understand why
Docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest API connection
to a Docker Daemon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker demon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a Docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest API and that sends
command line to the docker Daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with Docker the docker
Dem then checks the request against
um the docking components and then
performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create a container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have the devops
tools that we're looking to use
throughout this series of videos are all
environments that can be scripted and
this is really important because it
allows you to be able to duplicate and
scale the environments that you want to
be able to build very quickly and
effectively the agile container itself
has all of the applications and the
dependencies of those applications in
one package you kind of think of it as a
really effective and efficient zip file
it's a little bit more than that but
it's one file that actually has
everything you need to be able to run
all of your Solutions the actual Docker
registry itself is an environment for
being able to host and distribute
different Docker images among your team
so say for instance you had a team of
developers that were working on multiple
different solutions so say you have a
team of developers and you have 50
developers and they're working on five
different applications you can actually
have the applications themselves the
containers shared in the docker registry
so each of those teams at any time check
out and have the latest container of
that latest image of the code that
you're working on so let's dig into what
actually is in a container so the
important part of a docking container is
that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtualized environment it has all your
Frameworks and your libraries and it
allows the teams to be able to build out
and run exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then will run in isolation
so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
and the actual folder itself is much
smaller it's very secure highly portable
and the boot up time is incredibly fast
so let's actually get into how you
actually create a Docker container so
the docket container itself is actually
built through command line and it's
built of a file and Docker image so the
actual Docker file is a text file that
contains all the instructions actions
that you would need to be able to create
that Docker image and then we'll
actually then create all of the project
code with inside of that image then the
image becomes the item that you would
share through the dockier registry you
would then use the command line and
we'll do this later on select Docker run
and then the name of the image to be
able to easily and effectively run that
image locally and again once you've
created the document you can store that
in the docker registry making it
available to anybody within your network
so something to bear in mind is that
Docker itself has its own registry
called Docker Hub and that is a public
restrict so you can actually go out and
see other doc images that have been
created and access those images as your
own company you may want to have your
own private repository so you want to be
able to go ahead and either do that
locally through your own repository or
you can actually get a licensed version
of Docker Hardware you can actually then
share those files now some me it's also
very interesting to know is that you can
have multiple versions of a Docker image
so if you have a different version
control different release versions and
you want to be able to test and write
code for those different release
versions because you may have different
setups you can certainly do that within
your Docker registry environment okay so
let's go ahead and we're going to create
a Docker image using some of our basic
Docker commands and so there are
essentially really you know kind of just
two commands that you're going to be
looking for one is the build command
another one is to actually put it into
your registry which is a push command so
if you want to get a image from a Docker
registry then you want to use the pull
command and a pull command simply pulls
the image from the registry and in this
example using ngi next as our registry
and we can actually then pull the image
down to our test environment on our
local machine so we're actually running
the container within our Docker
application on a local machine wherever
people then have the image run exactly
as it would in production and then you
can actually use the Run command to
actually use the docker image on your
local machine so just a you know a few
interesting tidbits about the docking
container once the container is created
a new layer is formed on top of the
docker image layer is called the
container layout each container has a
separate read write container layer and
any changes made in that docking
container is then reflected upon that
particular container layout and if you
want to delete the container layer the
container layer also gets deleted as
well so you know why with using Docker
and containers be of benefit to you well
you know some of the things that are
useful is that containers have no
external dependencies for the
applications they run once you actually
have the container running locally it
has everything it needs to be able to
run the application so there's no having
to install additional pieces of software
such as the example we gave with JBoss
at the beginning of the presentation now
the container is a really lightweight so
it makes it very easy to share the
containers amongst your teams whether
it's a developer whether it's a tester
whether it's somebody on your operations
environment it's really easy to share
those containers amongst your entire
team different data volumes can be
easily reused and shared among multiple
containers and again this is another big
benefit and this is a reflection of the
lightweight nature of your containers
the container itself also runs in
isolation which means that it is not
impacted by any dependencies you may
have on your own local environment so
it's a completely sandboxed environment
so some of the questions you might ask
us you know can you run multiple
containers together without the need to
start each one individually and you know
what yes you can with Docker compose
docking compose allows you to run
multiple containers in a single service
and again this is a reflection on the
lightweight nature of containers within
the docker environment so we're going to
end our presentation by looking at some
of the basic commands that you'd have
within Docker so we have here on the
left hand side we have a Docker
container and then the command for each
item we're actually going to go ahead
and use some of these commands and the
demo that we're going to do after this
presentation you'll see that in a moment
but just you know some of the basic
commands we have are committing the
docker image into the Container kill is
a you know standard kill command to you
know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stop working
then restart those containers but
suddenly you can look at all the image
all of the commands here and try them
out for yourself so we're going to go
ahead and start a demo of how to use the
basic commands to run Docker so to do
this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line now depending
whether you're running Linux PC or Mac
and we're going to go ahead and the
first thing we want to do is see what
our Docker image lists are so we can go
sudo Docker images and this will give us
well first we'll enter in our passwords
let's go enter that in and this will now
gives a list of our Docker images and
here are the dock images I have already
been created in the system and we can
actually go ahead and actually see the
processes that are actually running so
I'm going to go ahead and open up this
window a little bit more but this will
show you the actual processors and the
containers that we actually have and so
on the far left hand side you'll see
under names we have learn simply learn
be unscore cool these are all just
different ones that we've been working
on so let's go ahead and create a Docker
image so I'm going to do sudo
docker
run
Dash D Dash p
0.0.0.0 go on a t colon 80
Ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run an Ubuntu image and this
will run the latest image and what we
have here is a hash number and this hash
number is a unique name that defines the
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
pseudo.go.ps and this actually show us
down there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exits see so let's do sucker
PS Dash a and this lists all the
containers that I have running on my
machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running State and in the
exit State and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running Ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go so let's change that to that
new dock container to a running state so
scroll down and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
Dash it Dash Dash
name my
um so this is going to be the new
container name it's going to be my
Docker so this is how we name our Docker
environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
Ubuntu
and dash bin Dash Bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my Docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that Docker
image and let's go ahead and check
against the other running Docker images
to make sure it's running correctly so
sudo docker
PS
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you actually see my
Docker along with the other Docker
images that we created and it's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another Docker image
this to scrub this one and we'll put it
in rename
and we'll rename I'm putting the old
container name which is image and then
we'll put in the new container name and
let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
previously been called image is now
called Purple
so we do sudo Docker PS
to list all of our Docker images
and if we scroll up and there there we
go purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop container so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my Docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still there as an image it's
just not in an active stages what's
known as an exit state
so here we go
and there's my doco it's in an exited
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if you want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
RM
we'll remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep it's not not listed there under exit
State anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be all
right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
I think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's going
to kill it
oops no I guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have
so sudo docker
kill oh we're going to list out of the
ones that are running oh okay there we
go now yellow isn't in that list so
let's take I know let's take simply
learn and so we can actually go ahead
and let's write sudo Docker kill simply
learn
and that will actually kill an active
Docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's they simply learn container is
not active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
Docker container hey everyone welcome to
this simple on video on kubernetes full
course in this full course we will learn
everything about kubernetes in detail we
will begin this full course video with
understanding what exactly is kubernetes
is next we will see how to install
kubernetes and the differences between
kubernetes and Docker then we will look
into the services and components of
communities in detail after that we will
be discussing everything about the
architecture of kubernetes then we will
see how kubernetes can be implemented on
AWS finally we will conclude this video
by discussing the important kubernetes
interview questions and answers for
beginners and experienced candidates by
the end of this video I can assure you
that all your kubernetes career related
queries will have been answered
so let's start with an exciting video on
the configuration management tool before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit that Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn
hello and welcome to Simply learn in
this session we're going to cover what
kubernetes is and why you would want to
be using it within your devops team but
before we get started remember to hit
the like button if you like this video
and the Subscribe button if you want to
get notified about more of these videos
as they come out and as always if you
have any comments about content that
we're covering or questions that you
have on the subject please post them in
the comments below so let's get started
we're going to break up this
presentation into four key areas we're
going to talk about life before
kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits that kubernetes
brings to you particularly if you are
using containers in a devops environment
and then finally we're going to break
down the architecture and working
infrastructure for kubernetes so you
understand what's happening and why the
actions are happening the way that they
are so let's jump into our first section
of life before kubernetes so the way
that you have done work in the past or
you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
Solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a Data Center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to Blind code
out to Virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have error issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not look not effectively and not
load balance effectively across the
environment the problem that you have
with this kind of infrastructure is that
it gets very expensive uh you can only
install one piece of software one
service on one piece of Hardware so your
Hardware is being massively
underutilized this is where virtual
machines have become really popular with
a virtual machine you're able to have
better resource utilization and
scalability a much less cost and this
allows you to be able to run multiple
virtual machines on a single piece of
Hardware the problem is is that VMS are
for virtual machines are not perfect
either some of the challenges you run
with VMS is that the actual hardware and
software need needed to manage the VM
environment can be expansive there are
security risks with virtual with VMS
there are security risks with VMS there
have been data breaches recorded about
solutions that run in virtualized
environments you also run into an issue
of availability and this is largely
because you can only have a finite
number of virtual machines running on a
piece of hardware and this results in
limitations and restrictions and the
types of environment you want to be
running and then finally setting up and
managing a virtualized environment is
time consuming it can take a lot of time
and it can also get very expensive so
how about
well kubernetes is a tool that allows
you to manage containerized deployment
of solutions an inherently kubernetes is
a tool that is really a Next Level
maturity of deployment so if you can
think of your maturity curve as
deploying code in directly to Hardware
in a Data Center and then deploying your
solutions to Virtual machines the next
evolution of that deployment is to use
containers and kubernetes so let's kind
of go through and look at the
differences between a virtual machine
and kubernetes we've got a few here that
we want to highlight and you'll get an
understanding of what the differences
are between the two so first of all with
virtual machines there is inherently
security risk and what you'll find as we
get dig through the architecture later
in the presentation is that kubernetes
is inherently secure and this is largely
because of the Legacy code the legacy of
kubernetes and where it came from we
will talk about that in just a moment
but kubernetes is inherently secure
virtual machines are not easily portable
now with that said they they are
technically portable they're just not
very easily portable whereas with
kubernetes it's working with Docker
container Solutions it is extremely
portable and it means that you can
actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of highlight
from differences virtual machines use
much less isolation when building out
the encapsulated environment then
kubernetes does for instance with a
virtual machine you have to run
hypervisor on top of the OS and hardware
and then inside of the virtual machine
you also have to have the operating
system as well whereas in contrast on a
kubernetes environment because it's
leveraging a Docker container and or
container-like Technologies it only has
to have the OS and the hardware and then
inside of each container it doesn't need
to have that additional iOS layer it's
able to inherit what it needs to be able
to run the application this makes the
whole solution much more flexible and
allows you to run many more containers
on a piece of Hardware than versus
running virtual machines on a single
piece of Hardware so as we've
highlighted here our VMS are not as
portable as kubernetes and kubernetes is
portable directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of containers it is much
less time consuming because you can
actually script and automatically
allocate resource to nodes within your
kubernetes environment because it allows
the infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
while we are running into a solution
where kubernetes had to come about
because the demand for having more
highly scalable solutions that are more
efficient was just really a natural
evolution of this software deployment
model that started with pushing out code
to physical hardware and then pushing
code out to Virtual machines and then
needing to have a solution much more
sophisticated kubernetes would have come
about at some point in time I'm just
really glad it came back when it did so
what is kubernetes does this dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence kubernetes is
an open source platform that allows you
to manage and deploy and maintain groups
of containers and a container is
something like Docker and if you're a
developing code you're probably already
using Docker today consider kubernetes
as the tool that manages multiple Docker
environments together now we talk a lot
talked about darker and as a container
solution with kubernetes the reality is
is that kubernetes can actually use
other container tools out there but
Docker just simply is the most popular
container out there both these tools are
open source that's why they're so
popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your Solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live and exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
Google and the original project was
Google book Google Borg it does exactly
what kubernetes does today but
kubernetes was Rewritten from the ground
up and then released as an open source
project in 2014 so that people outside
of Google could take advantage of the
power of kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native Computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
Microsoft Azure AWS Google Cloud all of
them will leverage kubernetes and it's
just become the the de facto tool for
managing large groups of containers so
let's kind of Step through some of the
key benefits that you'd experience from
kubernetes so we have nine key benefits
the first it is highly portable it is
100 open source code and this means that
you can actually go ahead and contribute
to this code project if you want to
through GitHub the ability to scale up
the solution is incredible
um what's the the history of kubernetes
being part of a Google project for
managing the Google network and
infrastructure kind of really sets the
groundwork for having a solution that is
highly scalable the out of the high
scalability also comes the need for high
availability and this is the desire to
be able to have a highly efficient and
highly energized environment but also
you can really rely on so if you're
building outer kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're maintaining and it's really
designed for deployment so you can
script out the environment and actually
have it as part of your devops model so
you can scale up and meet the demands of
your customer then what you'll find is
that the load balancing is extremely
efficient and it allows you to
distribute the load efficiently across
your entire network so your network
remains stable and then also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an SSD on the hardware
that the kubernetes is maintaining or if
the kubernetes environment is pulling
storage from a public Cloud such as
Azure or AWS you can actually go ahead
and make that available to your entire
system and you can inherit the security
that goes back and forth between the
cloud environments and one of the things
you'll find consistent with kubernetes
is that it is designed for a cloud-first
environment um kubernetes as well is
that it's it's really a self-healing
environment so if something happens or
something fails uh kubernetes will
detect that failure and then either
restart the process kill the process or
replace it and then because of that you
also have automated rollouts and
rollbacks in case you need to be able to
manage the state of the environment and
then finally you have automatic bin
packaging so you can actually specify
the compute power that's being used from
CPU and ramp for each container so let's
dig into the final area which is the
actual kubernetes architecture and we're
going to cover this at a high level
there's actually another video that you
can that simply learn has developed
which digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a clustered based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls
um and all of the activities within your
entire kubernetes infrastructure and
then you have nodes that actually are
running on Linux machines
um outs that are controlled by the
master so let's kind of go through some
of these areas so if we look at the
kubernetes master to begin with
um we'll start with uh Etc is this is a
tool that allows for the configuration
and the information and the management
of nodes within your cluster and one of
the key features that you'll find with
all of the tools that are managed within
either a the master environment or
within a node is that they are all
accessible via the API server and what's
interesting about the API server is that
it's a restful based infrastructure
which means that you can actually secure
each connection with SSL and other
security models between sure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
Daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so the other tools really are
the the infrastructure and you can
consider them the administration site um
of the master whereas controller is the
management it actually pushes out all of
the controls via the API server so let's
actually dig into one of the actual
nodes themselves and there are three key
areas of the nodes one is the docker
environment which actually helps and
manage and maintain the container that's
actually inside of the node and then you
have the Kubler which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the API server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are of extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node now the
kubernetes Mazda has the instructions of
what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those instructors to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way hi guys in today's video I am going
to show you how to install Ubuntu on
kubernetes kubernetes is an open source
platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is sudo app get
update which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install doco dot IO
you have to choose y
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's that so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo systemctl
start Docker and pseudo systemctl enable
dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because curl
command is used to send data using a URL
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
code
so you have to select Y and this will
take few minutes
[Music]
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download an add key for kubernetes
installation from a URL so let's go
ahead with that pseudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo app key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using C or sudo CH mode command
okay so the permission has changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a URL
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubadium cubectal and
kubernetes CNA so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap of
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap off
hyperlink now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
qadian in it
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so moving forward the next step is to
deploy Parts using the following command
[Music]
now the parts have been deployed to our
Network to see all the pods you have to
use the command pseudo cubectil get
pause
they exceed the password being deployed
hello and in this video we're going to
cover a common conversation which is
kubernetes versus darker but before we
jump into that I want you to hit the
Subscribe button so you get notified
about new content as it gets made
available and If you hit the
notification button that notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from Simply learn in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus Docker so let's go through a
couple of scenarios let's do one for
kubernetes and then one for Docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problem specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with Bose and Bose had a large catalog
of products that kept growing and their
infrastructure had to change so the way
that they looked at that was actually
establishing two primary goals to be
able to allow their product groups to be
able to easier more easily catch up to
the scale of their business so after
going through a number of solutions they
ended up coming up with a solution of
having kubernetes running their iot
platform as a service inside of Amazon's
AWS cloud service and what you'll see
with both these products is they're very
Cloud friendly but here we have um Bose
and kubernetes working together with AWS
to be able to scale up and meet the
demands of their product catalog and so
the result is that we're able to
increase the number of number production
deployments significantly by taking the
number of services from being large
bulky Services down to small micro
Services being able to handle as many as
1250 plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at
darker and see what a similar problem
that people would have so the problem is
with PayPal and PayPal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and PayPal doesn't just have
PayPal they have Braintree and venmo so
the challenge that PayPal was really
being given is that they had different
architectures which resulted in
different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with PayPal
through to a modern architecture with a
venmo through the use of Docker paper
was able to unified application delivery
and be able to centralize the management
of all of the containers with one
existing group the net net result is
that PayPal was able to migrate over 700
applications into Docker Enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this Ultra ultimately open up
a 50 percent increase in availability
for being able to add in additional time
for building testing and deploying of
applications just a huge win for PayPal
now let's dig into kubernetes and Docker
and so kubernetes is an open source
platform and it's designed for being
able to maintain a large number of
containers and what you're going to find
is that your argument for kubernetes
versus Docker isn't a real argument it's
kubernetes and Docker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and Docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with Docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to create a
nice consistent experience so that your
developers are working in the same
containers that are then also pushed out
to production so with Docker you're able
to manage multiple containers running on
the same Hardware much more efficiently
than you are with a VM environment the
productivity around Docker is extremely
high you're able to keep your
applications very isolated the
configuration for dark here is really
quick and easy you can be up and running
in minutes with Docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so if we look at the
deployment between the two and the
differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of PODS and
services in its deployment whereas with
Docker it's around about deploying
services in containers so the the
difference
um here is that kubernetes is going to
manage the entire environment and then
and that environment consisting of PODS
and inside of a pod you're going to have
all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers are
going to control the services that
actually power the app applications that
are being deployed kubernetes is by
default an auto scaling solution it has
it turned on and is always available
whereas a Docker does not and and that's
not surprising because Docker is a tool
for building out Solutions whereas
kubernetes is about managing your
infrastructure kubernetes is going to
run health checks on the liveness and
Readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas Docker
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now I'm not going to
kid you kubernetes is quite hard to set
up it's it's if of the tools that you're
going to be using in your devops
environment isn't it's not an easy setup
for you to use and for this reason you
want to really take advantage of the
services within Azure and other similar
Cloud environments where they actually
will do the setup for you Docker in
contrast is really easy to set up you
can as I mentioned earlier you can be up
and running in a few minutes as you
would expect the fault tolerance within
kubernetes is very high and this is by
Design because the architecture of
kubernetes is built on the same
architecture that Google uses for
managing its entire Cloud infrastructure
in contrast Docker has lower fault
tolerance but that's because it's just
managing the the surfaces within its own
containers what you'll find is that most
public Cloud providers will provide
support for both kubernetes and Docker
here we've highlighted Microsoft Azure
because they were very quick to jump on
and support kubernetes but the realities
is that today Google Amazon and many
other providers are having first level
support for kubernetes it's just become
extremely popular in a very very short
time frame the companies using both
kubernetes and Docker is vast and every
single day there are more and more
companies using it and you should be
able to look and see whether or not you
can add your own company to this list
hello and welcome to Simply learn today
we're going to be giving you a
kubernetes tutorial we'll provide the
overview of how and why you should be
using kubernetes but before we get
started don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from Simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus Docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we're going to
do a deep dive into the actual
kubernetes architecture itself and how
kubernetes and runs and operates within
your network and then finally we're
going to look at some kubernetes these
use cases of how you can actually apply
best learnings that other companies have
used with kubernetes we'll finish
everything off with a demo where we
actually step through and use some of
the actual codes that you can actually
use to run from your terminal window to
actually activate kubernetes itself so
with that said let's jump in so why
kubernetes well kubernetes is really
being built from allowing you to be able
to have a more reliable infrastructure
the tool itself is designed to manage
the containers you have within your
network it's very modular in
architecture which allows it to be very
easy to be able to maintain and to be
able to scale and meet the demands that
your current customers are offering you
today the actual ability for you to be
able to deploy and update software at
scale is really at the heart and center
of kubernetes it's really well there's
one of the reasons why kubernetes was
created was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into 10 tens of
thousands of networks and servers within
a Data Center and then finally when you
start working with kubernetes really
what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building Cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud-centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by Google Google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the data structured and
data infrastructure that they had within
their Network they really liked it and
one of the big benefits that kubernetes
that Google provided is that they
converted their code into an open source
program that they released as kubernetes
in 2014 and made an open source this
means is that any company can use
kubernetes there's no charge for it all
you have to do is know how to use the
command line to actually get up and
running the benefit of kubernetes being
open source is that most Cloud providers
now support kubernetes so whether you're
using Microsoft Azure you're using
Google cloud or AWS you'll find that you
can actually use kubernetes and
kubernetes and at a core really helped
eliminate manual processes so it allowed
for deploying and scaling your
container-based Solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of Step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes Within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 it doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes is
also will manage the actual containers
themselves including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great benefit of
working with kubernetes is that uh not
only is it a cloud-centric solution but
it was really built from a core need of
a secure solution so security is at the
heart and center of all the work you're
doing which really helps benefit any
teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored so that when you
have nodes that have your containers the
health of those nodes has been
constantly communicated back to uh the
kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment has always been
managed and checked so if you have any
additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done kubernetes will help
you automate those manual process
accesses if something does go wrong you
can actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll bag
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local SSD storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage fire the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and Docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit kubernetes and Docker often
get connected with each other and
largely because kubernetes manages
containers and Docker is really famous
for creating the most popular container
management solution which is called
Docker if you're a developer you're
probably already using Docker today so
one of the things that kubernetes is
really really good at is that it manages
containers at scale and just massive
volume of containers Docker swarm is
docker's alternative to kubernetes it's
a tool that allows you to also manage
large number large numbers of containers
there are differences between the two of
them and right now without doubt the
most popular open source solution out
there is kubernetes from Google it just
has a massive Community behind it and
the community really have embraced
kubernetes and yes the original product
was by developed by Google but Google
has been great stewards and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product Docker
swarm is actually managed and developed
by Docker there is a smaller Community
but it is also a very passionate
community and the reason being is is
that both products are actually pretty
good and you just really kind of have to
choose which one you want to go with
without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm Community
um but with that said Docker swarm is
really easy to set up so if you are used
to working within the docker environment
you'll be able to set up Docker swarm
very very quickly whereas kubernetes
does require some heavy lifting to get
up and running now with that said if you
are using Microsoft Azure or Google
Cloud very often those environments will
actually set up kubernetes for you so
you don't have to do it and you can
actually then focus on writing the
instructions to maintain your kubernetes
environment kubernetes has extremely
high voltage tolerance again it's
because kubernetes is has been Road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on man managing sites such as
Gmail google.com YouTube I mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to Docker swarm which has lower fault
tolerance
um and this really kind of leads into
um the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee strong clusters and management
just a really reliable environment Dr
swarm however is able to take containers
to deploy them into large casters very
very quickly two interesting differences
is that with kubernetes the load
balancing is still manual and be
interesting to watch how kubernetes
matures that skill set in contrast load
balancing is automatic within Docker
swarm so let's dig into the kubernetes
architecture and just kind of expose
some of those key elements um if you're
interested in actually having a very
deep dive into kubernetes architecture
we have already got another video and we
should have a link in the comments that
you can see select that will take you to
that video as well but this will provide
you an overview as well um so the way
that kubernetes runs is that it uses
nodes to actually manage all the
individual Hardware within a specific
unit and so a node is really a physical
machine in a data center or a virtual
machine and when you're setting up an
environment on a cloud environment such
as Microsoft Azure or Google cloud or
AWS kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual nodes
but actually works with the cluster as a
whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to imagine the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster and it's very flexible
within kubernetes you can have local
storage such as an SSD card or a
traditional local local storage or you
can actually connect to the cloud and
use cloud-based storage and the benefit
that's cloud-based storage offers you is
that you are increasingly Moving Your
solution into more of a hardware free
environment cloud-based architecture
where you're not reliant on a physical
piece of Hardware within your data
center and why that's important is that
it gives you the opportunity to scale up
your Solutions much more effectively so
if you need to increase the hard drive
space you can do that very easily from
the cloud whereas local hardware is a
little bit harder to manage great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to choose from and so the the next
layer down is the actual management of
the application and that's within a
container and as mentioned earlier
Docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're probably already using
Docker as it was a natural maturity from
using a virtual machine but kubernetes
itself will actually manage the
containers that you have within your
nodes and so you have a collection of
containers working together and then you
pull those together into what's called a
pod and what's great is kubernetes will
actually manage the health of that pod
so if a container or a pod fails
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the pods themselves will actually be
managed by kubernetes and you really
want to let kubernetes do this because
it's allowing you to step away from the
manual management of Parts your
environment is just going to be
healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from Services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called Ingress and going back
earlier we talked about how security is
a key part of all the work that goes
into kubernetes and this is a great
example of where you can use an external
service but still have that layer of
security that is vital for your solution
because to be able to provide the
Ingress connection kubernetes requires
an SSL connection which automatically
allows for secure data transfer
absolutely fantastic so here we have an
overview of the actual architecture on
the right hand side we have our nodes
and the pods within our nodes and within
those pods are the containers on the
left hand side we have the master
architecture and the master architecture
is the actual brains behind the work
that you're doing it's actually managing
the schedules the controllers for all of
the nodes and then and the bottom left
hand side we have commands which are
written on a local workstation and those
commands are pushed up to the master so
let's kind of dig a little bit further
into the architecture of the master so
the master itself is comprised of a
number of key components again this is
the tool that's going to manage your
entire kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the etcd
control manager scheduler API server and
the key for components are etct or the
cluster store the controller manager the
scheduler and the API server the cluster
store is the tool where all the details
of the work that you're doing is stored
now it's going to manage the rules it's
going to manage all the instructions and
this is where you're going to post that
information the controller is actually
going to then perform the tasks that are
stored in the cluster store and as you'd
expect the schedule is the tool that
actually controls when instructions and
tasks are pushed out to all the pods and
nodes within your network and then
finally you have an API server which
allows you to be able able to control
all the operations the actual operations
themselves are all the instructions
written as rest instructions and which
allows you to take advantage of the
security that has been built into rest
and so you end up with a worker slave
architecture and slaves are all the
different nodes and pods within your
network and so a pod itself will have
multiple one or more multiple containers
and then each container and then each
pod will have a Docker container a
kublet and a kubernetes proxy and the
these are tools to allow you to
communicate back up to the master layer
so the docker is the actual container
itself and this is going to actually run
your application and the instructions
here are to pull down the correct
container from the docker images that
you have within your library the cubelet
is going to manage your containers and
your container instructions that will be
deployed to the cubelet are going to be
written in either yaml or Json format
yaml is just great if you haven't had a
chance to start working with yaml I
certainly encourage you to do so it's
very easy to pick up if you know any XML
you'll pick up yaml very quickly and
finally the kubernetes proxy is the tool
that interacts with the master
environment within the kubernetes
network and allows all the instructions
for that are pushed to the cubelete and
to Docker to be able to perform
effectively so let's have a look at some
of the companies using kubernetes there
are a lot and if you're doing any work
today in the cloud and or even if you're
just starting off and doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes for
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are Spotify sap eBay and of
course some of the the big companies out
there Google with their entire network
of solutions and Microsoft with office
and their tools so let's take a step
into to a you but now let's have a look
at a kubernetes use case and in this
example we're going to look at the New
York Times and how they use kubernetes
to solve a problem that their IIT
Department was struggling with so when
New York Times started working after
their data centers their their actual
deployments were small and the
applications were managed across VMS but
the problem is is that as New York Times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital Solutions
and at some point they realized that
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is I think
typical for a lot of companies is that
they treated a the cloud hosted provider
in the same way as they would with a
Data Center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our Solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
Amazon and start thinking of them as
Cloud first solution and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using Google Cloud platform with
kubernetes as a service and to provide
greater efficiency and so by using
kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
Solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you do the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the New York Times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to to Solutions through a more
traditional ticket based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
New York Times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going to look through
um and uh we'll let you uh read through
this but uh we have a cluster which is a
set of machines physical vertical in
which applications are managed and run
we have a node that are the working
machines that run containerized
applications and other workloads there
is the pod which is within a node and is
a group of containers that are deployed
together on the same host we have
replication controllers and a
replication controller is used to define
a pods life cycle rather than to create
the pods directly we have a selector
which is an expression matched label to
filter specific resources labels are key
value pairs that are attached to objects
such as pods and the key value pair or
the label can be filtered organize and
perform operate operations on resources
replication sense Define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
managed when you want to either replace
a pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the direction which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to a resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single IP address and DNS Name
by which the pods can be accessed so
this time what we want to do is take you
through kubernetes demo actually runs
through some of these basic controls so
we're going to take you through a video
of how to actually install kubernetes
and to use some of the basic
instructions so kubernetes is the most
wildly used platform for container
management the first step is to actually
install the necessary dependencies so
let's see if there's any updates first
so the first so to check if there's any
updates we use the command sudo app dash
get update we're entering our password
and this looks like it's going to take a
few minutes because we've got a few
updates that need to be running all
right we're done all right next we're
going to write sudo app get install Dash
y
apt-transport https and this will
install all of the dependencies we need
to actually start installing the
solutions needed for kubernetes all
right that was quick now we're going to
put in the docker dependency and the way
we do that is write the command sudo apt
install Docker dot IO I'll go typo
correct that quickly and put in y so vs
and we continue and it's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install Docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have Docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start Docker and
enable little Docker using our sudo
commands
alright so that's all done so let's
start to enable Docker we're going to
using so we're going to use sudo
systemctl start Docker and sudo
systemctl enable Docker this will be
quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to install the curl command and
then kubolate Cube C and then cubeadm
and we're going to install all the
necessary tools we'll do the curl
command cubelet cubic C2 and Cube ADM
and so let's go ahead and put in the
sudo apt-get install Curl we're going to
get a prompt we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudo curl dash s
and then we have a long URL which is
https
packages.cloud google.com apt dark
apt-key Dot gpg
sudo
apt-key there we go group my typo there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of a folder so we do that
with sudo chmod 777 slash Etc apt slash
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit and we're going to
create a simple file and so what we're
going to type in is the following
command DB hey cgbt
apt-kubernetes Dot IO slash kubernetes
Dash xenial Main and we're going to save
this file in the ETC folder and then
look for and then a APT which is going
to be down a little bit and there we
have it and we're going to save it in
the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as kubernetes dot list and
we'll save that and then we can close
out the notepad and go back to the
terminal window and let's look and see
see if there are any updates again so
we're going to go ahead and run apt-get
update and it's going to run any updates
from what we've created and we want to
check what's in the folder and so we do
cat accept
apt
sources.d kubernetes dot list and there
we are it shows what we have in that
text file and so we're going to go ahead
and we're going to install cubelet cubic
cubic 2 and Cube ADM but first we're
going to have to initialize the master
I'm going to show you what an error you
would get if you were to install cubelet
and the other files too quickly you get
a fine error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubic tool and kubernetes cni and
so we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap-up dash dash a and now we're going
to initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo Cube ADM in
it and this will take a few minutes for
it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the Pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cuboo
Cube CTL apply and then we have a long
Pathway to type out which is dash out of
hqbs raw githubs content.com choreos
flannel Master documentation Cube file
Dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by
creating
um mktr Dash p and then we have dollar
sign home dash dot Cube and create that
new directory and sudo cp-i and then the
path will be
Etc
kubernetes
admin.conf and then dial sign home slash
dot Cube dot slash config
and then final one will be pseudo
c-h-o-w-n dollar sign open Prime ID Dash
U closed paren colon dollar sign a brand
ID slash Dash G close parenth door sign
home slash dot Q slash config all right
now we're going to go ahead and deploy
and uh let's see and oh yeah I think I
have a typo in my command here yep oh
yes I did have a typo and so
um I've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spelled with a
t not an S and then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic Cube CTL
apply dash dash F and then we're just
going to change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
pods that we have in our Network and so
we're going to do that by writing the
commands sudo cubic TCL get pods Dash or
Dash Dash namespaces and it should list
all of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
note so let's see what we have here so
we can use the command sudo you know
cubic TL get nodes there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
nginx as service and we're going to do
that with the command sudo cubic CTL run
Dash Dash image equals nginx and we're
going to put this into Port 80 so it's
going to be nginx Dash app dash dash
Port equals 80 dash dash environment EMV
equals uh ubunt open quota domain equals
cluster close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo Cube CTL exposed
deployments nginx Dash app dash dash
Port equals 80 dash dash name equals
nginx Dash HTTP and once we've done this
we will be able to then run the command
to actually see our services and
there'll be quite a few of them
and our final command is sudo docker
ps-a
we have quite a lot of lists quite a lot
of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
Docker up and running and uh with some
basic commands and it is worth going
through a few times to again get right
um but once you actually have the
kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your document environment
and containers it's extremely powerful
if getting your learning started it's
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skill up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
welcome to kubernetes architecture from
Simply learn we're going to take a deep
dive into the kubernetes architecture if
you're new to kubernetes we already have
an introduction that goes and provides
an overview of kubernetes and we have
the link below so you can go straight to
that if you want to have a refresher
otherwise hang around and join us in
this presentation and if you want to see
more of these videos hit the Subscribe
button and if you want to get notified
hit the notification Bell and every time
we post up a new video you'll get the
notification right onto your phone or on
your desktop that the new video has been
uploaded and as always if you have any
questions please post them in the
comments below we do read the questions
or we try to respond to all of them as
quickly as we can with that said let's
jump into kubernetes architecture so
we're going to break out the
presentation into the following areas
we're going to cover what kubernetes is
and why you'd want to be using it we're
going to introduce the actual
architecture and provide an overview of
how it contains the containers and the
other components that you'd have within
the architecture we'll also compare
communities with Docker swarm and one of
the things that you hear with kubernetes
almost in the same breath as Docker and
we have to be careful not to confuse
Docker from a container point of view
and Docker swarm which is a container
management tool and kubernetes is also a
container management tool so compare the
two of those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally do a deep dive into the
architecture of kubernetes and provide a
case study of where kubernetes has been
used successfully in the past so let's
jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so kubernetes is a tool that
was designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally by Google out
of the Google Borg solution and then
Open Source by Google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you're a
developer in devops and you're working
with Docker then you're used to the
concept of the container and you'll also
know that containers and Cloud
technology these tend to be almost
breathed in the same breath so the work
that you're doing with kubernetes is to
be able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and it allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points kubernetes itself
is an open source solution originally
developed by Google but it is available
on most Cloud platforms today so AWS
Google Cloud Microsoft Azure all of them
support kubernetes and what you'll find
is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is flooded up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of these I think one of the big
benefits of kubernetes is this module
and T is that it really breaks down
containers into their smaller parts and
once you do that it becomes much more
efficient for you as an administrator to
be able to manage that entire
environment the reproductibility of
kubernetes is extremely high you can
build out infrastructures very quickly
and have them being able to imagine and
have containers coming on and off and
killed and created to be able to help
load balance your entire environment and
so again you know we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about is being able to
manage your applications that are
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to deploy Solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas so you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and Master is comprised
of four key areas which essentially
control all of your nodes and the node
contains multiple parts and each pod has
your Docker container built into it so
consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of PODS I'm
sorry infinite number of nodes are being
managed by the master environment so you
have your cluster which is a collection
of servers that maintain the
availability and the compute power such
as RAM CPU and disk utilization and you
have the master which is really
components that control and schedule the
activities of your network and then you
have the node which actually hosts the
actual Docker virtual machine itself and
be able to actually control and
communicate back to the master the
health of that pod and we'll get into
more detail on the architecture texture
later in the presentation so you know
you keep hearing me talk about
containers but they really are the
center of the work that you're doing
with kubernetes and can the concept
around kubernetes and containers is
really just a natural evolution of where
we've been with internet and digital
Technologies over the last 10 15 years
so before kubernetes you had tools where
you either running virtual machines or
you're running data centers that had to
maintain and manage and notify you of
any interruptions in your network
kubernetes is the tool that actually
comes in and helps address those
interruptions and manages them for you
so the solution to this is the use of
containers so you can think of
containers as that Natural Evolution
from you know uh 15 20 years ago you
would have written your code and posted
it to a Data Center and more recently
you probably posted your code to a
virtual machine and then move the
virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container and
everything is self-contained and can be
pushed out to your environment and the
thing that's great about containers
they're they're isolated environments
very easy for developers to work on them
but it's also really easy for operations
teams to be able to move a container
into production so let's kind of step
and back and look at a competing product
to kubernetes which is Docker swarm now
one of the things we have to remember is
that Docker containers which are
extremely popular I'm built by the
company Docker and made open source and
Docker actually has other products one
of those other products is Docker swarm
and Docker swarm is a tool that allows
you to be able to manage multiple
containers so if we look at some of the
uh the benefits of using Docker swarm
versus kubernetes and one thing that
you'll find is that both tools have
strengths and weaknesses but it's really
good that they're both out there because
it helps keep it really kind of
justifies the importance of having these
kind of tools so kubernetes was designed
originally from the ground up to be the
auto scaling whereas took a swarm isn't
the load balancing is automatic on
Docker Swan whereas with kubernetes you
have to manually configure load
balancing across your nodes the
installation for Docker swarm is really
fast and easy I mean you can be up and
running within minutes kubernetes takes
a little bit more time is a little bit
more complicated eventually you'll get
there um I mean it's not like it's going
to take you days and weeks but it's it
is a tool that's a when you compare the
two Docker swarms much easier to get up
and running now what's interesting is
that kubernetes is incredibly scalable
and it's you know that's its its real
strength is its ability to have strong
clusters whereas with Docker swarm it's
cluster stream isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison but
kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability kubernetes was designed for
by Google to scale up and support Google
Cloud Network infrastructure they both
allow you to be able to share storage
volumes with Docking you can actually do
it with any container with that is
managed by the docker swamp whereas with
kubernetes it manages the storage with
the pods and a product can have multiple
containers within it but you can't take
it down to the level of the container
interestingly uh kubernetes does have a
graphical user interface for being able
to control and manage the environment
the reality however is that you're
likely to be using terminal to actually
make the controls and Commands to
control your either Docker swarm or
kubernetes environment and it's great
that it has a GUI and to get you started
but once you're up and running you're
going to be using terminal window for
those fast quick administrative controls
that you need to make so let's look at
the hardware components for kubernetes
so and what's interesting is that
kubernetes is extremely light of all the
systems that we're looking at is
extremely lightweight
um it's allows you to have you compare
it to like a virtual machine which is
very heavy you know kubernetes is
extremely lightweight and other uses any
resources at all interesting enough
though is that if you are looking at the
usage of CPU it's better to actually
take it for
um the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combined together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center
um so you can have persistent volumes um
such as a local SSD or you can actually
attach to a cloud data storage again
kubernetes is really designed for the
cloud I would encourage you to use cloud
storage wherever possible rather than
relying on physical storage the reason
being is that if you connect to cloud
storage and you need to flex your your
storage the cloud will do that for you I
mean that's just an inherent part of why
you'd have cloud storage whereas if
you're connecting to physical storage
you're always restricted to the
limitations of the physical Hardware so
that's um kind of pivot and look at the
software components as compared to the
hardware components so the main part of
the components is the actual container
and all of the software running in the
container runs on Linux so if you have
documents stored as a developer on your
machine it's actually running inside of
Linux and that's what makes it so
lightweight and really one of the things
that you'll find is that most data
centers and Cloud providers now are
running predominantly on Linux inside of
the um the the container itself is then
managed inside of a pod and a part is
really just a group of containers
bundles together and the kubernetes
scheduler and proxy server then actually
manage what how the pods are actually
pushed out into your your kubernetes
environment the the parts themselves can
actually then share resources both
networking and storage so pods aren't
pushed out manually they're actually
managed through a layer of abstractions
and part of their deployment and and
this is the strength of kubernetes you
you define your infrastructure and then
kubernetes will then merge it for you
and there isn't that problem of manual
management of PODS if you have to manage
the deployment of them and you that's
simply taken away and it's completely
automated and the the final area of
software Services is on Ingress and this
is really the secure way of being able
to have communication from outside of
the cluster and passing of information
into that cluster and again this is done
securely through SSL layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at a use case of
how communities has been employed so
kubernetes again is we looked at this
diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which
controls the scheduling the
communication and the actual commands
that you have created and pushes those
out and manages the health of your
entire node Network and each node has
various pods so we like break this down
so the master node is the most vital
component with the master you have four
key controls you have Etc controller
manager schedule and API server the
cluster store Etc this actually manages
the details and values that you've
developed on your local workstation and
then we'll work with the out the control
scheduling API server to communicate
that out those instructions of how your
infrastructure should look like to your
entire network the control manager is
really an API server and again this is
all about security so we use restful
apis which can be packaged in SSL to
communicate back and forth across your
pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
at every single layer of abstraction the
communication is secure the schedule as
the name would imply really schedules
when tasks get sent out to the actual
nodes themselves the nodes themselves
are are dumb nodes they just have the
applications
um running on them the master and the
scum is really doing all of the work to
make sure that your entire network is
running efficiently and then you have
the API server which has your rest
commands and the communication and back
and forth across your networks that is
secure and efficient so your node
environment is where all the work that
you do with your containers gets pushed
out too so
um a work is really a it's a combination
of contain in each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers on
a node that all make logical sense to
have together within each node you have
a Docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
you have your cubelet which is a service
for conveying information back and forth
to the service about the actual health
of the kubernetes node itself and then
finally you have the proxy server and
the proxy server is able to manage the
nodes the volumes the the creation of
new containers and actually helps pass
the community the the health of the
container back up to the master to see
whether or not the containers should be
either killed stop started or updated so
finally let's look at see where
kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have greater performance and with
the end goal being able to Delight the
customer increase value to the customer
and enhance increased value and revenue
into the organization so your example of
this is a company called BlackRock where
they actually went through the process
of implementing kubernetes and so they
could so BlackRock had a chance where
they needed to be able to have much more
Dynamic access to their resources uh
they were running complex installations
on people's desktops and it was just
really really difficult to be able to
manage their entire infrastructure so
they actually went and pivoted to using
kubernetes and this allowed them to be
able to be much more scalable and
expansive in the in the management of
their infrastructure and as you can
imagine kubernetes was then hooked into
their entire existing system and has
really become a key part of the success
that BlackRock is now experiencing of a
very stable infrastructure um and the
bottom line is that BlackRock is now
able to have confidence in in their
infrastructure and be able to give their
confidence as back to their customers
through the implementation and more
rapid deployment of additional features
and services because what it is specific
to AWS Cloud platform so what's a part
of this tutorial and demo what's in
store for you at our offset I would like
to cover the basics of orchestration
tools as most of you would know
kubernetes is one of the most popular
orchestration tools in recent times
specifically for applications which are
Cloud native and deployed on some or the
other types of containers but what are
these orchestration tools why would one
need to use orchestration tools what are
the facilities of features provided by
these orchestration tools that's the
first thing that I'm going to cover
after that I will pick two orchestration
tools specific to container management
Docker swarm versus kubuntis I am going
to compare them with regard to the
features that they provide the use cases
that they cover what facilities that
they provide and when to use what after
that I will get into a little bit detail
of the kubernetes architecture what
exactly is required for setting up a
kubernetes cluster what runs in a
control plane or a master node what runs
as a part of the worker node after that
I will end the tutorial by running you
through a demo by setting up a three
node kubernetes cluster on AWS platform
I will use something called as cops
which is one of the admin tools for
setting up production grade kubernetes
cluster so I will use this to set up a
three node cluster on AWS all right now
that we set the context right let me get
started so what are orchestration tools
the application development and the life
cycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fault tolerance self-healing
capabilities Auto scaling all this as
complicated over the last few years as a
part of devops one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all these
application dependency or lifecycle
management using some or the other kind
of a tool so that's where these
orchestration tools have become very
very popular so what kind of features
that they provide is you'll have to just
let them know what are the kinds of tool
sets that is required what are the fault
tolerance mechanisms that it has to be
adopted to what kind of a self-healing
capabilities that application will have
to need and if at all there is any auto
scaling features that is required if at
all you can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a One-Stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where these orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management Docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with Apache
me Source there are many other container
management systems but I'm going to
topic Docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two Frameworks for the sake of
comparison I picked up Docker swarm and
kubuntase just because of the reason
that both of them operate in the space
of container management they do
something very very similar to
Containers that's the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools however there's a big difference
that exists when it comes to the types
of containers that both of them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be used for Docker swarm is a
cluster management solution that is
provided by Docker container Docker is
one of the very very popular containers
of recent times and in case you have
your applications that is totally
powered by only Docker containers if you
have a need where you want to run a
cluster of servers which are running
only Docker containers Docker swarm
should be your choice for your
orchestration tool kubernet is on the
other hand can cater to any other types
of containers other than Docker and
including Docker as well so in case you
have your applications which have got
Docker in them which I've got rkt in
them which they've got Alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a Docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 Max nodes so in case your
application is totally written in Docker
containers and the load or the expected
cluster size is about 50 60 nodes docus
swarm should be the choice of
orchestration tool on the other hand
kubernetes is something that was open
sourced by Google and the kind of the
scale of operations that kubernetes can
cater to is Google scale so if in case
your applications are more than a
thousand nodes that is where kubernetes
comes into play that's the big
difference that exists between Docker
swarm and kubernetes putting those
differences aside let me compare docus
warm and kubernetes based upon other
features which are similar in nature the
first and important feature that
kubernetes provides is something called
as Auto scaling if at all the load on
your cluster is too high and an
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new VMS or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the Fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the
powerfulness of Auto scaling which is
provided by kubernetes and this
unfortunately does not exist in Docker
swarm the other feature of load
balancing specifically application node
balancing so Docker swarm gives you an
application Level Auto load balancing
however kubernetes gives you the
flexibility of manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for application load balancing
installation as I mentioned earlier
Docker swarm is a loose cluster of
containers which are running on nodes it
is very easy to spin up a new node and
then connect them to a swarm and this
can be done in a very very loose coupled
way where you can create swarms of your
choice notes are allowed to connect to
swarms and quit or leave the Swarms on
the fly so in and all the installation
is pretty easy and fast kubernetes on
the other hand the configuration of
kubernetes is the way to spin up a big
cluster specifying the size of the node
how many Master known so many config
planes that you want how many nodes that
you want it's a pretty tough thing to
bring up a kubernetes scalability
kubernetes strength is very very strong
they are very tightly coupled and even
they have the capability where on the
cluster size things or the nodes can be
increased on the Fly based upon the
requirement on a Docker swarm the
cluster strength is weak as compared to
kubernetes worker nodes can be added to
a swarm worker notes can be asked to
leave us form or can be taken out of a
swarm based upon the requirement so this
is kind of a Loosely coupled
architecture for Docker swarm while
kubernetes the cluster is very tightly
coupled since Docker swarm runs only
Docker containers containers find it
very easy to share data and a lot of
other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they
are all from the same family so it's
very easy for them to share not just
volumes but a lot of other things
however for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if
application as to share some data across
different containers there's a little
bit of a complexity in how you would
want your containers to share data also
when it comes to kubernetes kubernetes
groups containers in something called as
pods while a pod can have either one
container that's the preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each pod can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three parts to be
running on the same node that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to Dockers form uh GUI so
there's not a good enough UI tool in
Dockers form at least the CE edition of
it which will allow you to get to know
what is running on your containers what
is the size of the containers what is
the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like portaner which gives
you a good visibility into your running
Docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker abilities gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also Club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way this is little
bit of a good UI for kubernetes file for
docus form there isn't anything that is
provided out of the box let me spend
some time in explaining a little bit
about the kubernetes architecture what
comprises of the kubernetes cluster what
resides in a master or a control plane
and what resides in a worker node this
is a very high level depiction of a
kubernetes cluster so this is the master
node which has got something called as a
cluster store a controller a scheduler
component and an EPA server and these
are the bunch of nodes that are
connected or administered by the master
node the master node can be 1 3 Phi
typically an odd number this is as per a
typical cluster management thing where
you would need the master nodes to be in
odd numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to whom and stuff like that all the
Masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cubic
CTL or the command from using which
anybody can assign some workloads to the
cluster can also be run either on the
same node or on a separate node so Cube
CTL is the command line tool that we
would be installing and using in order
to fire up our commands to our cluster
so if at all I have to put up a job on
our cluster if I have to give out any
specific commands to my cluster all this
is done using cubic CTL there's a bunch
of rest apis which is used by Q CTL and
Cube CTL will talk to the API server and
fire up the commands specific to my
cluster what runs in the master node
Master node without saying it's the most
important component of any of the
cluster if at all you're running
um cluster with only one must node if
your master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can talk to the different nodes in
the cluster so Master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster there's
always one node that should be running
as a master node that's a bare minimum
requirement for your cluster so what are
the other components in the master node
the most important one is called etcd so
this is nothing but a data store a value
of key value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store be 4
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
Daemon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of workload that is
running based upon the configuration
that the user has set in so if at all if
you are aware of something called as a
replication controllers endpoint
controllers namespace controllers all
these controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
Pod goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the Pod
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right APA server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the API server so this
is an entry point for all your requests
that come into your cluster anybody
wants to deploy something anybody want
to scale up a controller anybody who
wants to bring down few Services anybody
wants to put in a service all this will
have to come in as a part of a rest API
endpoint and API server is the entry
point in case you don't want want you
know somebody to access your cluster in
case you want only specific people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role-based access control for this API
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the master node what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as I mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a pod as a
service as a container so in kubernetes
world there's something called as a pod
a pod is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a wrapper around your
running containers so slave nodes are
the worker nodes typically run these
parts so that is where the whole
workload typically gets run but there
are a bunch of other components in the
in the node which also manages what runs
in the Pod who has to have access to the
Pod what is the state of the Pod is it
in a running state is it going down for
some reason and all the stuff so let's
quickly go over those components that is
there in the slave node the most
important component in my opinion that
should be on the on the Node should be
the container runtime as I mentioned
earlier kubernetes can run any different
types of containers not just Docker so
in case you want to have a node which
wants to have Docker running on it rkt
running or at LKC running on it or any
other container environment that is
running on it you have to ensure that
the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the Pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cube alert as the name says cubelet or
cube alert is a small subset which talks
to the cube API server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qvps server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um of affinity
towards any node on which these parts
are running because pods or containers
are something called as ephemeral they
can run anywhere so how would somebody
reach out to these applications that is
running in some pod which is running in
one container now and running in
probably another container another node
all together tomorrow so that is where
your kubernetes proxy comes into picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these spots and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a DNS server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the pod on which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by acting as a load
balancer and a network proxy now that at
a very high level we know what are all
the components that make up of our
kubernetes cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster we'll spin up
this cluster on AWS platform finally we
get to the demo section of my my
tutorial now that you guys are aware as
to what is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node probably
you're thinking that it's going to be
pretty hard to kind of set this up so
let me demystify that by running you
with a quick demo of how to set up a
simple three node kubernetes cluster
using a tool called cops and I will be
doing this whole setup on my AWS Cloud
okay so what is cops cops is nothing but
a simple tool it's an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as I said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why I would use something called as a
cops and I will use this on my cluster
which I'll spin up on my AWS instance so
I have an AWS account and what I'll do
first I will first pin up an ec2 server
I will power this with one of the Linux
Amis and I will install cops on it now
this will be my starting point from
where I'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case I'll try to keep
it little small I don't want too many
nodes in my cluster I'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know AWS is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what I
would do is I will create an IAM role
which will attach to my S2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that I'm going to specify
all right so once I have my cluster set
up I will also install Cuba CTL which uh
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which I can kind of connect to my
cluster give out some jobs put some
parts and stuff like that so I will use
qbctl I will also have a pair of SSH
keys so that from this machine I would
be able to successfully get onto the
master node and submit jobs on my behalf
so let me Begin by first logging into my
AWS account all the steps that I will be
following to bring up my AWS cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and I'll be sharing you this document in
a GitHub repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that I would need is to
launch an AWS ec2 instance now this is
an instance where I am going to install
cops and I will use it as a base server
from where I'm going to fight some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
AWS account and let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
um it doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire I would recommend choose free tire
only and choose an Ami of your choice
let me choose this instance I will make
it T2 micro that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
I don't want to change anything here
that looks good maybe I will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance I will name this as
my cops server all right I would need a
bunch of ports to be opened up so what I
will do is I'll create a new security
group called open to the word I would
not recommend that you do this since I
don't want to it will take a long time
for me to specify quickly pick and
choose the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster I don't want to do
that I will open up all the HTTP and
https ports so that it's quicker so I
will say all TCP I would save from
anywhere just to be on the safer side
also open HTTP and https and I will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me I will say review on launch
alright so I chose a T2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness I opened
up all the ports and the instant details
are you've seen what is that I've chosen
all right now important part is like I
would need a keypad I need to create a
new keypad I will call this as simply
learn keys I will download this key pair
and then I will launch the instance it
will take some time for my ec2 instance
to come up in the meanwhile what I'll do
is I will convert I have this Pim file
which is the pair of keys the SSH keys
with which I need to log into my ec2
instance so I'll need to convert this
because I'm trying to connect from my
Windows box I would need to convert this
into a PPK file so I have putition I'm
going to load my set of keys here and
convert that key into a ppk3 all right
open all right I would say save and save
privately yes I would say simply learn
or simply learn private private key I'll
save this here done that that's all so
this is my public key which is the pem
file and this is my APK or my private
key Now using the private key I will log
into my ec2 instance okay now my ec2
instance is up and running it is running
in this Ohio region and this is the IP
address of my public IP address of my
machine so let me connect to it so I use
mobile exterm which is nothing but an
SSH emulator you can use putty or any of
these sessions which I allow you to do
on SSH this is my IP address of my
machine and since I've spun up an Amazon
Ami the user this is the default user I
would need to specify the private keys
for my session and this is the private
key for my session say okay I am in my
Amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that I need to
do all right so as I said I just brought
up my ec2 instance but I would need my
ec2 instance to run few things on my
behalf so that it can spin up easy to
other ec2 instances it can also talk to
an S3 bucket where I'm going to store
the instance date of my kubernetes
cluster also some sort of an auto
scaling group because I want to spin up
more and more instances I also want to
have a private hosted Zone using my
Route 53 so I would need my ec2 instance
to have all these sort of permissions
for my server so what I would do is I
will go and create a permission a role
in the ec2 or rather in the AWS IM role
and I will attach this I am role to my
ec2 instance all right so let me go to
my IM which is nothing but the identity
and access management I will create a
role called as possibly cops rule I will
create a role this role will be used by
my ec2 so I'm going to click on ec2 I'll
say next permissions they would need a
lot of permissions uh specific
permissions to be very honest and the
permissions are all listed out here S3
ec2 and all this stuff just to keep it
pretty simple what I would do is I'll
create a role with the administrative
axis all right so I don't want any tags
I will review I'll create a role name I
will say cops fold for ec2 all right so
I'm going to create a rule which has got
administrative access role so I'm going
to create a role so this would ensure
that my ec2 instance from which I'm
going to run a my cluster would have all
the prerequisite permission so that it
can go and spin up instances talk to S3
buckets and all that stuff all right now
let us have our running instance get
powered by this roles I will connect
this role to my running instance alright
so this is my ec2 instant that is
running I will say action attach attach
attach attach replace IM roles so there
is no rule as of now I would want my
cops role for ecos role that I created
so I want this new rule to be assigned
to my ec2 all right great now my ec2
instance which is my cop server has got
all the required permissions so that he
can create a cluster on my behalf great
now before this let me do a sudo yum
update iPhone y so that any of the
because this is a newly provisioned VM I
just want to ensure that all my library
system libraries are all updated so that
when I do install cop and Cube CTL and
all those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so I'm just running a sudo update
iPhone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install all cops
cops is a pretty simple installation it
is available in a particular location I
have to just copy this and ensure that I
do a curl and I install this particular
stuff all right so it is fetching uh the
cops tool it's installing for me once it
is copied down let me change the mode so
that I can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local bin so that
it is available for me in my path okay
that's pretty much the cops installation
let me also do one other thing let me
install something called as qbctl so
this is what would be you know a tool
using which I'm going to be firing my
commands to my kubernetes cluster once
it comes up right this is a pretty
smaller executable so keep sitting here
all right so I have Cube CTL as well as
cops installed on my ec2 server now okay
now what I'll do next is I'm going to
create an S3 bucket in AWS so that the
equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name S3
bucket with this name so let me go to S3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name I will just say create a
bucket okay so this is simply run dot
kubernetes is the bucket that I created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
go and create a DNS entry or a DNS zone
or AWS Route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know I can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that I'm coming up so
I will create a private hosted Zone and
possibility possibly I will call this as
simply learn.in so this will be my name
of my private hosted Zone in case you
already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
Route 53 hosted Zone specific for your
domain name since I don't have any one
I'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to Route 53 click on any of these and
you can get these hosted zones out here
so I'm going to create a hosted Zone
here I'm going to create a hosted Zone
click on create hosted Zone
um this would be simply learn.in I want
to create a public no I don't want
public I want a private hosted Zone and
I'm going to associate my VPC ID for
this hosted Zone since I'm going to try
out all my exercises in the Ohio region
I will associate the VPC of the Ohio
region for this all right so this is the
one that is specific to the Ohio region
so I will say this one I'll say create a
hosted so great now let me come back to
my ec2 box my ec2 is all powered with
whatever it needs in order to go out
with the installation of my cluster only
few things that I need to take care of
is that you know now that I put a name
for my cluster I also have an S3 bucket
that I've configured for my cluster I
will have to ensure that I need to put
in these two configurations as a part of
my cluster building activity so I will
open my bash RC file and I'm going to
export these two variables if at all you
remember well these two variables are
nothing but the cluster name which is
nothing but the public or sorry the
private hosted Zone that I created and
the S3 bucket where I'm going to create
or rather I'm going to store my cluster
state so let me copy these two and open
up my bash RC file all right so I will
just add these two and copy these and
Export them out as my variable I'm going
to save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right I've got
these two that have configured and I
also ensure that this environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of SSH keys this is to ensure that
I can log into the box that I'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
SSH iPhone key gen I don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so I
created a bunch of my key pair now I'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops cops
will ensure that this will take some
time for the cluster to come up but this
is exactly how I would Define my cups
command I already got a copy here so
cops create cluster the state of the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what I have
exported out the number of node count is
2 node count is the worker node count if
at all I don't specif there's a
configuration for specifying the master
or the control pane as well if I don't
specify that the default one is one so
I'm going to create one primary or the
master node and to worker nodes uh size
of my master not size of the worker
nodes or what are the zones where I want
this to be created and where do I store
the cluster information and okay I've
already added this must account this is
actually not required but this is the
command that I'm going to fire off so
that I bring up my cluster all right
that went off very fast but this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and
that's why this mode very fast now that
everything looks good with whatever
configuration that is specified now let
me go ahead and create the cluster by
seeing cops update cluster hyphen iPhone
yes now this will take some time a good
five to ten minutes for it too because
this will actually start provisioning
the servers and as I mentioned earlier
based upon my configuration I'm going to
come up with one master server and two
notes or these worker nodes all right so
this is the command for me to validate
the cluster and I'm going to try it out
first I'm pretty sure that will fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and see how many
servers do I have running as of now if
you see I had only one server that had
started which was my cop server and
automatically the other three instances
one is called notes dot simply not in
and this these two are the nodes and
this is the master node so these 3 got
automatically provisioned by the cops
command that I ran all right so this may
take a while for it to get validated on
good 5-10 minutes so what I'll do is
I'll pause the video now and I'll come
back once on the server the cluster is
up and running it's been a good uh eight
to nine minutes since I started my
cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so this is a master node uh
minimum One Max one some notes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro uh subnet so my clusters seem
to be up and running and my cluster name
is simple learn.in so what I would want
to do is now let me just log into the
master and see if I can run some pods so
let me get back to my installation steps
here the variation is done so let me log
into my since my cluster name is simply
learn.n this is the way to log into my
box so let me get into my box so if you
see here this is the host name the
machine that I'm currently in if you see
this this is nothing but our this cop
server this is about now from here I'm
trying to get into the master box all
right so if you see the IP address has
changed I was in a different box I'm in
a different box now if I see host name
you'll find a different host name so
this is 153 which is nothing but the
master node yep that's 153 this is the
particular house so I'm getting into
this machine now so I started the
cluster from my cop server here it ran
and brought up three nodes so I'm
actually getting into my master node and
see if I can run some parts on it
alright so let me try Cube CTL get
cluster info right Cube CTL get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
Master node and one master node and two
worker nodes so let me see if I have
some pods here keep the CTL get pods so
there's no pod as of now so what I'll
try to do is let me just spin up a very
very simple Pawn just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct I have a a simple node.js
application that I have built and I've
got a container for that this is already
pushed to the docker up registered is
called simply run Docker Hub and the
image name that I have here is called my
node app and I will use this image to
power one of my parts that I will run so
this is the way in which I am going to
launch my pod let me show you these
commands Cube CTL run the name for my
deployment that I'm going to run hyphen
iPhone image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my container so
this is simply learn Docker Hub forward
slash my node app hyphen F1 replica is
equal to I want two replicas to be
running and the port that I want to
expose this particular part is on eight
zero eight zero so let me run this as
soon as this is run it creates something
called as a deployment all right now let
me just say I'm not really interested in
the deployment I'm interested in
checking if at all the parts are up and
running so I will say Cube CTL get what
all right so that was pretty fast so I
have two parts that are running here
these are two replicas because as I
asked for two replicas these parts are
running so I can run Cube CTL describe
pod pickup all right I can pick up any
of the Pod name and see what is the Pod
what is the information does it contain
from what is the image that is pulling
what is the image image Name ID this is
actually running my thought which is
actually spinning up a container great
so first of good so in kubernetes the
pods can are ephemeral so they can be
there at any time cannot be runtime if I
need to expose my pod outside I will
have to create a service for my pod so
what I'll do is I'll create a very very
simple service by exposing this
particular deployment before that you
check Cube CDL get deployment so there's
a deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so I
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as
um yeah I'll just expose this let me see
all right I'm not specifying what type
and all I don't want to get into the
complications of um what are the
different types of exposing this service
and all that stuff so if I don't specify
find anything it gives me something
project cluster ID so this is where my
pod is actually exposed so let me just
check if at all this part is up and
running I'll just try a simple curl
command uh curl HTTP colon this is my
cluster IP and the port is 8080 if at
all I hit this it's actually hitting my
application and giving me uh whatever I
put a simple uh sys dot out kind of a
thing where I'm just printing
um the container ID of whatever pod is
serving uh mix out of so I'm actually
eating my container and I'm getting this
output from the content so everything
looks good my content is up and running
so let me just go and clean it up I will
say Cube CTL delete deployment simply
learn app this should get rid of all the
parts that I created Cube CTL get pod
all right these parts are interminating
things let me just check Cube CTL get
Services there's one service I don't
want this service let me delete that
keep CTO delete service on this all
right this sounds good let me come back
to my host my cop server from where I'm
running so I managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what I'll do is I'll just
go ahead and complete this demo by going
and getting rid of my cluster so cops
delete cluster hyphen iPhone yes all
right so this will ensure that it will
clean up my complete cluster that I
created so I had three or four running
instances if you see them all the three
are shutting down because you know the
cop server which had cops installed on
it uh has now got a mandate to go ahead
and shut down and clean up the whole
instances and all those things that are
created as a part of my deployment hey
everyone I welcome you all to this
puppet Phil course by simply learn in
this complete course we will learn
everything that we need to know to excel
in puppet we have math F and Anjali to
guide us through this journey we shall
begin with having a basic understanding
of puppet and what is its relevance
today after that we shall dive deeper
and understand the components of puppet
followed by its architecture
after checking its architecture we shall
look at the process to install puppet
and configure it in our local system
moving forward we shall see companies
that have adopted puppet and all about
writing manifest and puppet after that
we will check regarding the puppet
community and puppet DSL postswitch we
shall see the Hands-On demo that will
explain the working of puppet from
scratch after we have ample knowledge
regarding the tool we shall understand
the difference between Chef puppet
ansible and salt stack finally we shall
take a look at some of the interview
questions that might increase your
chances of cracking any puppet interview
so before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our YouTube channel
and don't forget to click that Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn now without further Ado let's
begin with our introduction hello this
is Matthew from Simply learn we're going
to focus specifically on puppet so in
this session what we can do is we're
going to cover what and why you would
use puppets what are the different
elements and components of puppet and
how does it actually work and then we'll
look into the companies that are
adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when the server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where public shows its strap with
puppets all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
Ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out now to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working States or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out Solutions so let's dig deeper into
what puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like Chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of Puppets so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
their clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
will be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual documents so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public clients as a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact that the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so now that we
know what properties is let's look into
the puppet architecture so puppet has a
Master Slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and Below we have the puppet
clients so the Puppet Master is a system
where your system administrator sits the
clients are those systems which require
configuration you can have n number of
clients connected to the puppet master
so don't worry we look into each of
these components in detail firstly we
have the puppet master so the Puppet
Master is where the system administrator
sits and he or she types in the codes
here so the codes are not only written
in the system but they are also stored
here and whenever the client requires
these codes for their configuration they
simply request it so manifest is the
first sub-competent of the Puppet Master
these are the actual files where the
codes are written so in case of puppet
these are Ruby files modules tie
manifest templates and files into a
single unit now these codes dictate the
instructions for performing various
tasks on your client in next component
is templates so if manifests are your
code templates are the data so let me
explain this to you with an example
consider you want to create a file
called index.html on one of your client
machines so what you do is you write the
code for creating this file in your
manifest and the content of this file is
written in your templates then you
simply link them but here's the thing
when you divide your code and data in
this way it's a very clean structure so
it's preferred to do it in this manner
files are your static contents so the
files are basically sent to your client
and they are simply downloaded at the
client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the passer at the master itself
modules ties the Manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
Puppet Master CA which stands for
certificate Authority now as we will see
later in this video The Puppet Master
and the puppet client communicate
through an exchange of SSL certificates
so when the client sends over the
certificate to the master CA provides
the master the authority to sign these
certificates the minute the master signs
a certificate the master is basically
saying that yes this client is
registered with me and I agree to
exchange data with this client a next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have Factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our clients
and sending this data over to the Puppet
Master at the master this data is
compared against the Manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
Master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the SSL
certificates SSL stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted Channel between two components
what this encrypted Channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete Security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with Master Slave
architect texture so the client so far
is not a client it is just a system and
we will refer to the system as system a
so system a sends over a client
certificate to the master associated
with this client certificate is the host
name of system a now Master goes through
the certificate it's easy host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
the signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
I am willing to exchange information
with this system and I do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master Sciences certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the Manifest or even could be your files
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
this software now all this information
is collected it's called the fact and
it's sent over to the master at the
master this information that is the
facts is compared against the Manifest
so why does the master do this the
master basically compares the facts
against the Manifest to know if what the
Manifest is about to perform is already
performed on these systems so if the
Manifest has some additional
functionality they are compiled into
catalogs and then these catalogs are
sent over to the client now remember
those agent Services which existed in
your clients here's where they come in
the agents take the catalog and execute
them on the client once executed these
catalogs make the required changes on
the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master so the master keeps record of all
the changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state so this entire procedure can be
repeated n number of times and can be
repeated at regular intervals so if you
have a scenario where a system needs to
be configured every 30 minutes what you
can do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so today I'll be showing you how you can
use puppet to install Apache on one of
your client machines so we'll be using
two machines here we'll have a server
and we'll have a node machine the server
is essentially your master the node is
your client I'm just using the term
server and node instead because I want
to keep it very close to as they are
used in the command now both these
machines are going to be sent to as
seven machines and I have Oracle VM
virtualbox installed on my machine so on
that I've simply created two virtual
boxes both Center S7 of course so before
we move on to the actual demo I'll just
take you through the various steps so
first we'll install the puppet server on
our server or Master machine we'll then
start this server service we then shift
over to our node or the client machine
and we'll install the puppet agent
service we will then start this service
too and the minute you start the puppet
agent service and SSL certificate is
created so this certificate will have
the host name of your you're not
attached to it and this is how the
master or the server will recognize this
certificate and then it'll sign this
certificate so once your master or the
server signs the certificate you can
write your manifest so the Manifest has
just the codes for configuration and
once that too is done you shift back to
your client or the node system and you
run the Asian service so once you run
the agent service your manifest or your
cat logs because as you know the
manifests are compiled into catalogs
these are executed on your node and this
will make the required changes so that's
how this entire process is going to work
now let's move on to the actual demo
this is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course it's the client
so let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the Master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our Master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you missed this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the
hostname the last word you see there
that's the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our
hostname is set so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the IP of this
machine so for that you just type if
config
enter
so this is your IP guys
under enp 0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the IP will
differ for you guys needless to say
foreign
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client to communicate so for
this we need to remove certain firewalls
so the command for this is sudo because
we want the root permission
system
CTL
top
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the Puppet
Labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net also you won't
be getting an IP if it's not for the
first time
so here's the command to download the
puppet lab
foreign
again
okay so the Puppet Labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
field
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
Master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so I just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change in
our system config puppet server file so
let's just move to the file first
this file will open in VI editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2GB
so we are going to reduce the size
512 MB should be enough
so guys notice here I did not type the B
okay so I just changed this to XMS
512 m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite Troublesome okay so
now we can start our puppet server
service
foreign
okay so that's done so basically a
puppet server service has started it's
running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our Etc
host file with sudo because you need to
make a few changes and save it open this
in the vi terminal
foreign
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the IP for your puppet server
machine
foreign
puppet
Dash master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading Puppet
Labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
thank you
so Puppet Labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed let me just
clear this window
now that our puppet agent Services
installed we'll start this service so
I'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here Android changed stop
to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the servers start running but
an SSL certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a perfect
line machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's localhost.local domain so a
certificate should have this attached to
it so guys the first time your client
sends a certificate the name of the
certificate itself is usually the host
name of the machine so a certificate's
name should be localhost.local domain
we'll check this on our Master System
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client and we just started the
client we should have technically just
one certificate and it will be so
thank you
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain we'll now sign the
certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
yeah as you can see here the certificate
is signed
signed Certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
This is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as of now
so we are just checking here we are just
creating this file and then we'll go to
our client machine and just check the if
we can access this file from there
so now we'll move to our client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on a client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our Master server put some
content into this file and see how the
execution takes place
so we'll open our filesample.pp which we
created earlier in the vi editor
let's type a code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the host name of our client
machine
thank you
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the Apache service package on Centos
is called the httpd
so this line that I just typed in is the
action it'll ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so the suckline machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so I just cleared the screen now we'll
start the Apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and add localhost you must have the
testing page for your Apache
so we type localhost
until
and yeah this is the testing page for
Apache so as you can see we have
successfully used puppet to install the
Apache service on our puppet client
and this is the end of our demo so let's
have a look at companies that are using
puppets today there are a number of
companies that have adopted puppet as a
way to manage their infrastructure so
companies that are using puppy today
include Spotify Google ATT so why are
these companies choosing to use puppet
as their main configuration management
tool and the answer can be seen if we
look at a specific company Staples so
Staples chose to take and use puppet for
their configuration management tool and
use it within their own private Cloud
the results were dramatic the amount of
time that the it organization was able
to save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow
them to experiment with other and new
projects and assignments a real tangible
benefit to a company so let's look at
how you write a manifest in puppets so
so manifests are designed for writing
out in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of Ruby without dot PP
extension if we step through the five
key steps for writing a manifest they
are one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator to
compile your manifest and it's compiled
into a catalog three deploy the catalog
is then deployed onto the clients for
execute the catalogs are run on the
client by the agent and then five and
clients are configured to a specific and
desired state if we actually look into
how manifest is written it's written
with a very common syntax if you've done
any work with Ruby or really
configuration of systems in the past
this may look very familiar to you so we
break out the the work that we have here
you start off with a package file or
service as your resource type and then
you give it a name and then you look at
the features that need to be set such as
IP address then you're actually looking
to have a command written such as
present or start the Manifest can
contain multiple resource types if we
continue to write our manifest and
puppets the default keyword applies a
manifest to all clients so an example
would be to create a file path that
creates a folder called sample in a main
folder called Etc the specified content
is written into a file that is then
posted into that folder and then we're
going to say we want to be able to
trigger an Apache service and then
ensure that that Apache service is
installed on a nerve so we write the
Manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an Apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you will have exactly the same
result results on those machines now
let's have a look at the puppet
community
the puppet Community is a rich community
of a lot of people officially there is
no count but counting the various
channels where people collaborate there
are a little over 2 900 committers to
GitHub projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with Puppet Labs
there are 4 893 modules on the official
puppet Forge these include modules from
the Puppet Labs and also from open
source contributors to GitHub
so that's nearly 5 000 modules of
ready-made code available on the puppet
Forge so before you write any code for
puppet you can check to see if it's
already been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has 6
588 participants apart from this on
slack overflow you have a big tag of
Puppet Labs in puppet which gives you a
list of only puppet questions that's a
good playground for you to interact with
people who are already using puppet and
who are contributing and helping others
now let's have a look at puppet Forge
so puppet Forge is a GitHub client for a
repository which is hosted by Puppet
Labs that is almost 5 000 modules of
puppet code so these are both Puppet
Labs and Community contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize so when you
have a requirement for anything you're
doing with your infrastructure you can
just grab one of those 5000 modules and
then you can customize it according to
your needs one of the other benefits is
they have built-in tests so they follow
all of the best practices now if you
write your own module you also have to
write your own tests and you have to
spend extra time writing best practice
code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go so that's the
benefit you get from such a large
community where people contribute to the
modules and the code and share with the
community the puppet DSL puppet DSL is a
puppet domain specific language it's the
puppet's primary programming language
it's just like plain English and you
don't really need to be a programmer to
write code in it it's kind of a
sub-child of Ruby because it approaches
and uses is equal to and greater than
marks to Define things so it's very easy
to learn you can specify packages that
you want to install you can specify
services to be managed you could do
things based on the operating system
that you have so we'll be writing a
small puppet module which will be using
this puppet DSL
we will do that after we install the
puppet server and the client and then we
will write a simple puppet module to
show how to use the puppet DSL let's
have a look at the demo we are going to
do so you will be setting up the
machines using sudo DNS because we want
to have a resolvable DNS because only by
having a resolvable DNS can we use
puppet because puppet uses the SSL
certificates now we'll be installing the
puppet server and the client we'll be
signing the certificates of the client
on the server side and then we'll
proceed with writing an ntp module which
we'll be using for installation of ntp
on the client and then we'll look at the
puppet programming language or DSL now
we are going to look at a demo here so
we will be setting up the machines we
will set up a pseudo DNS locally because
puppet requires a fully qualified domain
name in order to run since there is a
certificate communication taking place
here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client we'll be signing the
certificate and finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
[Music]
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client I have two machines
here one is the puppet master and the
second is the puppet client the puppet
master has got almost four gig of RAM
and four vcpus which I can show you here
because it's a Ruby on Rails application
it requires a lot of CPU and RAM
for the client I don't need that much
RAM and CPU so I've allotted one
gigabyte of RAM and one vcpu I will
start both of these machines and find
out the IP addresses right click normal
start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing I'll do is log in using root
and red hat password and then I will
change the host name so I'll say Vim
Etc host name
this will open a hostname file in a text
editor which is vim
then we'll do a DD which will delete
that existing hostname
and then I press I for insert mode and
finally I'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine I'll save this file by doing
Escape semicolon WQ exclamation mark
and I'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the Puppet Master
I'll say root red hat
I'll open the hostname file
say DD then I'll say puppet hyphen
master
I'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect the hostname change does not take
effect unless you reboot the machine
now both of these machines are ready I'm
going to find out the IPS and use the
Mac terminal to log into these
so this is uh 23 and 21. so 23 is my
server and 21 is my client
I'll SSH to 23 first
now in order for the Puppet Master to be
installed I need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake DNS which
means a fully resolvable DNS name so if
I do hostname here you see my host name
is Puppet Master in order to set up a
fake DNS I need to go to the ETC host
file
go to the end then I say IP address
hostname local
then space hostname now this is one of
the techniques which makes the Linux
server believe that there's a fully
qualified domain name on this machine
I'll save this
then I do a hostname hyphen f
you see it it has a fully qualified
domain name now
so now we will be downloading the Puppet
Labs repository for Ubuntu 16.04 which
is zenial
so I'll say curl hyphen 0 https
apps.puppet labs
.com
Puppet Labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensannial.deb
you can see there's a Debian file which
has been downloaded here I will import
this using the dpkg command so I'll say
dpkg hyphen I Puppet Labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphen xenial.dap
and then I'll say apt-get update which
will update my apt package indexes on
this machine
and now I'll install the puppet server
so I'll say apt-get install puppet
hyphen
puppet server hyphen y
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server so I'll
say Etc default puppet server so by
default it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm I'll
make this three and I'll change this to
three as well and I'll save this file
I'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows Port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port
the rules have been updated to allow
that I'll now start the puppet server so
I'll say a system CTL
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running
I'll also enable it at boot time so I'll
say systemctl enable puppet to server
it will enable at boot time
now I also need to configure a fully
qualified domain name here so okay so
I'll do that by going into the hosts
file
I'll go to the end and I'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen server.local and then puppet
hyphen server
if I do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master
so the trick is to have the
hostname.local in front of the IP
address in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go to the client setup
the client setup is almost the same with
just a small difference
the package which we need to install on
the client is puppet agent so we will go
to the client
so you see this has got a host name
now we also need to set up the fake DNS
here so I'll copy this hostname
open the host line
go to the end write the IP address
and then dot local and then hostname
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name so when I do a host name it
says puppet hyven client when I do a
hostname hyphen f it says puppet client
local to install the puppet agent on
this machine I will need to download the
zenio packages so I'll say that we'll
get https
apt.puppetlabs.com
Puppet Labs
hyphen release hyphen pc1 hyphen
zenial.deb
I'll download this and then I'll say
dpkg hyphen I Puppet Labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphen xeniel.deb
so this is the repository package which
I'll be downloading here and then I'll
say apt-get
update hyphen y this will update my apt
caches on this machine
and now I'll finally install the puppet
agent
so I'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here I'll start
the puppet agent and I'll enable it at
boot time so I'll say system control
start puppet
then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server but each of them
should know each other so we'll have to
do a cross certificate host mapping so
we will be copying the host file entry
of the client and adding it to the
server so I'll go to the ETC hosts on
the server side go to the end paste it
there
okay and I'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now because one of
them has the host entry of the other
so if if I do from the master ping
puppet hyphenagent dot local
if I ping the agent from a server
hyphenclient.local
it is able to Ping it and if I ping the
master from the client
if I say ping puppet hyphen master.local
both of them will be able to Ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request so I'll go
to my to this directory which is opt
Puppet Labs puppet bin
and I'll say puppet agent hyphen T
hyphen knife and server
is equal to
and I'll give the fully qualified domain
name of the Puppet Master
then I'll say hyphen f
when I do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if I go to the server and I do an
opt
I'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there is a public client
certificate which is pending to be
signed which is denoted by the absence
of a plus sign here
I'll be signing the certificate so I'll
say puppet search sign and then the name
so puppet hyphen client
dot local this will sign the
certificates and when I go to the server
on the client side if I run the puppet
agent again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from Puppet Forge
puppet Forge is a big collection of Open
Source modules which are free to use as
a first step we will be using a
ready-made module and that would be a
demonstration for how to actually get up
and running with a module so search for
Apache module here
this is the Puppet Labs Apache module
I'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install this is the
command for that but I will make sure I
run this command from the puppet home so
I'll go to the master I'll go to Etc
Puppet Labs code environments production
in this I'll do modules now I will run
it from the binary which is present at
the opt to Puppet Labs bin puppet
and then module install
Puppet Labs hyphen Apache and then this
version so we are specifying the latest
version and I'll hit enter
when I press enter it starts downloading
from the forge API
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat STD lib and Apache
so now I'll go to a folder here which is
one level up called manifest so this is
the file here Etc Puppet Labs code
environments production manifest so in
this there's a file which I'll be
creating called site.pp the site.pp will
specify and this is the main controller
of how the infrastructure looks in the
site PP
I specify
that I want puppet hyphenclient dot
local node to have the Apache module
included I'll save this file and the
only thing I need to do now is since all
is set on the server side I need to go
to the client side and run puppet agent
it will automatically download the
Apache module and compile it and may
then make sure the server is in a state
so when I press enter we see a lot of
output it tries to configure Apache on
this machine
and done now when I go to the front end
of this machine on this port I should be
able to see apache's default page so
this is apache's default page
so the module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that Apache would be installed and run
at boot time so that is why it is
running here
and that is all we have from the uh
puppet module and this concludes the
demo today we're going to go through a
real tough battle we're going to decide
which is better for your operations
environment is it Chef puppet and
support or salt stack all four are gonna
go head to head so let's go through the
scenario of why you'd want to use these
tools so let's meet Tim he's our
assistant administrator and Tim is a
happy camper putting and working on all
of the systems in his network but what
happens if a system fails if there's a
fire a server goes down well Tim knows
exactly what to do he can fix that fire
really easily the problems become really
difficult for Tim however if multiple
servers start failing particularly when
you have large and expanding networks so
this is why Tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool and we
need to now decide what would be the
best tool for him because configuration
management tools can help make Tim look
like a superstar all he has to do is
configure the right codes that allows
him to push out the instructions on how
to set up each of the servers quickly
effectively and at scale all right let's
go through the tools and see which ones
we can use the tools that we're going to
go through are Chef puppet and support
and salt stacks and we have videos on
most of these software and services that
you can go and view to get an overview
or a deep dive in how those products
work so let's go and get to know our
contestants so our first contestant is
Chef and Chef is a tool that allows you
to configure very large environments it
allows you to scale very effectively
across the entire ecosystem and
infrastructure Chev is by default an
open source code and one of the things
that you find is a consistent metaphor
for the tools that we recommend on
simply learn is to use open source code
code the code itself is actually written
in language of Ruby and erline and it's
really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution the way that Chef works
is that you write recipes that are
compiled into cookbooks and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up a node and a node is a
selection of servers that you have
configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have Apache Linux
servers running or you may have a MySQL
server running or you may have a python
server running and Chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and we need to have
instructions sent out to them to correct
that impact you can also send
instructions from the server to the
nodes to make a significant update or a
minor update so there's great
communication going back and forth if we
look at the pros and cons the pros for
Chef is that there is a significant and
following for chef and that has resulted
in a very large collection of recipes
that allow you to be able to quickly
stand up environments there's no need
for you to have to learn complex recipes
the first thing you should do is go out
and find the recipes that are available
it integrates with Git really well and
provides for really good strong Version
Control some of the conso are really
around the learning speed it takes to go
from beginner user with Chef to being an
expert there is a considerable amount of
learning that has to take place and it's
compounded by having to learn Ruby as
the programming language and the main
server itself doesn't really have a
whole lot of control it's really
dependent on the communication
throughout the whole network alright
let's look at our second Contender
puppet and puppet is actually in many
ways very similar to Chef there are some
differences but again puppet is designed
to be able to support very large
heterogeneous organization it is also
built with Ruby and uses DSL for writing
manifests so there are some strong
similarities here to Chef as with a chef
there is a Master Slave infrastructure
with puppet and you have a master server
that has the manifests that you put
together in a single catalog and those
catalogs are then pushed out to the
clients over an SSL connection some of
the pros with public is that as with
Chef there is a really strong Community
around puppies and there's just a great
amount of information and support that
you can get right out of the gate it is
a very well developed reporting
mechanism that makes it easier for you
as an administrator to be able to
understand your infrastructure one of
the cons is that you have to really be
good at learning Ruby again as with shav
you know the more advanced tasks really
need to have those Ruby skills and as
with Chef the server also it doesn't
have much control so let's look at our
third Contender here ansible and so
ansible is slightly different it is the
way the ansible works is that it
actually just pushes out the
instructions to the server environment
there isn't a client server or Master
Slave environment where ansible would be
communicating backwards and forwards
with its infrastructure it is merely
going to push that instructions out the
good news is that the instructions are
written in yaml and yowel stands for
yaml eight markup language yaml is
actually pretty easy to learn if you
know XML and XML is pretty easy if you
know XML you're going to get yamo up
really well ansible does work very well
on environments where the focuses are
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a Playbook and an inventory or
you have a Playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
Playbook and the Playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
Playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote notes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with yaml
quickly the actual performance once you
actually have your infrastructure up and
running is less than other tools that we
have on our list now I do have to add a
Proviso this is a relative less it's
still very fast it's going to be a lot
faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and yaml itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as Ruby Ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
Contender here salt stack so salt stack
is a CLI based tool it means that you
will have to get your command line tools
out or your terminal window out so you
can actually manage the entire
environment via salt sack the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yaml or DSL which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient now
the way that sort stat works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with salt stag so
saltstack is very easy to use once it's
up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that sort
stack is fairly late in the game when it
comes to actually having a graphical
user interface for being able to create
and manage your environment other tools
such as ansible have actually had a UI
environment for quite some time all
right so we've gone through all four
tools let's see how they all stack up
next with each other so let the race
begin let's start with the first stage
architecture so the architecture for
most of our environments is a server
clients environment so for Chef puppet
and salt snack so very similar
architecture there the one exception is
ansible which is a client Only Solution
so you're pushing out the instructions
from a server and pushing them out into
your network and there isn't a client
environment there isn't a two-way
community education back to that main
client for what's actually happening in
your network so let's talk about the
next stage ease of setup so if we look
at the four tools there is one tool that
really stands out for ease of setup and
that is ansible it is going to be the
easiest tool for you to set up and if
you're new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with ansible just to try out
and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration before looking
at other tools now and so with that said
Chef puppet and salt stack aren't that
hard to set up either and you'll find
there's actually some great instructions
on how to do that setup in the online
community let's talk about the languages
that you can use in your configuration
so we have two different types of
language with both chef and ansible
being procedural in that they actually
specify at how you're actually supposed
to do the task in your instructions with
puppet and salt stack it's decorative
ways plus 5 I only want to do in the
instructions let's talk about
scalability which tools scale the most
effectively and as you can imagine all
of these tools are designed for
scalability that is the driver for these
kind of tools you want them to be able
to scale to massive organizations what
do the management tools look like for
our four contenders so again we have a
two-way split with ansible and salt
stack the management tools are really
easy to use you're going to love using
them they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and Chef the management tools are
much harder to learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
DSL or the Ruby DSL to be able to be a
true master in that environment but what
does interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about Cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
ansible and salt stack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular Cloud environments and
puppet and Chef are actually available
in both Amazon and Azure now we've
actually just haven't had a chance to
update our Chef link here but Chef is
now available on Azure as well as Amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four tools so the
communication is slightly different with
them Chef has its own knife tool and
whereas puppet uses SSL to secure
sockets layer and ansible and saltstack
use secure socket hashing and SSH as
their communication tool bottom line all
four tools are very secure in their
communication so who wins well here's
the reality all four tools are are very
good and it's really dependent on your
capabilities and the type of environment
that you're looking to manage that will
determine which of these four tools you
should use the tools themselves are open
source so go out and experiment with
them there's a lot of videos our team
has done a ton of videos on these tools
and so feel free to find out other tools
that we have then covered so you can
learn very quickly how to use them but
consider the requirements that you have
and consider the capabilities of your
team if you have Ruby developers or you
have someone on your team that knows
Ruby your ability to choose a broader
set of tools becomes much more
interesting if however you're new to
coding then you may want to consider
yaml based tools again the final answer
is going to be up to you and we'll be
really interested on what your decision
is please post in the comments below
which tool you have decided to go with
and what are the challenges that you're
coming up with because we'll help answer
those challenges for you and someone
provides you with one of the easiest
ways to automate your application and it
infrastructure on that note hi guys
welcome to this complete ansible
tutorial by simply learn in this video
we'll be covering some of the most
important Concepts relating to the
devops tool ansible we'll take you
through how you can install ansible and
how you can use the tool to automate
your processes first we have Anjali to
tell us how to install ansible on your
system a very warm welcome to all our
viewers I'm Anjali from Simply learn and
today I'll be showing you how you can
install the configuration management
tool ansible so let's have a brief about
why one would use ansible and what
exactly is ansible so if you consider
the case of an organization it has a
very large infrastructure which means it
has more than probably hundreds of
systems and giving one or even a small
team of people the responsibility to
configure all these systems makes their
work really tough repetitive and as you
know manual work is always prone to
errors so ansible is a tool which can
automate the configuration of all these
systems with ansible a small team of
system administrators can write simple
code in yaml and these codes are
deployed onto the hundreds and thousands
of servers which configures them to the
desired States so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager I'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's a server system or
the Master System so let's begin at data
service system
so this is my Master System guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
Chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
Creator ansible tool is installed now we
need to open our ansible host file and
there we'll specify the details of our
node or client machine
so this is ansible host file as you can
see here the entire file is commented
but there's a certain syntax that you'd
observe for example here we have a group
name web servers under which we have the
IP addresses or certain host name so
this is about how we'll be adding the
details for our client system first we
need to give a group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the IP address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the IP address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your IP address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for a client machine
so all Communications between the server
or the Master System and the client or
the node system takes place through SSH
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the roots password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our host file is written the
next thing we do is we write a Playbook
so Playbook is the technical term used
for all the configuration files that we
write in ansible now playbooks are
written in yaml yaml's extremely simple
to both write and understand it's in
fact very close to English
so now we'll write our Playbook The
Playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our Playbook
so name
and I'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is Root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
Playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation next we need to
specify our tasks so these are basically
the actions that the Playbook will be
performing so you would have noticed
everything so far is aligned that is
name host remote user become and task
because these are at one level now
whatever comes under task will be
shifted slightly towards the right
although yamil is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically a Apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task now
our second task could be running our
Apache service
so name run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied to a node
system at a particular file location
that will provide
a Content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our HTML files
and that's it we are done writing our
Playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the Playbook or push
the Playbook onto our node system let's
check the syntax of our Playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the Playbook to
unnode or the client machine
and that's the Syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed and next task was running httpd
now Although our system had the Apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that that everything is fine here we
can move on to our node system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our Playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running State and the web
page that we created should be hosted so
let's just type localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our web page is displayed here so we
come to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible thanks Anjali now we have
Matthew and Anjali to take us through
how to work with ansible ansible today
as one of the key tools that you would
have within your devops environment so
the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use a product like
ansible what ansible really is and how
it's of value to you in your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
I'm going to dig into the architecture
for ansible we're going to look at how
you would create a Playbook how you
would manage your inventory of your
server environments and then what is the
actual workings of ansible as a little
extra we're going to also throw an
ansible Tower one of the secret Source
solutions that you can use for improving
the Speed and Performance of how you
create your ansible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
Case by looking at HootSuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your devops environment for
helping manage the servers and this
definitely falls on the operations side
of the devops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of Sam and like
yourselves Sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
Apache it could be database servers
running my Sequel and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain I mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it will we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where ansible
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system Solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and setup of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what asphal
really is so you know this is all great
but you know how do we actually use
these tools in our environment so
ansible is a tool that really allows you
to create and control three key areas
that you'd have within your operations
environment first of all there's it
automation so you can actually write
instructions that automate the it setup
that you would typically do manually in
the past the second is the configuration
and having consistent configuration
imagine setting up hundreds of Apache
servers and being able to guarantee with
Precision that each of those Apache
servers is set up identically and then
finally you want to be able to automate
the deployment so that as you scale up
your server environment you can just
push out instructions they can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk talk a
little bit about pull configuration and
how it works with ansible so there are
two different ways of being able to set
up different environments for Server
Farms one is to have a key server that
has all the instructions on and then on
each of the servers that connect to that
main Master server you would have a
piece of software known as a client
installed on each of those servers that
would communicate to the main Master
server and then what periodically either
update or change the configuration of
the slave server this is known as a pull
configuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the push configuration
is slightly different the main
difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a master's slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with ansible
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an ansible environment
so when you're setting up an ansible
environment the first thing you want to
do is have a local machine and the local
machine is where you're going to have
all of your instruction and really the
power of the control that you'd be
pushing out to the remote server so the
local machine is where you're going to
be starting and doing all of your work
connected from the local machine are all
the different nodes pushing out the
different configurations that you would
set up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code within a
module so you do this on your local
machine for creating these modules and
each of these modules is actually
consistent playbooks the local machine
also has a second job and that job is to
manage the inventory of the nodes that
you have in your environment the local
machine is able to connect to each of
the different nodes that you would have
in your Hardware Network through SSH
clients so a secure client let's dig
into some of the different elements
within that architecture and we're going
to take a first look at playbooks that
you would write and create for the
ansible environments so the core of
ansible is the Playbook this is where
you create the instructions that you
write to define the architecture of your
Hardware so the Playbook is really just
a set of instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yamo and this is a
standard language used for configuration
server environments did you know that
yaml actually stands for yaml 8 markup
language that's just a little tidbit to
hide behind your ear so let's have a
look or one of these playbooks it looks
like and here we have a sample yaml
script that we've written so you start
off your yaml script with three dashes
and that integrates the start of a
script and then the script itself is
actually consistent of two distinct
plays at the top we have play one and
below that we have play two within each
of those plays we Define which nodes are
we targeting so here we have a web
server in the top play and in the second
play we have a database server that
we're targeting and then within each of
those server environments we have the
specific tasks that we're looking to
execute so let's step through some of
these tasks we have an install patchy
task we have a start Apache task and we
haven't installed my SQL task and when
we do that we can actually execute a
specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
Apache and then setting the state of the
Apache environment or starting the
Apache environment and setting up and
running the MySQL environment so this
really isn't too complicated and that's
the really good thing about working with
the animal is it's really designed to
make it easy for you as an operations
lead to be able to configure are the
environments that you want to
consistently create so let's take a step
back though we have two hosts we have
web server and database server why do
these names come from well this takes us
into our next stage and the second part
of working with ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible so
the inventory part of ansible is where
we maintain the structure of our Network
environment so what we do here is part
of the structure and creating different
nodes is we've had to create two
different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database server note
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointed to specific machines within that
environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the yamla
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you you to be able to
just point to new services without
having to write out complex instructions
so let's have a look at how ansible
actually works in real world so the real
world environment with is that you'd
have the ansible software installed on a
local machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
SSH connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
Playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment that is consistent
so this asks you a simple question what
are the major opportunities that ansible
has over chef and puppet really like to
hear your answers in the comments below
pop them in there and we'll get back to
you and really want to hear how you feel
that ansible is a stronger product or
maybe you think it's a weaker product as
it compares to other similar products in
the market here's the bonus we're going
to talk a little bit about ansible Tower
so ansible Tower is an extra product
that red hat created that really kind of
puts the cherry on the top of the ice
cream or is the icing on your cake
ansible by itself is a command line tool
however asphalt Tower is a framework
that was designed to access ansible and
through the ansible tower framework we
now have an easy to use GUI this really
makes it easy for non-developers to be
able to create the environment that they
want to be able to manage in their
devops plan without having to constantly
work with the command prompt window so
instead of opening up terminal window or
a command window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes alright so we've
talked a lot about ansible let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
going to look at HootSuite now HootSuite
if you not already use their products
and they have a great product HootSuite
is a social media management system they
are able to help with you managing your
pushes of social media content across
all of the popular social media
platforms that are able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really grateful and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
HootSuite the challenge they had at
HootSuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible came in and
really helped the folks over at
HootSuite today the devops team at
HootSuite write out playbooks that have
Specific Instructions that Define the
architecture and structure of their
Hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of seconds the bottom line is
ansible has been able to provide
HootSuite with it automation consistent
configuration and free up time from the
operations team so that instead of
managing servers they're able to provide
additional new value to the company I've
very warm welcome to all our viewers I
am Anjali from Simply learn and today
I'll be taking you through a tutorial on
ansible so ansible is currently the most
trending and popular configuration
management tool and it's used mostly
under the devops approach so what will
you be learning today you learn why you
should use ansible what exactly is
ansible the ansible architecture how
ansible works the various benefits of
ansible and finally we'll have a demo on
the installation of Apache or the httpd
package on a client systems we'll also
be hosting a very simple web page and
during this demo I'll also show you how
you can write a very simple playbook in
Yemen and your inventory file so let's
begin why should you use ansible let's
consider a scenario of an organization
where Sam is a system administrator Sam
is responsible for the company's
infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator Sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task Sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where Sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
Sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes Sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for Innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does Sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible Sam can write simple quotes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct States so
now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an I.T engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically beings bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this can of an
order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right next ansible automates
configuration management so
configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired state are the tools
that automate configuration management
include puppet and Chef and finally
ansible automates deployment deployment
simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals now that we
know what exactly ansible is let's look
at ansible's architecture ansible has
two main components you have the local
machine and you have your node or the
client machine so the local machine is
where the system administrator sits he
or she installs ansible here and on the
other end you have your node or the
client systems so in case of ansible
there's no supporting software installed
here these are just the systems that
required to be configured and they are
completely controlled by the local
machine at your local machine you also
have a module a module is a collection
of your configuration files and in case
of ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml Inked a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to English we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the Playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course the local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
SSH ssh is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
Communication in an unprotected
environment okay so we saw the various
components of ansible now how does
ansible exactly work you have your local
machine on one end this is where you
install ansible if you've gone through
any previous material on ansible you
would have come across the term
agentless often being associated with
this tool so this is what agentless
means you're installing ansible only on
your local machine and there's no
supporting software or Plugin being
installed on your clients this means
that you have no agent on the other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term agentless another
term that you would come across with
ansible is push configuration so since a
local machine has complete control here
it pushes the playbooks onto the nodes
and thus it's is called a push
configuration tool now the playbooks and
the inventory are written at the local
machine and the local machine connects
with the nodes through the SSH client
this step here is optional but it's
always recommended to do so it's where
the facts are collected so facts are
basically the current state of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine so when
the Playbook is executed the task
mentioned in the Playbook is compared
against the current status of the note
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your notes are
configured to the desired States so as I
mentioned before ansible is currently
the most trending tool in the market
under the configuration management
umbrella so let's have a look at the
various benefits of ansible which gives
it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple in important and provides
automated reporting how does it do all
this let's have a look at that agentless
as I already mentioned before you
require no supporting software or Plugin
installed on your node or the client
system so the master has complete
control and automatically this means
that ansible is more efficient because
now we have more space in our client and
node systems for other resources and we
can get ansible up and running real
quick ansible is also flexible so an
infrastructure is prone to change very
often and ansible takes no amount of
time to adjust to these changes ansible
cannot get any simpler with your
playbooks written in a language such as
yaml which is as close to English as you
can possibly get
it important basically means that if you
have a Playbook which needs to be run n
number of systems it would have the same
effect on all of these systems without
any side effect and finally we have
automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these tasks are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
Hands-On before we move on to the actual
Hands-On let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so I'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both Centos 7
Operating Systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
I'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the Playbook and then
simply deploy this Playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our Playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
Oracle virtual box here I have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminal is open
right now so the client machine terminal
has a black background with white text
and the Master machine terminal has a
white background with black text just so
you can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the Master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen Y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible's installed the next
step we go to our host file so host file
here is basically the inventory it's
where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so I'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the IP address
of our client machine so my client
machines IP address is
192.168.2.127 so before you come to this
it's advice that you check the IP
address on your client machine the
simple command for that is ifconfig now
once you type the IP address put a space
and here we need to mention the username
and the password for our client
so I'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is Root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
foreign
just clear the screen
next we move on to our Playbook we need
to write the Playbook
so the extension for our Playbook is yml
which stands for yaml
and as you can see here I have already
written my playbook but I'll just
explain to you how this is done so a
yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire Playbook
so I have named it sample book host is
basically where this would be executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory I
mentioned client's group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your clients so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called the
privilege escalation now A playbook
consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task I've named it to install httpd so
what we are doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the Apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome and the
destination of the file will be via
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our HTML files now as you can see
here there's quite a lot of indentation
and when it comes to yaml although it's
very simple to write and very easy to
read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first Dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
Playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file the
language is pretty simple very readable
indentations absolutely necessary make
sure all your spaces are correctly
placed we can now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of a yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
Playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is sample
dot yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our Playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the Playbook is
ansible Playbook
and the name of your playbook
so playbooks executed as you can see
here Gathering facts that's where all
the facts of the know that the present
state of the note is collected and sent
to the local machine so it's basically
to check that if the configuration
changes that we are about to make is
already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay State this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so I made it this way so
that you can at least see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that I was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so next step we need to just check on a
client machine if all the changes that
we desired are made so let's move to our
client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it is open your browser
and type in localhost
so there you go your Apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
hey there are you exploring test
automation are you wondering why
everyone is talking about selenium
around you do you want to know what
selenium is all about if yes this is the
video for you simply learn brings to you
a very simple tutorial on selenium what
should you expect from this video before
you start understanding any automation
tool it's good to look back into what
manual testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
Suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the Primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a Facebook
application and in Facebook application
let's let's open the Facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first first name the surname mobile
number or the new password and you will
also test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an accessibility testing you would do
a performance testing for this page or
say a response time after you say click
on the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
this test cases ready what do you do you
start executing this test cases one by
one you will find bugs your developers
are going to fix them and you will need
to rerun all these test cases one by one
again until all the bugs are fixed and
your application is ready to ship now if
one has to run test cases with hundreds
of transactions or the data sets and
repeat them can you imagine the amount
of effort required in that now that
brings us to the first demerit of the
manual testing manual testing is a very
time consuming process and it is very
boring also it is very highly
error-prone why because it is done
manually and human mistakes are bound to
happen since it's a manual executions
tester's presence is required all the
time one is to keep doing manual Steps
step by step again all the time he also
has to create manual reports group them
format them so that we get good looking
reports also send this reports manually
to all stakeholders then collection of
logs from various machines where you
have run your test consoliding all of
them creating repositories and
maintaining them and again since it's
all is a manual process there is a high
chance of creating manual errors there
scope of manual testing is limited for
example let's say regression testing
ideally you would want to run all the
test cases which you have written but
since it's a manual process you would
not have the luxury of time to execute
all of them and hence you will pick and
choose your test cases to execute that
way you are limiting the scope of
testing also working with large amount
of data manually is Impractical which
could be the need of your application
what about performance testing you want
to collect metrics on various
performance measures as a part of your
performance testing you want to simulate
multiple loads on application under test
and hence manually performing these kind
of test is not feasible and to top it
all up say if you are working in an
agile model where code is being churned
out by developers testers are building
their test and they are executing them
as and when the bills are available for
testing and this happens iteratively and
hence you will need to run this test
multiple times during your development
cycle and doing this manually definitely
becomes very tedious and burning and is
this the effective way of doing it not
at all so what do we do we automate it
so this tells us why we automate one for
faster execution two to be less error
prone and three the main reason is to
help frequent execution of our test so
there are many tools available the
market today for automation one such
tool is selenium birth of selenium much
before selenium there were various tools
in the market like say rft and qtp just
to name a few popular ones selenium was
introduced by gentlemen called Jason
Huggins way back in 2004. he was an
engineer at thoughtworks and he was
working on a web application which
needed frequent testing he realized the
inefficiency in manually testing this
web application repeatedly so what he
did was he wrote a JavaScript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and he named it as
JavaScript test run later he made this
open source and this was renamed as the
selenium core and this is how selenium
came into existence and since then
selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in Speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate No human errors since your
test cases are automated Human Resources
require to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
Market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like Internet Explorer Chrome Firefox
Safari Edge Opera and even The Headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as I said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in JavaScript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium ID which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features so in
name provides support for different
programming languages like Java python
c-sharp Ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or Advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has suppose for Windows Macs
Linux even Ubuntu as well so you can run
your selenium test on any platform of
your choice and hence selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tools for automating your web
applications selenium set of tools so
let's go a little more deeper into
selenium as I said selenium is not a
single tool it is a suite of tools so
let's look at some of the major
components or the tools in selenium and
what they have to offer so selenium has
four major components one selenium ID
it's the most simplest tool in the suite
of selenium it is integrated development
environment earlier selenium IDE was
available only as a Firefox plugin and
it offered a simple record and Playback
functionality it is a very simple to use
tool but it's mainly used for
prototyping and not used for creating
Automation in the real-time projects
because it has its own limitations like
any other record and replay tool
selenium RC this is nothing but selenium
remote control it is used to write web
application test in different
programming language what it does it
basically interacts with the browser
with the help of something called as RC
server and how it interacts is its uses
a simple HTTP post get request for
communication this was also called as
selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by Webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
Webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium Suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute test cases it is obviously the
successor of the selenium RC which we
talked about because of certain
drawbacks which are C hat so what
Webdriver does is it interacts with the
browsers directly unlike RC where the RC
required a server to interact with the
browser and the last component is the
selenium grid so selenium grid is used
to run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium Webdriver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test Automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an IDE RC and grit and as I said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
RC so RC was on its path of deprecation
and web driver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of Webdriver and also
the RC so they coexisted from tree
thought onwards RC was completely remote
and Webdriver took its place there is
also a four dot version around the
corner and it has more features and
enhancements some some of the features
which are talked about are w3c Webdriver
standardization improved ID and improved
grid now let's look at each of the
components in the selenium Suite
selenium IDE is the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is nothing
but an integrated development
environment for creating your automation
scripts it has a record and Playback
functionality and is a very simple and
easy to use tool it is available as a
Firefox plugin and a Chrome extension so
you can use either of this browser to
record your test scripts it's a very
simple user interface using which you
can create your scripts that interact
with your browser the commands created
in the scripts are called selenis
commands and they can be exported to the
supported programming language and hence
this code can be reused however this is
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitation which any other record
and replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium ID so earlier selenium ID was
only a Firefox extension so we saw that
IDE was available since the selenium
version one selenium ID died with the
Firefox version 55 that was ID was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium ID has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on Chrome as well as as an
add-on on Firefox browser so they
completely revamped this IDE code and
now they have made it available on the
GitHub under the Apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new ID now with this new ID also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side Runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using IDC
on Chrome or Firefox but through command
prompt using your site Runner you can
execute this test cases on any browser
thus by achieving your cross browser
testing control flow statement so
initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are this
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while Loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this ID looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so I'll
say let's go to the Firefox browser so
on this browser I already have the ID
installed so when you already have an ID
installed you will see an icon here
which says selenium ID and how do you
install this you simply need to go to
your Firefox add-ons here whether it
says find more extension so just type in
selenium ID and search for the sixth
Stitch so in the search results you see
the selenium ID just click on that and
now since I've already installed here it
says remove otherwise for you it is
going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium ID icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this ID so when I
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so I already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so I'll go ahead and open that
so I'll say open existing project and I
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
Facebook using a dummy user mail sorry
username and password that's all it's
very simple script with few lines and
this is what it's going to do so what we
will simply do is we'll just run the
script and see how it works for that I'm
just going to reduce the test execution
speed so that you should be able to see
every step of execution here all right
so so what I'll do now here is I'll just
adjust this window and I'll just simply
say run current test all right so I'll
just get this side by side so that you
should be able to see what exactly the
script is doing okay so now you are able
to see both the windows okay so now it's
going to type in your user email here
there you go and now it will enter the
password and it has clicked on the login
button so it's going to take a while to
say login and since these are the dummy
IDs it is you are not able to log in
here and you're going to see this error
window fine that is what is the expected
output here now on the ID if you look
here after I execute the test case every
statement or every command which I have
used here is color coded in green so
that means this particular step was
executed successfully and then here in
the log window it will give you a
complete log of this test case right
from the first step till the end and
your end result is it says FB login
which is my test case name completed
successful let's look at few components
of this ID the first one is the menu bar
so let's go to our ID all right so the
menu bar is right here on the top so
here is your project name so either you
can add a new project here or rename
your project so since we already have
this project which is named as Facebook
and then on the right you have options
to create a new project open an existing
project or save the current project and
then comes our toolbar so using the
options in this toolbar you can control
the execution of your test cases so
first one here is the recording button
so this is what you use when you start
recording your script and then on the
left you have two options here to run
your test cases the first one is run all
tests so in case you have multiple test
cases written here you can execute them
one by one sequentially by using this
run all test else what you can do is if
you just want to run your current test
this is what you would use then idea has
this debugger option which you can use
to do a step execution so say for
example now whenever I run the script
it's going to execute each and every
command here sequentially so instead if
I just select the first command and say
do step execution all right so what it
does is the moment it finishes the First
Command which is opening of Facebook
right I think which is already done here
yeah all right so once this is done it
is going to wait immediately on the
second command and it says paused
debugger so from here you can do
whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is it's just going to Simply go
ahead and complete the com complete the
test case now there is another option
here which is you see the timer there
which says test execution speed so to
execute your test cases in the speed you
want say whenever you're developing an
automation script right and say you want
to give a demo so you need to control
the speed sometimes so that the viewer
is able to exactly see all the steps
which is being performed and this gives
you an option to control that complete
execution right so do you see the
grading here so we have somewhere from
Fast to completely slow execution so the
previous demo which I showed was I
control the speed and then I executed it
so that we could see every command how
it has been executed all right so what's
the next this is called as an address
bar so whichever Wherever Whenever you
enter an URL here that is where you want
to conduct your test and another thing
what it does is it gives a history of
all the URLs which I've used for running
your test then here is where your script
is recorded So each and every
instruction is displayed here in the
order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as login reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https Facebook
book.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or filled so in case there is a failure
you will immediately see this test case
is filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if I click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is a details of this
command which I have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this ID so
with this you'll get an ideas how do we
actually record scripts in ID so for
that I have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon.in then we'll search
simply search for say a product iPhone
and once we get that search page where
all your iPhones are displayed we will
just do an assert on the title of the
page simple all right so let's do that
so first thing what I need is a new URL
okay so first let me go to my Firefox
browser here and say amazon.in so why
I'm doing this just to Simply get the
right URL absolute URL path here and so
that I don't make any mistakes while
typing in the URL okay so I got this so
let me close all this windows I don't
need any of this let's minimize this all
right so here what I will do in the
tests tab I'll say add a new test and
name this test as uh Amazon search done
I'll say add now I'll enter this URL
which I just copied it from my browser
okay and then I'll just say start
recording so what it did was since I
have entered the URL in this address box
it just opened the amazon.in URL now
let's do the test case so in my test
case what I said was I want to search
for iPhone once I have this I'm just
going to click on my search button so
now this gives me a list of all iPhones
and then I said I want to add an
assertion on the title of the this page
so for me to do that what id gives me an
option is I have to just right click
anywhere on this page and you'll see the
selenium ID options here so in this I
will select assert title and then I will
close this browser so that kind of
completes my test case so now take a
look at all the steps which has created
for me so it says open slash because
I've already provided the URL here so
either you can replace it with your
regular URL or you can just leave it as
it is so what I will do since this is
going to be a proper script and I might
be using this to run it from a command
prompt also so I'll just replace this
target with the actual URL and then what
it is doing it is setting a window size
then there are whatever I did on that
particular URL on that website it has
recorded all the steps for me so this is
where it says type into this particular
text box which is my search box and what
did it type iPhone this was the value
which I entered now there was one more
feature which I told you in this new ID
which had which I said it has a fail our
mechanism for your locating techniques
now that is what this is now if you look
here this ID is equal to two tab search
text block this is nothing but the
search box where we entered the text
iPhone and it has certain identification
through which this IDE identifies that
web element and that has multiple
options to select that particular search
box so right now what it has used is ID
is equal to two tab search box however
if you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
CSS and the XPath so how does this help
in failovers say tomorrow if Amazon dot
in website changes the ID of this
element right you are not going to come
and rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular ID fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the ID it simply
moves to the next available ones and and
it tries to search for that element
until one of this becomes true that is
what was the failure mechanism which has
got added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
Asar Title Here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all very simple test case
so what we will do now is we will stop
the recording and then I've also given a
closed browser so right now what I will
do is I'll just comment this out why
because if I just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now I'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now I'll just say run the
current test so your Amazon in is
launched okay it is typed in the iPhone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the lock so it's going to be a
running log so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
Facebook is also in the same lock so we
all have to see the log from running
Amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see here every command
line right it was executed successfully
assert title was also done at your test
case was executed successfully so it
passed now what we will do is on this
assert title I'll just modify this and
let's say just add some text I'll just
add double s here now this by
intentionally I am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the ID behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so I'll just
run the disk test case again so before
that let's close the previous window all
right done and now here I'll also
uncomment the close because anyway it's
a failure which I'm am going to say
which I should be able to see it in the
logs so I'll close the browser after the
execution of test case okay so let's
simply go and run the test case Okay
amazon.in is launched it should search
for iPhone now yeah there you go all
right now it should also close the
browser yes it is close the browser and
it has failed now see here now this is
the line where our Command fit why
because the expected title was not there
and if you look in the logs it says your
assert title on amazon.in failed actual
result was something different and it
did not match with what we had asked it
for so this is how simple it is to use
your ID to create your automation
scripts so we saw all the components of
ID we saw the record button then I
showed you the toolbar I showed you the
editor box and also the test execution
log so now let's come to what are the
limitations of this ID with IDE you
cannot export your scripts your test
scripts to web driver scripts this
support is not yet added but it is in
The Works Data driven testing like using
your Excel the files or reading data
from the CSV files and passing it to the
script this capability is still not
available also you cannot connect to
database for reading your test data or
perform any kind of database testing
with selenium Webdriver yes you can also
unlike selenium Webdriver you do not
have a good reporting mechanism with the
ID like say for example test NG or
report NG so that brings us to the next
component of The Suite which is selenium
RC selenium remote control so selenium
RC was developed by Paul Hammond he
refactored the code which was developed
by Json and was credited with Json as a
co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in Java it is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
Java C sharp Perl Python and Ruby it
interacts with a browser with the help
of an RC server so this RFC server uses
a simple HTTP get and post request for
communication and as I said earlier also
Selena MRC was called as selenium 1.
overshill but it got deprecated in
selenium 2.0 and was completely removed
in 3.0 and it got replaced by what web
driver and we'll see why this happened
and what was that issue which we had
with the RC server so this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
at a very high level so when Jason
Huggins introduced selenium you know the
tool was called as JavaScript program
and then that was also called as a
selenium core so every HTML has a
JavaScript statements which are executed
by web browser and there is a JavaScript
engine which helps in executing this
command now this RC had one major issue
now what was that issue say for example
you have a test script say test dot
JavaScript here which you are trying to
access a limits from anywhere from the
google.com domain so what used to happen
is every element which is accessible are
the elements which can belong only to
google.com domain like say for example
mail the search or the drive so any
elements from this can be accessible
through your test scripts however
nothing outside the domain of say
google.com in this case was accessible
say for example if your test scripts
wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which is under test on the same machine
and imagine if you have to do this for
every machine which is under test this
is not going to be feasible or even
effective all the time and this issue is
called as a same origin policy now what
the same origin policy issue says is it
prohibits a JavaScript from accessing
elements or interacting with scripts
from mid domain different from where it
is launched and this is purely for the
security measure so if you have written
a scripts which can access your
google.com or anything related to
google.com these scripts cannot not
access any elements outside the domain
like as we said in the example yahoo.com
this was the same origin policy now to
overcome this what this gentleman did
was he created something called as
selenium remote control server to trick
the browser in believing that your
course your selenium core and your web
application under test are from the same
domain and this is what was the selenium
remote control so if you look at again a
high level architecture or how did this
actually work first you write your test
scripts which is here right in any of
the supported language like your PHP or
your Java or Python and before we start
testing we need to launch this RC server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the Cellini's commands and
these Cellini's commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your RC server the browser interaction
which happens through RC server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple HTTP post and
get request and that is how your RC
server and your browser communicate and
how exactly this communication happens
this RC server it acts like a proxy so
say your test scripts asked to launch a
browser so what happens is this commands
goes to your server and then your RC
server launches the browser it injects
the JavaScript into the browser once
this is done all the subsequent calls
from your test script right from your
test scripts to your browser goes
through your RC and now upon upon
receiving these instruction your
selenium core executes this actual
commands as JavaScript commands on the
browser and then the test results are
displayed back from your browser to your
RC to your test scripts so the same
cycle gets repeated right until the
complete test case execution is over so
for every command what you write in your
JavaScript here or your test script here
goes through a complete cycle of going
through the RC server to the browser
collecting the results again from the RC
server back to your test scripts so this
cycle gets repeated for every command
until your complete test execution is
done so RC had definitely a lot of
shortcomings and what are those so RC
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts which we just
saw so that was an additional setup
since it acts as a mediator between your
commands which is your Cellini's
commands and your browser the
architecture of RC is complicated why
because of its intermediate RC server
which is required to communicate with
the browser the execution of commands
takes very long it is slower we know why
because every command in this takes a
full trip from the test script to your
RC server to the core engine to the
browser and then back to the same route
which makes your overall test execution
very slow lastly the AP is supported by
RC are very redundant and confusing so
RC does have a good number of apis
however it is less object oriented so
they are redundant and Confused say for
example say if you want to write into a
text box how and when to use a type key
command or just a type command is always
confusing another example is some of the
mouse commas using a click or a mouse
dot both kind of you know almost
providing a similar functionality so
that is the kind of confusion which
developers use to create hence
selenium RC got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome this shortfalls web driver was
introduced so while RC was introduced in
2004 web driver was introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006. It's a class platform
testing platform so Webdriver can run on
any platform like say Linux Windows Mac
or even if you have a Ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ID and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the web driver method so
when I do a demo you will understand
what this Webdriver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like RC so it is pretty fast why because
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the RC hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs and this
driver is responsible to make the
browser understand the commands which
you will be passing from the script like
say for example click of a button or you
want to enter some text so through your
script you tell which browser you want
to work with say Chrome and then the
Chrome driver is responsible for
interpreting your instructions and to
execute it on the web application
launched on the Chrome browser so like
RC Webdriver also supports multiple
programming languages in which you can
write your test Scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various Frameworks like test NG
junit and unit and Report entry so when
we talk about the limitations of
Webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various Frameworks and Tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
Webdriver at a high level what is in
Webdriver so Webdriver consists of four
major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries right or what we also call it
as language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if I go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your Bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all the
stabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that I'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you're
working with Java here what you need to
do is you need to download your Java
language binding so let's go back to the
presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser
and when we do the demo I'll be showing
you some of this APS right and these are
nothing but the rest apis and everything
whatever we do through the script
happens through the rest calls then we
have a Json wire protocol what is Json
JavaScript object notation it is nothing
but a standard for exchanging data over
the web so for example you want to say
launch a web application through your
script
so what selenium does it it creates a
Json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as I said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation so does selenium so let's
look at what these limitations are and
if there are any workarounds for them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like APM
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool however what
selenium provides is a support for
integrating this APM tool which is
nothing but a mobile application
automation tool and using APM and
selenium you can still achieve mobile
application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium I said that with Webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallely on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of web driver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about also if you want to
know more details as how do we work with
the grid how do you want to install that
grid so do check out our video on simply
learn website on selenium grid third
limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium Webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test NG report NG and even extend
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it also there are other
challenges with selenium like selenium
is not very good with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like autoit
and securely so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation needs and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium RC and the web driver
so RC has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
RC server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser web driver
architecture is pretty simple execution
speed
it is slower in RC and much faster than
Webdriver why because in Webdriver we
have eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that's the RC server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers it
requires an RC server to interact with
the browsers we just talked about it and
whereas Webdriver can directly interact
with the browser
so RC again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant ABS which kept developers
guessing as which API to use for what
functionality however Webdriver offers
pretty clean apis to work with
RC did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in Webdriver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website then type the
selenium in search bar and click on it
and click on the selenium 3.0 training
so we are basically searching for
selenium 3.0 training on the simply
learn website first let's do the steps
manually and then we will go ahead and
write the automation script so let's go
to my browser on my browser what I'll do
is let me first launch the simply learn
website
okay and here what my use case step says
is I need to search for selenium and
click on the search button so once I do
that it is going to give me a complete
list of all kind of selenium trainings
which is available with simpler and what
I'm interested in is the selenium 3.0
training here once I find this on the
web page I need to go and click on that
all right so this is all the steps which
we are going to perform in this use case
okay now so for writing the test cases
I'll be using an ID which is Eclipse
I've already installed my eclipse and
also I have installed selenium in this
instance of my Eclipse all right so if
you can see the reference library folder
here you will see all the jars which are
required for the selenium to work next
another prereq which is required for
selenium and that is your driver files
now every browser which you want to work
with has its own driver file to execute
your selenium scripts and since for this
demo I'll be working with the Firefox
browser I will need a driver file for
Firefox now driver file for Firefox is
the gecko driver which I have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers now where did I download
this from let's go ahead and see that so
if I go back to my browser and if you go
to your selenium hq.website you have to
go to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this
you'll see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selling it and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
I am working on Mac this is the file
which I'm using if you're a Windows user
you need to download this ZIP file and
unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
Firefox or a chrome driver for your
Chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project and just
place the driver files here so these are
the two prereqs for your selenium one is
importing your jar files like this and
then having your drivers downloaded and
keep them under a folder where you can
reference to okay so now we'll go ahead
and create a class I already have a
package created in this project so I'll
use this project and create a new class
so I'll say create new Java class and
let's call this as
search training I'll be using a public
static wordman and I'll click on finish
so let's remove this Auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your code is what you need
to do is you need to define or declare
your driver variable using your class
web driver so what I would do is I'll
say Webdriver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this ID is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from
org.opensq.sellini this is the package
which we will need all right so you have
a driver created which is of the class
web driver and now after this I am going
to create three methods all right so
first method I will have for launching
the Firefox browser okay and then I will
write a simple method for
searching
selenium training
and clicking on it this is the actual
use case what we'll be doing and then
third method I'm going to write is just
to close the browser which I'm going to
be opening right so these are the
different methods which I'll be creating
and from the public static wordman I
will just call these methods one after
the other okay so let's go ahead and
write the first method now my first
method is launching the Firefox browser
so I'll say public void since my return
type is null or there is no return type
for this let's call it as launch browser
okay all right now in this for launching
any browser I need to mention two steps
now the first step is where I need to do
a system.set property okay let's do that
first and then I'll explain what this
does I'll just say system dot set
property so this accepts a key and a
value pair so what is my key here my key
here is Webdriver dot gecko dot driver
and I need to provide a value so value
is nothing but the path to the gecko
driver and we know that this gecko
driver which I'm going to use here is
right here in the same project path
under the drivers folder okay and that
is what the path which I am going to
provide here so here simply I need to
say drivers slash gecko driver gec KO
all right done and let me close this
sentence all right now since I'm a Mac
User my gecko driver installable is just
the name gecko driver if your windows
use user and if you are running your
selenium scripts on the Windows machine
you need to provide a complete path to
this including dot exe because driver
executable on your machines is going to
be gecko driver.exe all right so just
make sure that your path which you
mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is I
need to just say driver is equal to new
Firefox driver okay so this command new
Firefox driver creates an instance of
the Firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the Firefox driver class is
present okay we did that now these two
lines are responsible for launching the
Firefox browser form so this is done so
what's my next step in the use case now
I need to launch the website simply
learn so for that we have a command
called driver dot get driver dot get
what it does is whatever URL you're
going to give it here in this double
quotes as an argument it is going to
launch that particular website and for
us it's a simply learn website so what I
do as a best practices instead of typing
out the URL I go to my browser launch
that URL which I want to test and I
simply copy it come back to your eclipse
and just simply paste it so this ensures
that I do not make any mistakes in the
URL okay so done so our first method is
ready where we are launching the browser
which is our Firefox browser and then
launching the simply learn website now
the next method what is my next method
in my next method I need to give the
search string to search selenium
training on this particular website now
for that we need to do few things what
are those few things let's go to the
website again all right so let me
relaunch this let's close this okay let
me remove all this and let's go to the
home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when I did a manual
testing of this I entered the text here
so now since I have to write a script
for this first I need to identify what
this element momentous for that what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to say
right click here and I'll say inspect
element all right now this element let's
see what attribute it has which I can
use for finding this element so I I see
that there is an ID present so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to Simply
use this ID and then I'll just copy this
ID from here go back to Eclipse let's
write a method first so I'll say public
void and what do we give the method name
say search training or just search all
right now in this I need to use a
command called driver dot find element
by ID is what I'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the ID which I copied from the website
is what I'm going to paste here okay and
then what am I going to do on this
element is I need to send that text the
text which I'm going to search for which
is selenium so I'll just say send keys
and whatever text I want to send I need
to give it in double quotes So for that
selenium so this is done so now I've
entered the text texture and after
entering the text I need to click on
this button so for that I need to first
know what that button is so let's
inspect that search button okay now if
you look at the search button other than
the tag which is span and the class name
I do not have anything here all right so
what I can do is I can either use the
class name or I can write an X path
since this is a demo which we have
already used ID locating technique I
would go ahead and use the X path here
so for me to construct an X path I will
copy this class first okay and then I
already have a crow path installed on my
Firefox so I'll use the crop path and
first test my X bar so I'll just say
double slash let's see what was that
element it has a span tag okay so I'll
have to use span and at class equal to
and I'll just copy the class name here
and let's see if it can identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so I'll just use this x path in my code
so I'll go back to eclipse and I'll say
driver dot find element by dot X path
and the X path which I just copied from
cropath is what I'm going to paste here
and what is the action I need to do here
I need to say click done so I have
reached a stage where I have entered
this selenium okay and then I have
clicked on the search button once I do
this I know that expected result is I
should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.0 training okay and
I should be able to click on that so for
that again I need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag H2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so I would again would like
to use a x path here now this time while
using the X path I am going to make use
of a text functionality so that I can
search for this particular text so I'll
simply copy this I'll go to my Crow path
the tag is H2 so I'll say simply H2 okay
and here I'll say text equal to and this
is the text which I copied I missed out
that yes there so I'm just going to add
an S okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see your blue dotted line it
is able to show us which element it is
identified so I'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ID Eclipse so now
here what I need to do is I'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot X path and paste the X path which
we just did and then again I have to do
a click operation done all right so
technically we have taken all the steps
of the use case and we have written the
commands for that now let's add an
additional thing here say after coming
to this page after finding this we want
to uh say print the title of this page
now what is the title of this page if
you just hover your mouse on this it
says online and classroom training for
professional certification courses
simply now so what I will do is after
doing all these operations I will just
print out this page title on our console
so for that I have to just do this try
fiber dot so let's do a sys out so I'll
say sys out
system.out.println okay and here I would
say let's add a text here the page title
is and then let's append it with driver
dot get title so this is the command
which we'll be using to fetch the page
title done now what is the last method I
need to add just to close the browser
all right so let me add a method here
I'll say public void close browser and
it's a one single command which I need
to call I'll say driver dot quit Okay
and then I need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so I let me use my class name which is
this so I'm going to create an object
obj is equal to new class name and then
using this object first is I need to
call the method launch browser and then
I'll call the method search right and
then I'll call the method close browser
so technically our script is ready with
all the functionality which we wanted to
cover from our use case now there are
few other tweaks which I need to do this
and I'll tell you why I need to do this
now for example after we click here
right after we click on the search if
you observed on your website it took a
little while before it listed out all
the selenium trainings for us and
usually when you are actually doing it
you wait for the selenium 3.0 training
to be available and then you click on
that now same thing you also need to
tell your scripts to do that you need to
tell your scripts to wait for a while
until you start seeing the selenium 3.0
training or it appears on your web page
there are multiple ways to do that in
your script and it is a part of overall
synchronization what we call where we
use kind of implicit and explicit kind
of image now since this is a demo for
demo purpose what I'm going to do is I
am going to use a command called
thread.sleep and I'm just going to give
an explicit weight of say three seconds
so you can use this Main only for the
demo purposes you can use a thread.sleep
command now this thread.sleep command
needs us to handle some exceptions so
I'm just going to click on ADD throws
declaration and say interrupted
exception now same thing I'll have to do
it in my main function also okay so
let's do that and complete it all right
so this is done so by doing this what am
I doing I'm ensuring that before I click
on the selenium three dot training we
are giving enough time for the script to
wait until the web page shows this link
to the selenium 3.0 training that's one
thing I'm doing all right and also now
since you are going to be seeing this
demo through the video recording the
script when it starts running it is
going to be very fast so you might just
miss out saying how it does the send
keys and how did it click on the search
button for us to enable us to see it
properly I'll just add some explicit
weights here just for a demo purpose so
after entering the keys right so what
I'll do is I'll just give a simple
thread.sleep here yeah
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds which should be good enough okay
at three seconds weight should be good
enough here so that we should be able to
see how exactly this works on your
browser when we execute this okay now
our complete script is ready so what
I'll do is I'll just save the script and
then we will simply run the script so to
run the script I just say right click
run as Java application okay it says ask
me to select and save I have saved the
script now so let's observe how it runs
okay the simply learn.com the website is
launched so the selenium text has been
entered in the search box it has clicked
on the search okay all right so now it
did everything whatever we wanted it to
do all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what I have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what we'll
do since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium 3.0 training or
not I'll just comment out the closed
browser uh the command okay so we will
not call the close browser so that the
browser remains open and we get to see
whether did it really find the training
link or not okay so let me close this
window we don't need this Firefox window
close all tabs and then I'll just
re-execute the script so I'll say run as
Java application so save the file okay
simplylearn.com is launched so search
text is entered now it's going to click
on the search button yes all right so
we've got the search results it should
click on selenium 3.0 training and yes
it is successfully able to click on that
all right so now it's not going to close
the browser because we have commented on
that line however it did print us the
title here all right so this is a simple
way of using the selenium Scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with Webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by Patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallelly so design
is in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run tests and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has as a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
system like as in this picture you could
say one of them is a Windows machine one
of them is a Mac machine and another one
is say a Linux machine so your
requirement is to run the test on all
supported browsers and operating systems
like the one which is depicted in this
picture so what you have to do is first
thing is you configure a Master machine
or what you also call it as a hub by
running something called a selenium
Standalone server and this Talent
Standalone server can be downloaded from
the selenium HQ website using the server
you create a hub configuration that is
this node and then you create nodes
specific to your machine requirement and
how are these nodes created you again
use the same server which is your
Standalone selenium server to create the
node configuration so I'll show you
where the selenium server can be
downloaded so if we go back to our
selenium HQ website so you can see here
right on the top it says selenium
Standalone server and this is the latest
version available so you just need to
download once you download this keep a
version of this one on your master
machine that is your Hub and this should
also be present on your node machines
and there is a certain command which you
can use to install the server as a node
and as a master depending on your
configuration so once that is done you
have your master and your master or the
Hub and the notes created your master
can control on which nodes you want to
execute test now say if this is a Mac
machine this is a Windows machine
through your master or your Hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what is then also you could have
a multiple combination of tests like say
for example smoke test to be run on all
these nodes that's the kind of
configuration you can create or a
certain component and test to be run on
say only Windows 10 with an edge browser
or say regression test on Mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the Hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the Node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the Node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it intends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does is grid have now
the first one it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications it is pretty static each
server is configured in advance with a
subset of required browser instances
available so if you want to vary this
you'll need to reconfigure so any
configuration tomorrow on any machines
you want to change it cannot be done
automatically you need to completely
reconfigure that node and then add it
back to the grid thirdly although it is
available to run on Virtual servers it
is actually not designed as a cloud
native application and because of as a
result of this it isn't optimized to
take advantage of things like say
distributed storage or dynamic scaling
or even automatic failover so these are
some of the limitations of the grid
advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy of course since there is no
manual execution your test can run
faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution and you can run or
execute large volumes of test within a
very short time frame let's take an
example say before just before the
release of your product say during the
last lap of your testing you find a bug
and of course it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and you want to
run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second Advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support So this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping in achieving a
very broad test coverage and we also saw
that really easy to use tool right so
you can check out all our videos and you
can it's just a matter of time that you
can Master the skill of writing your
automation scripts reusability of course
like any programming language it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy well again
let's see an overall what are the
limitations of selenium itself now since
selenium is open source that is one of
the biggest Advantage now there is a
little disadvantage which comes with
that and what is that you do not have
much technical support because it's an
open source code however there are loads
and loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like APM for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like autoit and securely which can be
integrated with cell linear selenium
Webdriver has limited a limited
reporting capability but again it does
provide us support for integrating tools
like test NG report NG and extend report
it does not have test management
capabilities it need not right not one
tool need not have each and everything
what is required but there is always a
way to integrate it so selenium does
provide a way to integrate any of the
test management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation how to install
selenium on Windows system selenium
installation is a three-step process so
it has certain prereqs the first
prerequis you need to have Java on your
system so we will be installing Java
first and then we will be working with
Eclipse ID so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install
selenium for Java we will install the
version Java 8 and for Eclipse we have a
version 4.10 this was the last stable
version which was released in December
last year so I'll be using that version
and selenium we will download the latest
3.14 version okay so let's get started
with our first step which is the Java
installation so to install Java let's go
to the browser and simply just search
for Java 8 download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your Java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the Oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdkits and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the Oracle log into that
account and then you can just download
the Java 8. so since I already have an
account and I have already downloaded
the package but I'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this Java development kit 8211 so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
Windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as I said I've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what I've done is
I've just created a directory called
installers and I'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here I have
a folder called Java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install Java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can change
the directory to the choice of whatever
drive and the folder structure you want
to I would like to leave it as default
here and we'll just go and click on next
and then the Java installation is in
progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what I'll do is I'll go to my
command prompt and I'll suggest say Java
minus version so it says Java version
1.8 and this tells us that the Java is
installed successfully now after this
installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
we are also going to set a Java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the Java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the Java got
installed was in program files Java I
have there are certain previous versions
which are installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here that's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what I have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so so what I
will do is I'll just copy this path and
then go to your control panel here go to
your where is my system yeah so click on
the system go to Advanced system setting
and here in the environment variables
find the PATH variable okay and then say
edit now what are we doing here in the
path variable is we are going to add the
Java bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say Ctrl V
paste the path which you have just
copied from the Explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the Java now
what I'll do for that is I just say new
I'll just type Java home here and what
is the value of this we need to set we
need to set the same path but without
the print directory so we just need to
set the path till your Java directory
that is this so we'll just copy the path
again and paste it here that is up just
say Okay click on Okay click on OK here
and we are done so again let's go to our
Command Prompt and just say Java minus
version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed Java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
Eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 2019 0 6. so
especially with Eclipse since it's an
open source I prefer to work with the
last stable version and so does most of
the developers do and hence that is the
reason why I have picked up the version
which is like last year's version which
is 4.10 which was released in last
December so you can always choose to go
with the latest version but then if
there are any issues and if you are like
first time working with the eclipse
you're going to get confused as where
these issues are coming from right so I
would still recommend that you use the
last stable version which is available
with your records so now to get the last
stable version what you need to do is go
and click on this download packages and
here if to scroll down this page you can
see here more downloads so there is a
list of all the previous releases of app
Clips which is available and this is
what we need to download so just click
on that 4.10 version and then click on
the OS on which you want to install
eclipse for us it is Windows so I'll
just click here on the 64-bit windows
and then click on the download and you
will be downloading the complete package
so once you download this is what it
will look like so let's go back to our
directory of installers so this is the
installer for the Eclipse which I got
now what's the next step I need to do
just launch this installer and install
Eclipse so I'll just say double click on
this I'll say run
so here you will see multiple options
here for Eclipse installation so
depending on your requirement you can go
ahead and install any of these packages
so for us we just need an eclipse ID for
Java developers so I'll select this and
I'll say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so I have chosen D drive here
this is a default directory name it
takes which is okay we can leave it as
it is and then also you have an option
to create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
just say select all you can close this
window just say select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this workspace directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
Java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you're going to create
through Eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is I'll go to the D drive and I
already have a directory so here I'll
create I'll just create select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace I'll say my workspace and then
I'll say launch so every time I open the
eclipse right so if this is going to
take as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain Windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so I'll
say file new and since I'm going to be
using Java with selenium I'll say create
Java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the JRE which
you want to use so we just install this
jdk 1.8 okay so I'm going to click on
use default JRE otherwise you also have
an option to use a Project Specific gr
for example I could have two different
projects where one project I'm going to
be working with GRE 1.8 and there is
another project which I want to work
with the latest Java maybe Java 12 and I
can have more than one Java installed on
the machine so this gives me an option
to select whichever Java I want to work
with so if you have another Java
installed here it will show up in this
list so and you can just go ahead and
select that now since we have only one
Java installed on our machine which is
Java 1.8 I will say use default GRE
which is 1.8 and I will click on finish
now if You observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
Java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selling
so let me go to my browser and here I
will be going to the
seleniumhq.org so if you are working
with selenium this particular website
the seleniumhq.org is going to be a
Bible everything and anything related to
selenium is available in this website
whether you want to download the files
whether you want to refer to the
documentation anything regarding to
selenium is available here so what we
want now is the installables for
selenium so here go to the the download
tab now for you to install selenium and
start working with selenium there are
three things which are required for you
to download one is a standalone selenium
server so this is not required
immediately when you get started with
selenium however when you start working
with remote selenium Webdriver you would
be requiring this when you have a grid
setup you will be requiring the
Standalone server so for that what you
can do is you can just download the
latest version available here so when
you click on that it'll download the
file into your download folder so this
is one particular file which you need to
keep next selenium client and Webdriver
language mine takes now in today's demo
we will be looking at selenium with Java
so that means my client package of java
is what I need to download so whatever
programming language selenium supports
we have respective downloadables
available with that so if you're working
with python then you need to download
your client library for Python and since
we are working with Java you need to
download this package so simply what you
need to do click on this link and it
will download the Java package file
which are basically the jar files so we
have client libraries now and then there
is another component what we need now
with a linear you're going to be
automating your web browser applications
correct and you also want your
applications to run on multiple browsers
so that means your scripts the
automation scripts which you create
should be able to run on any browser
selenium works with multiple browsers
like Edge Safari Chrome Firefox and
other browsers even it has a support for
headless browser now every browser which
it supports comes with its own driver
file now say for example we want to say
work with Firefox driver so that means
for us to start working with Firefox
browser we need to download something
called as a gecko driver here and if you
want to work with Chrome browser you
need to install the Chrome driver so
depending on what browsers you'll be
testing with go ahead Click on each of
this link and download the latest driver
files now since we are going to be
working with Firefox in this demo what I
need to do is I just need to click here
on the latest link so when I click on
the latest link it is going to take me
to this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for Linux for mac and for
Windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file I need because
we are working on Windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
selenium hq.org for us to install
sending so let me show you the folder
where I have already downloaded all this
so if you see here selenium Java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client Library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once I download this this is a
ZIP file after I unzip the file this is
the folder structure I see and let's see
what is there in this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selenium and then we also downloaded the
driver files so what I did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser I created a directory here
called drivers and have kept all my
browser drivers here so I have a driver
file downloaded for Chrome I want to
work with Firefox so I have a gecko
driver here and then for Internet
Explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this JRE libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium Jazz to
this library and how do we add that on
your right you can see this add external
jars click on ADD external Jazz go to
your folder where you have downloaded
your selenium which is this select all
the jar files which is available so I
have two jar files here I'll just say
click open again I will click on ADD
external jars now from the lips folder I
will select all this five so select all
the five jars and click on open so you
should see all the seven jar files here
so once you have this just say apply and
close now if you look into your project
directory here you will see some a
folder called referenced library and
this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in Eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts so for us to install Java let us
go to our browser
and simply what I'll do is I'll just
Google for Java 8 download
so we would select the Oracle site for
downloading the SD okay so once you go
here you can see that we have something
called as Java software development kit
8 u211 so this is the version we'll be
working with so in order for you to
download you need to have an oracle
account so since I already have one I
have directly been logged into that so
if you do not have an oracle account
please go ahead create an account for
yourself so that you can download any of
the Java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so I'll be downloading this
package for that I need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on Mac this
is the package which I'm going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since I have
already downloaded the package and I
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what I have
done is I've created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what I have
downloaded it and kept it here so we'll
go step by step so that you understand
what each of these packages are so as
you see here I have the jdk8 which I've
already downloaded so let's go ahead and
install jtk so how do we install jdk so
you have the DMG file here you just go
ahead and double click on that
okay and then I'll double click on this
package
and then we will say continue and
install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay I've given my password and I'll say
install the software
it's probably it will just take a couple
of minutes to install Java okay there
you go so now the Java has been
installed so let me close this window
let me close this window too and then
now I'll go to my terminal window so
let's open my terminal and here
let's say Java minus version bingo so
there we have Java 1.8 installed on our
system now there are couple of other
things which you need to do apart from
installation of your jdk you also need
to set some system variables right so in
Mac how do you set the system variables
or the environment variables you do that
in your bash profile so let's see how we
do that all right so what I will do is
I'll use an editor which is my VI okay
and then I'll open my bash profile so
what is Bash profile it's a config file
for your bash cell this is mainly used
to export variables in your shell like
in Windows we are going to do the system
variable setting from the advanced
setting right so similarly we are going
to do that here so I'll say VI Dot bash
underscore profile so this is the file
where I will be adding Java homework
now I have other parts here already
written because I'm working with other
multiple software on this machines and
now I'll go to the end of this file and
I'll say
export
Java home
equal to now what is the path we need to
give for Java home we need to give the
path where the Java has been installed
on your system okay first let's go and
find out that path so let's go back to
our finder
and then I have a folder called Library
here so here
there is a Java and then there is
something called as Java virtual
machines so if you have a single Java or
multiple Java versions installed so all
those versions you're going to see under
this directory which is Java virtual
machines and Java one dot is is what we
installed just now so let me go and open
that folder there is something called as
content and then home and in this you
have your JRE and Bin folder so that
means I need to give my Java Home Path
until here till this home directory so
simply what I'm going to do is I'll just
go here say get info because I want to
just copy the path and what you can do
is you copy this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here I'm going to paste this path
plus I want to tell the home directory
so I'm just going to type out homie home
that is it so you have now set your Java
home environment variable so simply you
do
save the file Escape colon WQ and come
out of it and now what you need to do
for this batch profile uh to be
activated you just exit out of this
terminal
okay close this terminal window and I'll
go ahead and open another terminal so
let me close this info text so here let
me again give Java minus version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our Java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your Java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences okay here you
will see this Java control panel okay
this is another way of finding out that
your Java has been installed
successfully on the machine so you can
just open this Java control panel and if
there is any settings which you want to
do here you can do it through your
control panel also
all right
let's close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder Windows
so we have successfully done our step
one so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what I will do I'll go to my
browser
okay and now I'll open another tab here
and I'll say
Eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you're working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
I would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what we are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions I just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that on this
page if you scroll down you will see
something called as more downloads right
in this you will see all the bills of
Eclipse which is available all your
previous versions So since today I'll be
working with 4.10 version I will go
ahead and click on this 4.10 this 4.10
was released last year this is 2018
December okay and now when you look at
this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what I would be using is Eclipse ID
for Java developers so since we are
going to be working on Mac I will go
ahead and click on this downloadable
and then I'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me I've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installer okay so now
do you see this Eclipse Java 2018 12 are
blah blah blah dot DMG so this is the
file which we're going to be using to
install Eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk I'm going to double click on
this and install the eclipse let's see
how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now I'll just move this
folder into applications
done so my eclipse is ready now so
simply let's go ahead and launch so what
I'll do I'll just simply search for that
on my system Eclipse there you go and
I'll just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it
okay it is launching it so did you see
how simple the eclipse installation is
it's just downloading the package and
just installing it on your Mac machine
all right when you start the eclipse for
the first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you are going to keep all your folders
all your Java code or whatever you're
going to do in Eclipse all under that
particular directory so right now it
gives me a default directory rather what
I will do is since I have created a
separate folder for our demos I will go
ahead and select that folder which is
why simply Denmark
and then in this I will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files I'm going to
create whatever code I'm going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then I'll go ahead and
say launch so it'll take a minute to
load your workbench yeah there it goes
so when you launch your Eclipse right so
let me just make this window bigger the
first screen what you are going to see
is the welcome screen just go ahead and
choose the welcome skills and this is
the first view of your eclipse what
you're going to get so let's close out
all the windows which we are not going
to be working today and I just need this
main screen here now what is the first
step you're going to do once you have
the eclipse I would go ahead and create
a project first so I'll simply say open
file new Java project let's give a nice
name to this since this is our first
project which is going to be created so
I'll say selenium
first project
now if You observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
Eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it has done while I create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution JRE which
you already have on the system okay
that's why it is already chosen Java one
dot it in case you have multiple Javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is you can always go here select this
and select the Java of your choice so
say if you've got the latest Java which
is Java 12 installed on your system it
will give you an option here along with
Java software 8 it will give you Java 12
year so you can go ahead and select that
for this particular project that option
is also available now since we have only
one jtk installed here I will go ahead
and create this project
so I just click on finish and it's going
to create a projection so there are few
default things which it creates created
one is definitely the Jr system
libraries right this is what we told
Eclipse when we created project that my
Java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our Java programs to work
in our Eclipse ID and then it creates a
SRC which is your Source directory
wherein where we'll be creating all our
Java code or our selenium test scripts
okay good so far so this is a simple way
of installing your eclipse and getting
your Eclipse ready to work with your
Selena all right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
HQ Dot
so this is going to be a Bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what I do is
I go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with Selena
one is the selenium Standalone server
right so when you're going to be working
with remote selenium Webdriver is when
you would require this however I would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what I just need
to do is I need to click on this and
it's going to download This Server form
okay so I have already downloaded it and
I'll show you that and then what we need
is the selenium client and Webdriver
language findings okay we need a client
so what is the client which you are
going to work with we are going to
working with Java client with the
selling it and for that I need to go
ahead and download this if you're
working on say C sharp or a ruby or
python then you have the respective
packages which you can go and download
now since we are going to be working
with Java here I would go ahead and
click on this and this is going to
download the Java client formula now as
I said since I've already downloaded it
so let's go ahead and look at what are
those downloadables what we have so
let's close out this window now if you
see here one is the selenium server
Standalone which we just downloaded and
then when you download the client
libraries what it does it it creates a
zip file it downloads a zip file and it
unzips it and what is contained in that
particular folder so if you look here
selenium Java 3 in this folder you have
multiple jar files with which is what we
will be working with Selena so here you
have two jar files here and then under
the folder Labs you have other jar files
now these are the files which we will
need and now let's see how do we utilize
this file in our Eclipse so for that
let's go back to our Eclipse okay so let
me maximize this window so in Eclipse
first thing what you need to do is click
on your project okay right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path go to the build path and say
configure build path now here in this
configure build path what you need to do
is go to your libraries okay go to add
external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium site so that is present in our
selenium Java 3. so what I'll do I'll
simply select
these two first
okay
then again you click on the external jar
file so what we have is in Libs so
select all the jar files in the list
say open okay you have all the Java
files what we need identified it go
ahead and click on apply and close once
you do that how do you know whether all
those jars have been imported correctly
go to the reference libraries here you
should be able to see all the selenium
jars which we have downloaded to be
listed out here and so it lists here so
that means we have successfully imported
selling hello this is Matthew from
Simply learn and today we're going to go
through part one of a two-part series on
interview questions that you are likely
to be asked if you are interviewing for
a job that focuses on devops so there
are approximately seven sections that we
cover in devops we go from general
devops questions source code management
with tools such as git continuous
integration and here we'll focus on
Jenkins continuous testing with tools
such as selenium and then you also have
the operation side of devops which is
your configuration management with tools
such as Chef puppet enhanceable
containerization with Docker and then
continuous monitoring with tools such as
nagios so let's just get into those
general devops questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is devops different from agile
and the reality is is that devops is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
Solutions that's different from agile if
we look at the evolution of delivery
over the last five to ten years we've
gone from waterfall based delivery to
Agile delivery which is on Sprints to
where we are with continuous integration
and continuous delivery around devops
the whole concept of devops is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and opt team
another area in which I see that devops
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app to your
chatbot or any digital solution that you
have and has an expectation when you're
going through and actually doing a
devops paradigm the old model would be
that you would capture requirements from
the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there'd be these barriers between each
of those as we move faster through from
waterfall to Agile what we saw is that
with agile we're able to respond much
faster to customer months so instead of
it being weeks or months sometimes in
some cases years between releases of
software what we saw it would was a
transition to weeks and months for
releases on software now we see with
devops is that the release cycle has
shrunk even further with the goal of
continuously delighting the customer how
further has that release cycle shrunk
too there are companies that have gone
from having releases of once a week or
once every two weeks or once a month to
now having multiple releases a day
indeed some companies have up to 50
releases a day this isn't something to
also bear in mind is that each of those
releases are tested and verified against
test records so that you can guarantee
that the code that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases of devops so
effectively there are two main phases of
devops there's the planning and coding
phase and and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
Jenkins that allows you to integrate
between both environments some of the
core benefits that you may have to
devops are going to be some technical
benefits and some business benefits so
when somebody asks you what are the
benefits of devops you can reply that
from a technical point of view you're
able to use continuous software delivery
to constantly push out code that has
been tested and verified against scripts
that have been written and approved you
can be able to push out smaller chunks
of code so that when you have an issue
you're not having to go through massive
blocks of code or massive projects
you're going through just very small
micro services or small sections of code
and you're able to detect and correct
problems faster on the business side the
benefits are absolutely fantastic from a
customer that's coming to your website
and or to your a mobile app they're
going to see responses happening
continuously so that the customer is
always aware that you as a company are
listening to their demands and
responding appropriately you're able to
provide a more stable environment and
you're able to scale that environment to
the demands of the number of customers
that are using your services so how you
approach a project that needs to
implement devops so this is really an
exciting area for you to be in so there
are effectively three stages when it
comes to actually working in a devops
the first stage is an assessment stage
and think of this as the back of the
napkin ideation stage this is where you
are sitting with a business leader and
they're giving you ideas of what they
would like to see from feedback that
they've had from their customers this is
Blue Sky opportunity this is thinking of
Big Ideas that second stage and this
often comes as a fast follow to stage
one it's actually prove moving out that
concept so developing a proof of concept
and a proof of concept can actually be a
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering will really depend on
how complicated you want the POC to be
but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the POC so that when you
present this to a customer they're able
to respond to that creation that you've
developed and able to give you feedback
to be able to validate that you are
going with the right solution and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your devops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code based on a backlog of
features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with devops what
you're also looking at is putting an
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that's being delivered
so that once you've actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated where are the failure points
and you want to use that data and feed
that back into your continuous
integration and have that as a means to
be able to backfill the demand of work
that gets completed in the bank log so
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so continuous delivery is
based on putting out code that can be
deployed safely to production an
insurance that your businesses and
functions are running as you would
expect them to be so it's going through
and completing the code that you would
actually see continuous deployment in
contrast is all about ensuring that
you're automating the deployment of a
production environment so you're able to
go through and scale up your
environments to meet the demands of both
the solution and the customer this makes
software development and release
processes much more faster and more
robust so if we look here we can
actually see where continuous
integration and continuous deployment
come hand in hand so when you actually
start out with the initial pushes of
your code that's where you're doing your
continuous integration and your
continuous delivery and then at some
point you want to get very comfortable
with deploying the code that you're
creating so it's being pushed out to
your production environment so one of
the things that's great about working
with the tools that you use in a devops
continuous integration and can
continuous delivery model is that the
development tools that you use the
containerization tools the testing tools
should always reflect the production
environment and what this means is that
when you actually come to deploying
solutions to production there are no
surprises because your development team
have been working against that exact
same environment all the way through so
a question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of a
configuration Management in Dev apps and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas I'm the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences
there's the ability manage and handle
large changes to multiple systems in
seconds rather than days hours or weeks
as that may have happened before the
second area is that you want to also
demonstrate the business reasons for
having configuration management and the
business reason here is that it allows
I.T and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to manage a
significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
in it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed on cloud or
private cloud and allow you to do this
with high accuracy so how does
continuous monitoring help and maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring is that with being able to
effectively monitor your entire network
24 7. for any changes as they happen
you're able to identify and Report those
thoughts or threats immediately and
respond immediately for your entire
network instead of having to wait as it
happens sometimes for a customer to
email or call you and say hey your
website's down nobody wants that that's
an embarrassing thing the other three
areas that you want to be able to
highlight are the ability to be able to
ensure that the right software and the
right services are running on the right
resources that's your number one
takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
required hiring manually monitoring but
having a agent that's monitoring those
servers continuously and then the third
is that by scripting out and
continuously monitoring your entire
environment you're creating a self-audit
trail that you can take back and
demonstrate the effectiveness of the
operations environment that you are
providing so one of the cloud companies
that is a strong advocate for devops is
Amazon's web services AWS and they have
a really five distinct areas them that
you can zero in on board services so
when the question comes up what is the
role of AWS in devops you want to really
hold out your hand and list of five
areas of focus using your thumb and
finger so you want to have flexible
Services built for scale automation
secure and a large partner ecosystem and
having those five areas will really be
able to help demonstrate why you believe
that AWS and other Cloud providers but
AWS is 70 the leader in this space are
great for being able to provide support
for the role of devops so one of the
things that we want to be able to do
effectively when we're releasing any
kind of solution is to be able to
measure that solution and so kpis are
very important so you will be asked for
three important Dev of kpis and so three
that really come to mind that are very
effective the first one is mean time to
failure recovery and what this talks
about is what is the average time does
it take to recover from a failure and if
you have experience doing this then look
at the experience you have and use a
specific example where you were able to
demonstrate that mean time to failure
recovery the second is deployment
frequency and with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy Solutions and
what actually happens when you're
actually doing those deployments and
what does the impact to your network
look like when you do doing those
deployments and then the third one is
really tied to that deployment frequency
which is around what is the percentage
of failed deployments and so how many
times did you deploy to a server and
something happened where the server
itself failed what we're looking for
when you're going through and being
asked for these kpis is experience with
actually doing a devops deployment and
being able to understand what devops
looks like when you're pushing out your
infrastructure and then the second is
being able to validate that
self-auditing ability and one word of
caution is don't go in there and say
that you have a hundred percent success
the reality is that servers do degrade
over time and you maybe want to talk
about a time when a server did degrade
in your environment and use that as a
story for how you were able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
going to be asked to explain
infrastructure structure as code and
really it's it's something that actually
becomes a byproduct of the work you have
to do when you're actually putting
together your devops environment and
infrastructure's code really refers to
the writing of code to actually manage
your environment and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this series but you'll see
that XML or Ruby or yaml are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the physical
Hardware versus a traditional model
which is having software and installing
that software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
infrastructure as code is fundamental to
the foundation to infrastructure as
service and then finally allows you to
be able to talk about how you can use
scripted languages such as yaml to be
able to create a consistent experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into the next section
which is source code management and
we're going to focus specifically on git
the reason being is that get is really
the most popular source code management
solution right now there are other
Technologies out there but for the types
of distributed environments that we have
uh source code management with Git is
probably the most effective so the first
question you'll be asked when it comes
to get is to talk about the difference
between centralized and distributed
Version Control and if we look at the
way that the two are set up all the
Technologies such as older versions of
Team Foundation server though the
current version does actually have get
in it but older versions required a
centralized server for you to check in
and check out of code the developer in
the centralized system does not have all
the files for the application and if the
centralized server crashes then you
actually lose all of the history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code to a
server however for you to be effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code for
the solution directly onto your local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire solution
running on your local machine this
allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows for
scalability when it comes to building
out your team so if you have a team that
may be in Europe you can actually then
scale that team with people from Asia
from North America or South America very
easily and not have to worry about
whether or not they have the right code
of the wrong code and in addition to
that if the actual main server where
you're checking in your code does crash
it's not a big deal because you actually
have each person has a copy of the code
so as soon as the server comes back up
you have to check back in and
everybody's running back as if there was
nothing had happened at all so one of
the questions you'll be asked is to give
the answer to some of the commands you
use for working with Git so if you were
to be asked the question is what is the
git command that downloads any
repository from GitHub to your computer
on the screen you have four options we
have git push get Fork get clone and get
commit the answer in this instance would
be get clone now if you want to be able
to push code from your local system to a
GitHub repository using git then first
of all you want to be able to do is
connect the local repository to a remote
repository and in the example you may
want to talk about using the command get
remote ad origin and then the actual
path to get Hub repository you could if
you wanted to actually at this point
also talk about other repositories such
as get lab that you can also work with
or a private git repository that would
be used just for the development team
once you've actually then added the
local repository into your local
computer then the second action you want
to use is a push which is to actually
push your local files out to the master
environment so you use the command git
push origin master so one question you
may be asked is what is the difference
between a bear repository and a standard
way of initializing a git repository so
let's look through what is the standard
way so the standard way using get in it
allows you to create a working directory
using the command git in it and then the
folder that creates is the folder that
creates all the revision history related
to the work that you're doing in
contrast using the bear way you have a
different command for setting that up so
it would be git init Dash bear and it
does not contain any working or checked
out source files locally on your machine
in addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you'd have with
the normal get in its initialization so
which of the following CLI commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git RM get MV git RM Dash r or none
of the above well in this instance it
would be gate MV a question that you'll
be asked around commit is going to be
what is the process to revert a commit
that has already been pushed and made
public and there are two ways you can
address this the first is to actually
address the bad file in the new commit
and you can use the command git commit
Dash M and then put in a comment for why
that file is being removed the second is
to actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit ID and the commit ID and
it could be something such as
560e0938f but you'd have to find that
from the the commit that you had made
but that would allow you to revert any
bad files that you had submitted so the
two ways of being able to get files from
a git repository and you're going to be
asked to explain the difference between
git Fetch and get Paul so get fetch
allows you to fetch and download only
new data from a new repository it does
not integrate any of the new data into
your working files and it can be undone
at any time if you want to break out the
remote tracking branches in contrast get
pull updates the current head Branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server so you get all of the files and
downloaded it downloads new data and
integrates it with the current working
files you have on your system and it
tries to merge remote changes with your
local Wireless so one of the questions
you'll get asked about get is what is a
get stash so as a developer you'll be
working on the current Branch within a
solution but what happens if you come up
with an idea where it's something that
will take a different amount of time for
you to be able to complete but you don't
want to interrupt the mainline Branch so
what you can actually do is you can
actually create a branch that allows you
to start working on your own work
outside of the mainline branch and this
is called git stash it allows you to be
able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline Branch so you
once you start talking about branching
in git be prepared to answer and explain
the concept of branching so essentially
what it allows you to do is have a
Mainline Master branch that has all the
code that the team is checking in and
checking out against but allows you to
have an indefinite number of branches
that allows for new features to be built
in parallel to the mainline branch and
then at some point be reintroduced to
the mainline Branch to allow the team to
add in new features and so if we look
through the merge and get rebase these
are the two features that you'd be using
continuously to be able to talk about
how you take a branch and merge it back
into the mainline Branch so on the left
hand side we have get merge which allows
you to take the code that you're
creating and merge it back into the
master on the right hand side what you
have is a slightly different approach
and this is for projects where you reach
a point in a project where you go okay
we're going to effectively restart the
project at this point in time and we
want to ignore the complete history
that's happened before that and that's
called get rebase and that would allow
you to rewrite the project history by
creating a brand new Mainline branch
that ignores all other previous branches
that have happened before it you can if
you want to very quickly and easily find
out all the files that have been used to
make a particular commit so when
somebody asks you the question how do
you find a list of files that's been
changed in a particular commit you can
actually say that all you have to go is
find the command get div tree dash R and
then the hash that you would use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question that you'll be asked
when you're talking about merging files
is what is a merge conflict in git and
how can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have two more
branches that are competing with commits
in git and you have to be able to
determine which is the appropriate files
that need to be submitted and this is
where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you're going
to be able to show how that pull request
would be demonstrated inside of GitHub
So within the pull request there's going
to be a highlight of conflict markers
and you'll be able to select which
conflicts you want to keep and which you
want to merge and which ones you want to
change so with a step through how you
would actually resolve a merge conflict
and the first step would be under GitHub
you want to be able to pull the
repository name and then the pull
request around that repository in the
pull request list click the pull request
with a merge conflict and that you'd
like to be able to resolve they'll pull
up a file they'll list out all of the
conflicts for you near the bottom of
that file will be a list of the requests
that need to be resolved and then if you
need to make a decision on which
branches you want to keep or which ones
you want to change that will have to be
something you have to put in
instructions inside of the file you'll
actually see that there are conflict
markers within the instructions which
are going to ask you which files you
want to change which ones you want to
keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolved in GitHub so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then on to the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all the
conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into GitHub and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within GitHub so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use a get bash and so you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local git repository in
command line by using the CD change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file style guide.md
has a merge conflict in it and as before
with working with GitHub you actually go
through and use a text edit and use any
text editor but as you go through then
edit out what you want to keep and what
you want to manage in your conflict so
you actually have a resolution that's
been created so that you'll be able to
then once you you're using the conflict
markers you can actually merge your
files together so that the solution
itself will allow you to incorporate
your commits effectively into the
resolution once you've gone through and
applied your changes you're able to then
merge the conflicted commits into a
single commit and able to push that up
to your remote repository all right
let's talk about the next section which
is continuous integration with Jenkins
so the first question you'll be asked
about with Jenkins is explain a master
sleeve architecture of Jenkins so the
way that Jenkins is set up is that the
Jenkins Master will pull code from your
remote git repository such as GitHub and
we'll check that repository every time
there is a code commit it will
distribute the workload of that code and
the the tests that need to be applied to
that code to all of the Jenkins slaves
and then on requests the Jenkins master
and the slaves will then carry out all
the builds and tests to be able to
produce test reports the next question
you'll be asked is what is a Jenkins
file and simply put a Jenkins file as a
text file that has a definition of the
Jenkins Pipeline and is checked into a
source code repository and this really
allows for three distinct things to
happen one it allows for a code review
and iteration of the pipeline it permits
an audit Trail for that Pipeline and
also provides a single source of Truth
for the pipeline which can be viewed and
edited so which of the following
commands runs Jenkins from the command
line is it Java Dash jar jenkins.war
Java Dash War jenkins.jar Java dot dash
jar Jenkins jar Java Dash War
jenkins.war and the answer is a Java jar
jenkins.war so when working with Jenkins
you're going to be asked what are the
key Concepts and aspects of working with
a Jenkins Pipeline and you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the use-defined model of a CD
continuous delivery pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part of
that Jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells Jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire Pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to Define
dependency in Maven and do we have a
build.xml b palm.xml c dependency Dot
XML or D version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in Jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as
the domain-specific language for Jenkins
and there are one or more note blocks
that are used throughout the entire
Pipeline on the left hand side you can
actually see what the actual script
would look like and the right hand side
shows what the actual declaration for
each section of that script would be the
second type of Jenkins pipeline is a
declarative Pipeline and a decarative
pipeline provides a simple and a
friendly syntax to Define what the
pipeline should look like and then you
can actually at this point use an
example to actually break out how blocks
are used to define the work completed in
a decorative pipeline so how do you
create a copy and backup of Jenkins well
to create a backup periodically back up
Jenkins to your Jenkins home directory
and then create a copy of that directory
it's really as simple as that the
question you'll be asked as well is how
can you copy Jenkins from one server to
another well they're essentially there
are three ways to do that one is you can
move a job from one installation of
Jenkins to another by copying the
corresponding job directory the second
would be to create a copy of an existing
job directory and making a clone of that
job directory but with a different name
and the third is to rename an existing
job by renaming a directory so security
is fundamental to all the work that we
do within devops and Jenkins provides
the center core to all the work that
gets completed within a devops
environment there are three ways in
which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within Jenkins the three
responses you you want to be able to
provide is a Jenkins has his own
internal database that uses secured user
data from and user credentials B is you
can use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate Jenkins users or C you can
actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plugin within Jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot HPI plugin file into the Jenkins
home plugins sub directory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi dot pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
Jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off Jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to True which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to a false the security
will be disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time Jenkins
is restarted so what are the ways in
which a build can be scheduled and run
in Jenkins well there are four ways in
which you can identify the way a build
can be scheduled on Ryan Jenkins the
first is when source code management
commit new code into the repository you
can run Jenkins at that point the second
can be the after the completion of other
builds so maybe you have multiple builds
in your project that are dependent to
each other and when so many other builds
have been executed then you can have
Jenkins run you can schedule builds to
run at a specified time so you may have
nightly builds of your code that
illustrates the changes in the solution
you're building and then finally you
also can manually build a environment on
request occasionally you will want to
also restart Jenkins and so it's good
that when a question around how do you
restart Jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the Jenkins
URL that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the your or else your
Jenkins environment slash safe restart
so let's go into the fourth and final
section of this first video which talks
about continuous testing with selenium
so the first question you will be asked
most likely around selenium are what are
the four different selenium components
and again you will want to hold open
your fingers because there are four
distinct environments you have selenium
integrated development environment or
selenium IDE you have selenium remote
control or selenium RC you have selenium
Webdriver and then selenium grid you'll
be asked to explain each of those areas
in more detail but let's start off with
by looking at selenium driver what are
the different exceptions in selenium
Webdriver so it's useful to remember
that an exception is an event that
occurs during the execution of a program
that disrupts the normal flow of that
program's instructions and so we have 4
we have a timeout exception an element
not visible exception no such element
exception and a session not found
exception and each of those if we step
through them are the four different
types of exceptions that can be thrown
up when using the selenium Webdriver so
as we evolve in our digital world with
the different types of products that are
available for us to be able to build
Solutions onto multiple platforms you're
going to be asked can selenium and other
devops tools run in other environments
and so a good question around this is
cancellium test and application in an
Android web browser and the short answer
is absolutely yes it can we have to use
the Android driver for it to be able to
work so you want to be able to talk
about the three different types of
supported tests within selenium so when
the question comes up what are the
different test types supported by Salam
you can answer that and there are three
different types of tests first is a
functional test second is a regression
test and third is a load testing test
the functional test is a kind of Black
Box testing in which test cases are
based on a specific area or feature
within the software a regression test
helps you find any specific areas that
functional tests or non-functional areas
of the code wouldn't be able to detect
the load testing test allows you to
monitor the response of a solution as
you increase the volume of hits and how
you're using the code are put onto it an
additional question you'll be asked is
how can you get a text of a web element
using selenium well the get command is
due to retrieve tax of a specific web
element it's important to remember
however that the command does not return
any parameters but just returns a string
value so you want to be able to capture
that stream value and discuss about it a
question you'll be asked around selenium
is can you handle keyboard and mouse
actions using selenium and the answer is
yes you can but you have to make sure
that you're using the advanced user
interaction API and the advanced user
interaction API is something that can be
scripted into your test and it allows
you for capturing methods such as a
click and hold and drag and drop Mass
events and then keyboard down or
keyboard up key release events so that
if you want to to capture say the use of
control shift or a specific function
button of the keyboard you'd be able to
capture those of the following four
elements which of these elements is not
a web element method a get text B size C
get tag name d send keys and it's B size
you're going to be asked to explain what
is the difference for when we use find
element or find elements and so if we
look at find element find element finds
the first element in the current web
page that matches the specified locator
value in contrast find elements finds
all of the elements on the web page that
matches the specified value when using
Webdriver what are the driver close and
Driver quit commands and these are two
different methods used to close a web
browser session in selenium so driver
close will close the current web browser
which your focus is set and Driver quick
closes all the browser windows and ends
the web driver session completely the
final question that you are likely to be
asked in using selenium is how can you
submit a form using selenium well in
this instance that's relatively easy the
following lines of code will let you
submit a form in selenium which would be
web element El equals driver dot find
element and then you put in the ID and
the element ID and then L submit open
close parentheses semicolon so let's
just get into the first action which is
configuration management so one of the
questions that you'll get asked right
away is why do you have SSL certificates
used for Chef really fundamentally your
immediate answer should be security SSL
provides for a very high level of
private security and private and public
key pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using SSL and you're using the
private public key model within SSL
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that the chef that you'll
be able to validate that the nodes
within your network the chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked some questions such
as the following which is the following
commands which you use to stop or
disable the HTTP service when the system
boots and you'll typically get four
responses and there'll be hashtag system
CTL disable
httpd.service or is it system disable
http.service system disable httpd or the
final option which is systemctl disable
httpd.service your answer should be the
first one which is hashtag systemctl
disable
http.service so Chef comes with a series
of tools that allow it to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about is what
is Test Kitchen and Test Kitchen is
essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy it
to a real node so some of the commands
that you would use are for instance if
you want to create an instance of Test
Kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an instance after
you've created it you do kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge so a question you'll get is
around Chef is how does Chef apply
differ from Chef client has a
fundamentally the difference between
them is that Chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas Chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focus on the entire cookbook so there
are some differences when you're working
with different command lines so for
instance when you're working with
puppets and you're working with one
version of puppets and you want to do
what is the command to sign a requested
certificate the top example here is for
puppet version 2.7 whereas the lower
option here is for puppet version three
and that's something to bear in mind
when you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration can
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show you the Deep
knowledge that you have which open
source or Community tools do you use to
make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
Foundation of puppet itself and so the
three options you have is uh being able
to track configurations with jira which
you should be doing anyway but it's a
great way to be able to clearly
communicate the work that's been done
with puppet our Version Control can be
extended with get and then the changes
should be passed through Jenkins so the
three tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira Git and Jenkins so
what are the resources in public well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic units of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppets one other thing things that
you are likely to be asked regarding
puppet is what is a class and puppets
and so a class in public is really the
name blocks in your manifest that
contain the various configurations and
this can include Services files and
packages and we have on the screen here
example of what a class would look like
when you write it out and you may want
to memorize just one class don't
memorize just a whole set of classes
just memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
and particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
Playbook so exam example we have here on
the screen actually shows you one role
within a Playbook and in this role it is
to install Tomcat on a node again as
with a previous question within puppet
of a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as French
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within ansible and really
the answer comes down to two things one
is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this principle
value of and we have Foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of Foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to import an improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
rows to manage the tasks within the
Playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for Windows in contrast puppet is an
agent based installation it's written in
Ruby the configuration files are written
in DSL and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual Arc texture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture so let's get on to
our next section which is
containerization so let's go through and
you're going to be asked to explain what
the architecture of Docker is and Docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so Docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and then the
docker Daemon which is run as a rest API
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute Docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of Docker over a
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a Docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for Docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all Docker does contain an occupy Docker
containers occupy significantly less
space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
Docker is significantly faster than a VM
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single Docker image Docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation Docker data value games
can be shed and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your Arguments for Docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for Docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like Docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
Docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is Leverage The Power of
Docker swarm so darker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed so what are the
commands to create a Docker swarm and so
here we have an example of what a
manager node would look like and once
you've created a swarm on your manager
node you can now add working nodes to
that swarm and again when you're
stepping through this process be very
precise in the execution part that needs
to be taken to be able to effectively
create a swan so start with the manager
node and then you create a worker node
and then finally when a node is
initializes a manager node it can
immediately create a token and that
token is used for the worker nodes and
associating the IP address with the
worker nodes question 17 how to run
multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers as a single service by using
docker compose and Duck and compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yaml
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a Docker file so a
Docker file actually is used for
creating Docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can I
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like and again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things I really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
Whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the Whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as in architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a Docker file so we go through
and that we have a Docker file that
actually then goes ahead and creates the
docker image which then in turns creates
the docker container and then we are
able to push that out up to a Docker Hub
and then share that Docker Hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between Docker image
and Docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a Docker
container an image is built using a
Docker file and it stores that Docker
file in a Docker Repository or a Docker
Hub and and you can use Docker Hub as an
example and the image layer is a
read-only file system the docker
container is a collection of the runtime
instances of a Docker image and the
containers are created using Docker
images and they are stored in the docker
Daemon and every container is a layer is
a read write file system so you can't
replace the information you can only
append to it so while you can actually
use yaml or writing your so a question
you can be asked is instead of yaml what
can be an alternate file to build Docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use Json so if
you are comfortable working with Json
and my that is something that you should
be get comfortable with is you want to
be able to use that to name your files
and it's a frame reference Json is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a JavaScript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a Docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a MySQL Docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a Docker image or pull
from an existing Docker image from a
Docker repository or Hub and then you
want to be able to then use Docker to
create a new container which has my SQL
from the existing Docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image now below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the command
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have Docker registry
Is An Open Source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing Docker
images whereas in contrast for
repositories a collection of multiple
versions of a Docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between Docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the registry Docker also has
its own default registry called Docker
hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
Docker images it is stored in a Docker
registry and it has two tabs a public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own Enterprise registry so
you're going to be asked you know what
are the cloud platforms that support
Docker really you know lists them all
and we have listed here Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure Google Cloud
Rackspace but you could add in their IBM
bluemix you could put in Red Hat really
any of the cloud service providers out
there today do support Docker it's just
become an industry standard so what is
the purpose of Expose and publish
commands in Docker so if we go through
expose is an instruction used in Docker
file whereas publish is used in Docker
run command for expose it is used to
expose ports within a Docker Network
whereas with Publishers can be used out
side of a Docker environment for expose
it is a documenting instruction used at
the time of building an image and
running a container whereas with
published is used as to map a host port
to a running container port for expose
is the command used in Docker whereas
for publish we use the command Dash p
for when we're doing our command line
used in Docker and examples of these are
expose 8080 or with Docker we would put
in all for publish we would do the
example Docker run Dash Dash p and then
0.0.0.80 colon 80 as our command line so
let's look at continuous monitoring so
with continuous monitoring how does
nagos help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and service and so
this is really just a high level
question of using now yes within your
environment and you should be able to
just come back very quickly and say
negus allows you to help manage the
servers and check if they've been
sufficiently utilized and if there are
any task failures that need to be
addressed and so there are three areas
of utilization and risk that you want to
be able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with our web services and apis
that are reachable
so the second question you'll be asked
is how does nagos help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
services so it's able to do this by
having the initial negative process and
scheduler and the additional plugins
that you would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negia's web interface to be able to
run status checks on a predefined
schedule so what do you mean by nagis
remote plugin executor or the mpre of
Nag years so mpre allows you to execute
plugins on links Unix machines that
allow you to do additional monitoring
and machine metrics such as disk usage
CPU load Etc what are the ports used by
nagios for monitoring purposes in this
example there are three and they're easy
to remember so I would memorize these
three but they're essentially ports five
six six five six six seven and five six
six eight so the are two types of checks
within that year so you will be asked
for what is an active and passive check
in nagios so an active check and is
initiated by the nagios process and is
run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks uh results are submitted to
netgear's for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
90s Daemon now yes we'll execute a
plugin and pass information about what
needs to be checked plugin will then
check the operational state of the host
of servers and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and I guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negos may send out notifications log
alerts Etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in nag year so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how many years
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that's read by both
now used processor and the cgis so this
will allow you to be able to manage the
main configuration file that's placed
into your settings directory so what is
the netgears network analyzer and again
hold out your four fingers because there
are four options here so the nagias
network analyzer are one provides an
in-depth look at all your network
traffic source and security threats two
allows system admins together high level
information on the healthier Network
Three provides a central view of your
network traffic and bandwidth container
and then four allows you to proactive in
resolving outages abnormal behavior and
threats before they affect critical
business processes so what are the
benefits of HTTP and SSL certificate
monitorings with nag years so with HTTP
certificate monitoring it allows you to
have increased server and services and
application availability obviously very
important fast detection of network
outages and protocol failures and allows
web transaction and web service
performance monitoring the SSL
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
response to this the first thing you
should be able to talk about is how nice
itself can run on many different
virtualization platforms including
Microsoft Visual PC VMware Zen Amazon
ec2 et cetera Etc so just make sure you
get that right off the that and I guess
it was able to provide capabilities
tomorrow and so much of metrics on
different platforms it allows for ensure
for quick detection of service and
application failures and has the ability
to be able to monitor against many
metrics including CPU usage memory
networking and VM status so name the
three variables that affect recursion
inheritance in nagios and it is name use
and register so name is a template name
that can be referenced in other object
definitions use specifies the name of
the template object that you want to
inherit its properties and variables
from and register indicates whether or
not the object definition should be
registered to nagios and on the right
hand side of the screen we have an
example of what that script would look
like again you may want to be able to
memorize this as it's something that you
can actually write down and show someone
if you're going through a technical
interview so why is nagyo said to be
object or oriented and fundamentally
comes down to the object configuration
format that you can use in your object
definitions it allows you to inherit
properties from other object definitions
and this is typical object-oriented
development and is now applied for the
nagias environment so some of the
objects that you can inherit are
Services host commands and time periods
so finally explain what is State talking
in nagios and so there are really four
options here when you're talking about
State stalking so State stalking is used
for login purposes in nagios it allows
you to enable for a particular host or
service that nagos will watch over very
carefully it will log any changes it
sees in the output of the check results
and then finally it helps the analysis
of log files and so with that we come to
the end of this devops tools full course
if you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comment section below
so watch out for more interesting videos
like these until then keep learning and
stay tuned to Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
[Music]